vous avez vu les chiffres c'est
extraordinaire et bien on demande aux
Français de faire un effort
supplémentaire donc pour nous pas penser
non alors ce projet d'une bataille au
Parlement d'une bataille dans la rue
bien sûr tout le monde a les yeux fixé
sur les différentes de mardi 7 mars
Journée de blocage total a voulu par
exemple faire réagir au fait que Laurent
Berger était bien commence à vouloir
voir également des députés et leurs
opposés à la réforme se positionner
aussi sur le terrain politique je ne
sais pas dans quelles conditions de
cette rencontre éventuelle a été imaginé
je ne pense que c'est pas monsieur
berger t'as demandé la rencontre
Monsieur Pradier oui le groupe et l'air
d'assemblée beaucoup plus divisé que le
groupe lrtiste est bien tenu bien droite
il y a aucune surprise à voir
oui et qui pensent que en faisant reste
un peu de droite ici
Monsieur Macron a disparaîtra en terme
de d'avantage à qui non le grand gagnant
il faut lui dire et le redire donc comme
je viens de rencontre les autres gens à
la réforme moi ne me choque pas et on a
les contacts permanents avec leur berger
avec lui Martinez avec les autres
grandes amicales naturellement
simplement il peut y avoir une sorte de
consensus des gens de progrès et puis je
n'oublie pas que il y a des gaullistes
sociaux qui ont contribué compris à
l'avènement de la gauche au pouvoir et
je les respecte particulièrement
la façon dont se déroule les débats pour
l'instant la gauche prend largement la
parole il y a une espèce de gentleman
et vous le remarquerez nous pendant la
parole je pense l'activités avec fond il
n'y a pas de construction on est là dans
notre rôle finalement de défendre les
intérêts et donc pour répondre à votre
question et bien continuer à travailler
dans le même sens il y a pas de dire
qu'il aurait un accord de signer entre
les uns il y a un consensus au stade y
compris à droite pour dire mais il est
peut-être utile effectivement que
l'article 7 soit abordé
après en tout cas les Français je trouve
vraiment exprimé et je pensais on
s'exprimer lourdement ils vont dire
qu'il n'en veulent pas et je crois que
c'est bien que notre départ a lieu juste
après effectivement cette prise de
position de l'eau concitoyens
et bien que le gouvernement appelle un
bloqué ce qui pourrait être possible par
exemple en 2010 trouve voilà une façon
d'expédier à la fin des discussions
plusieurs moyens pour prendre cette
expression d'expédier donc de bâillonner
le position de moyenne pour le
gouvernement des moyens de règlement
général pour la droite sénatoriale nous
verrons bien quand je commence par le
passé quand même
nous résisterons puisque nous conférons
cette réforme est en mauvaise et bien
écoutez une réforme de style au final
c'est pas une bonne chose pour pour les
Français affaiblir cette réforme il faut
l'affaiblir et en plus la défaille sur
le plan constitutionnel donc si cette
réforme devait être voté du Conseil
d'État dont on a beaucoup parlé
globalement
du Conseil constitutionnel donc nous
verrons avec le Conseil constitutionnel
parce que nous aurons des recours
multiples en matière qu'elle sera son
avis donc le combat de commencer merci
beaucoup Patrick d'avoir répondu à ma
question
voilà pour cette interview enregistrée
il y a une heure environ alors les
débats ont commencé à reprendre dans les
mystiques Audrey un peu avant la
suspension les sénateurs ont commencé à
débattre de l'Arctique le premier bis un
article qui prévoit là encore un rapport
pour réfléchir à la mise en place d'un
système Universal des retraites et une
fois n'est pas coutume c'est un sujet
qui voit et bien gauche et droite
d'accord pour supprimer cette article
mais pour autant les débats risquent
d'être encore long 8e si j'ai bien
compté il reste encore une cinquantaine
d'amendements sur cet article premier
bises a raison de 2 minutes apparemment
en plus des éventuels autres prises de
parole le sujet devrait nous occuper
encore une bonne heure ensuite sauf
surprise les sénateurs de passer à
l'examen de l'article 2 l'article 2
c'est celui sur l'index senior est-ce
que vous l'Assemblée nationale la
supprimer mais comme elle n'a pas étudié
et voter le texte jusqu'au bout l'index
retour dans le texte que le gouvernement
soumet au Sénat il y a donc de l'enjeu
sur ce sujet parce qu'on va voir ce que
fait la chambre haute de cette index
seigneur
merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes ces
explications on espère effectivement que
vont débattre de cet article 2 dans
l'après-midi ou en début de soirée tout
de suite c'est bien on reprend la
direction de l'hémicycle vous l'avez dit
et bien il y a de très nombreux
amendements de suppressions qui sont
toutes nues notamment par la gauche pour
supprimer et bien ce rapport pour
réfléchir à la mise en place d'un
système universel des retraites un
amendement qui a été ajouté au contact à
l'initiative du début de naissance
proche d'Emmanuel Macron marque
vers le régime de retraite
merci on est passé directement à Madame
Monnier parce que il y a eu des il y
avait des absents qui s'étaient inscrits
mais qui n'était pas là après madame
Bonnier monsieur n'est pas là Monsieur
ministre mais chers collègues
introduction sur la future mise en œuvre
d'un système universel de retraite
intégrant qui plus les paramètres de la
réforme prévue par la présente-toi me
paraît tout bonnement un chronique donc
déjà exprimé leur refus massif en 2019
et 2020 on se souvient du chaos provoqué
par le déclenchement du 49-3 à la veille
du grand confinement vous ne pouvez pas
refaire le match par le russement de
texte ainsi la question de la méthode
que sur le
fondation de cet article 1 merci
merci
merci monsieur le Président en
amendement suppression de ces articles
d'abord parce que je me demande ce que
je viens de faire un rapport sur un
nouveau système de retraite dans un
projet de loi de finance rectificatif de
la sécurité sociale et je me demande
effectivement il n'y a pas de risque
en 2019 la réforme du système universel
de façon massive et je ne rappellerai
pas ici les grèves durs que marquer
cette nuit seul la crise covid a permis
de sauver le gouvernement il avait une
autre urgence et réelle celle-là et
voilà vous remettez l'ouvrage sur le
métier et que vous voulez nous imposer
très rapidement avec un rapport de 1 an
seulement votre retraite universelle
décidément vous êtes vous êtes très
attaché au système par répartition mais
vous faites tout pour faire disparaître
nous ne sommes pas d'accord oui
bien puisque créé par le CNR et nous
voulons connaître nos interventions de
nos intentions
merci Madame meunier n'est pas Madame
Bonnefoy non plus
la parole à Monsieur
monsieur
je m'interroge sur le sens finalement de
laisser dans un texte un amendement dans
nos savants déjà qu'il sera retoqué par
le Conseil constitutionnel puisque nous
conforme à la loi organique relative à
aux lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale deuxièmement je me demande
comment nous pouvons avoir confiance
finalement dans le Parlement et d'une
manière générale dans l'action politique
si nous fêtons déjà un rapport qui acte
le fait que la réforme qui est disputée
ne sera pas satisfaisante bon en tout
cas pour ceux qui n'ont pas posé et pour
ceux qui ont la voter nous ne pensons
pas quel est satisfaisante nous pensons
qu'il y a d'autres choses enfin puisque
c'est une réforme ce rapport demande de
revenir à la retraite La retraite de
grosses difficultés d'abord elle n'a
plus aucun caractère de distributif
puisque les fonctions sont strictement
fonctions du nombre de points accumulés
et donc pas de caractère et aucune
capacité de
ça sera encore pire après la réforme
puisque elle posera des conditions de
cotisation étage qui ont la situation
encore merci
monsieur
le Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur collègues finalement dans le
premier bises c'est pas c'est un article
anodin incolore exotique
non c'est un articlement politique et je
travaille pas sur le monde concernant la
retraite par point mais on dit
évidemment de Monsieur
grand
député Renaissance proche de du
président de la République excusez-moi
je crois que
Macron
de la République parce que ce n'était
pas dans le texte à plusieurs reprises
et on te le retrouve là dans la navette
alors que rien n'est obligé le
gouvernement a pouvoir le reprendre donc
l'apprenti sorcier les deux en même
temps on choisirait mais la question
que je voudrais
me répondre tout à l'heure c'est
pourquoi cet article
qui a une connotation manifestement
systémique
dans un prochain
paramétrer il y a quelque chose qui ne
marche pas il y a quelque chose qui ne
tourne pas c'est presque
qui nous est proposé en terme de
d'article 1 de ce projet alors je
connais tout à l'heure Franco que j'ai
qui n'est pas encore arrivé mais
attention un train pour quelqu'un
d'autre
j'ai l'impression que quand
la recette
et nous on est contre le corbillard
concernant la retraite
1er avis
merci Monsieur
la présidente Rossignol merci monsieur
le Président rapide parce que j'étais
déjà intervenu sur cet article premier
bus et que notre but n'est pas de
ralentir les travaux du Sénat pour
ralentir les travaux
je ne savais pas comment faire pour vous
faire plaisir en ce début de dimanche
après-midi et dimanche on est tous
ensemble c'est quel petit signe
pourrais-je envoyer à
et donc je n'aurais qu'une seule
question pourquoi parmi tous les
amendements qui ont été adopté
l'Assemblée nationale et que le
gouvernement n'a pas joué de tenir
pourquoi celui-là a subi un sort
différent bénéficier d'un sort différent
des autres pourquoi vous avez absolument
voulu le garder et j'imagine pas un
instant soit pour des raisons d'amitié
que ce soit voulu faire préciser au
présent de la République en conservant
un amendement de ses amis ce serait
vraiment indigne de la République et
jamais dans jamais dans votre façon de
présider les pays
merci chers collègues et donc le 2027
monsieur Dufour
merci
il prévoit effectivement la convergence
du régime après la population de la loi
effectivement
de leur capacité c'est la raison pour
laquelle le régime des avocats on est
particulièrement reposé à ce texte
d'ailleurs c'était pas été retenu
publiquement par la première ministre on
suppression de cet article
merci monsieur n'est pas là l'amendement
de des rapporteurs
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues
59 avant de suppression je pense que je
n'ai pas grand-chose à dire parce que je
pourrais être soupçonné d'être de l'anti
monnaie donc je m'arrête là et je dirais
que tout était
merci Madame espagnol
défendu
ensuite madame guidez
monsieur opère monsieur Moreau
la présidente
moi je vais juste simplement vous dire
que la confiance qu'on peut obtenir en
fait de l'ensemble des Français c'est de
ne pas changer de ligne tous les quatre
matins donc cette étude je suppose
qu'elle avait déjà été faite sur le
système le régime universel par point
elle revient là au détour de cette loi
je vous assure que ça ne peut pas donner
confiance et moi je voudrais juste
attirer votre attention sur la situation
des artistes auteurs que si jamais vous
commencez une étude de bien vouloir ne
pas oublier leur spécificité
merci
on suit madame
merci monsieur le Président alors moi je
crois qu'effectivement
ça place ici parce que c'est la
prochaine étape et cette étape là elle
est pas prête depuis
2019 elle est prête depuis 2017 en fait
de quoi il s'agit aujourd'hui nous
allons vous l'avez voté raboté tous les
régimes qui sont plus protecteurs nous
allons aggraver presque tout les
paramètres on l'a bien vu contre ça
effectivement pour faire passer la
brutalité de la réforme au rendra 3
milliards sur les 18 qu'on a cagnotté
mais surtout surtout
réforme bloque le paramètres de
l'augmentation des cotisations c'est pas
du tout hasard parce que il faut bloquer
ce paramètres parce que désormais et
vous le savez il faudra augmenter les
ressources
il faudra augmenter les cotisations mais
vous voulez pas que ça aille dans le
premier le deuxième étage de la fusée
vous voulez que ça dans le 3e et là pour
dans 3e il y a plus de problème
il y a plus de problème de compétitivité
mais il faut que c'est cotisations
nécessaires qui devraient être augmenté
dans le 3e étage ce que je veux dire
c'est que vous voulez faire exploser un
principe qui date et de gauche monsieur
le ministre qui dit de chacun selon ses
moyens à chacun selon ses besoins en
fait là quand vous avez au principe 1 €
doit donner le même nombre de points
tout ce que vous dites c'est que c'est
de chacun à selon ses moyens et à chacun
selon ses moyens toujours selon les
moyens et là aussi nous avons quelques
mesures d'atténuation vous donnerez
aussi de la des points gratuits c'est
gentil mais un peu dans la même
proportion de 18 c'est-à-dire 6e donc il
s'agit effectivement
c'est tout à fait cohérent que ça soit
là on bloque
les cotisations et après on demande
l'amendement de l'employeur la
défiscalisation et on demande aux
salariés devant la baisse des pensions
il y a qu'une solution c'est le 3e étage
et celui-là il est
merci ensuite le 4403
de notre système social c'est un bien
précieux de notre nation notre objectif
est de le préserver ce sont les mots de
la première ministre Élisabeth borne cet
article
ce que vous poursuivez comme une chimère
c'est la destruction profonde de notre
système de retraite et ça transformation
universelle qui serait évaluer chaque
année vous remettez sur le tapis un
projet dont personne ne veut un projet
qui va renforcer les inégalités que vous
avez contribuer à créer avec le report
de l'âge les gars de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans un projet
une réforme du haut du système de
retraite inédit depuis 1945 et destiné à
transformer pour les décennies à venir
un système social qui constitue l'une
des composantes du contrat social ce
sont les selon les mots du Conseil
d'État en 2019 un projet qui obligera à
travailler plus longtemps avec une
pension aller à toi en fonction d'une
valeur de poids
c'est une gestion individualisée des
retraites et les professions entre elles
vous en voulons pas un jeu de points et
cela a été largement démontré en 2019 ou
tous seront perdants les femmes la
majorité des 20 millions de salariés de
régime général les profils libéraux les
400000 agents des régimes spéciaux les 4
millions de fonctionnaires tous
européens un projet que nous qui nous
permettrait de bien vivre au travail
alors que nous voulons bien vieillir
libérer du travail profitez de ce temps
de la vie qui a pris un nom celui de la
retraite nous ne voulons pas de ce
rapport prémices d'une réforme qui
remonte du marché remettra encore le
principe de solidarité qui fait la force
de la protection sociale en France merci
merci
[Musique]
vous en avons fini avec la présentation
des
amendements de suppression bon la
commission a donné son avis puisque les
parties prenantes de ses amendements
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
des signataires sur tous les branches je
connais je précise
en terme de l'espérance de vie
mais cette intervention permettra
d'apporter peut-être de précision
d'abord pour dire à madame la Présidente
dans le cas de l'application de
l'article
gouvernement auquel nous avons inventé
la totalité il était peu nombreux la
totalité des amendements adoptés par
l'Assemblée nationale
tous les amendements adoptés par la
nationale ont été ajoutés au texte que
nous vous présentons
on va projeter initial du gouvernement
accompagner les amendements adoptés à la
chambre qu'il a examiné et que le
gouvernement souhaite conserver nous
avons constamment tous les amendements
qui habitaient la deuxième pression que
je voulais apporter avant de donner la
vie du gouvernement
c'est le fait que le système immunitaire
de retraite que nous avons présenté en
2019 n'était pas un système par
capitalisation je tiens
aussi à souligner que le fait de faire
un système à points clique pas
automatiquement mettre en place un
système capitalisation et j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que dans les souvenirs que
nous avons les uns les autres du système
universel de retraite proposant en 2019
une par considérable des cotisations
solidarité qui se traduisent ensuite par
l'octroi considéré comme gratuit mais
qui n'a rien gratuit puisque financé par
des cotisations consacrées au mécanisme
de solidarité
un système à points et un système par
répartition et la loi de 2019 malgré son
devenir pouvaient ainsi illustrer petit
concerne les amendements de suppression
je l'ai dit monsieur le Président
durable à la demande de rapport qui
avait été présenté par un certain nombre
de député de la majorité pour cette
seule raison je ne peux donner un avis
favorable alors suppression mais voyons
la liste des signataires je m'en remets
bien merci
alors explication de votre signal que je
suis saisi d'une demande de prudent
public
par les groupes CRCE et les groupes
socialistes donc nous allons passer aux
explications de vote alors madame
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
bien entendu me le Premier ministre moi
j'ai parlé de 3e étage qui sera l'étage
de capitalisation je t'ai jamais dit que
les deux premiers ne pouvaient pas
l'agir que la colle montre bien être
dans un régime de
oui alors moi je crois je voudrais
revenir sur le fait effectivement que la
grande différence quand même avec ces
deux de régime c'est que aujourd'hui
dans toute la protection sociale nous
avons alors souvent on dit c'est un
salaire différé moi je préfère dire que
la protection sociale au nom du principe
que je vous ai dit à chaque personne
c'est moyen et de chacun il y a chacun
son nom c'est besoin
le prélèvement de socialisé et le droit
ça ouvre à droite qui est différé et
dans toutes les branches
de la santé
parce que la santé vous voyez bien que
on s'intéresse pas au rendement on se
dit pas
autant pour que ça concerne pour pour
avoir un retour sur investissement et
c'est pareil pour tout et pour la
retraite c'est pareil aujourd'hui nous
payons pour les retraités
d'aujourd'hui effectivement on ouvre un
droit pour demain et ce qui empêche pas
de faire des réserves pour travailler à
long terme donc c'était un petit peu un
petit peu 5 je voudrais pointer le fait
que le 3e étage lui qui sera
effectivement très certainement par
capitalisation
puisqu'elle se verra comme
supplémentaire comme comme étage et bien
effectivement a besoin ma collègue la
vie du premier étage qui lui quand même
assure le respect de ce principe de
socialisation dont je t'ai parlé
merci la parole madame
on a beaucoup
on a beaucoup débattu du système à
points
quel que soit les formes qu'il prend le
système à points
structurels
probablement le français
puisque son niveau changeait
la raison de rappeler que Monsieur
Fillon constaté ces derniers on change
le point donc combien de retraite
troisièmement avec tout le monde dans un
système d'instabilité alors qu'on est
déjà dans un système social ou tout ce
qui protège garantit la sécurité permet
de voir loin et totalement déstabiliser
finalement déstabilisant l'ensemble du
pacte républicain et de la société
française
je voudrais surtout assister
je te l'incohérence de la position
gouvernementale
on nous dit dans un an on va remettre
sur le tapis les conditions d'un passage
vers une retraite à point
mais je ne demande pas simplement le
retrait de cette article c'est bien le
retrait de la réforme parce que
sur le tapis c'est pas la peine de
continuer à mettre des patients
avec les organisations syndicales prenez
vos responsabilités pour qu'on ait enfin
à politique avec les organisations
ça donne cette sentiment dramatique de
la stabilité chronique de notre système
de retraite qui ne fait perdre toute
confiance dans ce système et de national
alors non seulement retrait de cet
article mais Monsieur le Ministre soyez
cohérent retrait de la réforme
merci Madame Ferret
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement continue de
nous tromper de tromper les Français
après avoir fait le choix d'un véhicule
législatif inadapté à l'examen de la
forme aussi importante pour les français
plutôt qu'un projet de loi en tant que
tel le gouvernement sans le dire
introduit par ce nouvel article la mise
en œuvre d'un système universel de
retraite en proposant la remise des
rapports système rejeté massivement par
les Français rappelez-vous alors qu'il
n'y a compris qu'il faut pour préserver
notre système par répartition et
ainsiueilleusement vous préparer le
terrain pour demain alors
la vérité au français ne les trompez pas
ne les trouve pas
de gauche et on affirmant qu'il n'y aura
pas de perdant dites monsieur ministre
ce qu'il en est retiré cette réforme
merci monsieur
votre réponse pour être tout à fait
précis donc le texte
qui est arrivé au Sénat et l'initiale
gouvernement parce qu'il n'a pas été au
bout et vous l'avez dit avec les
artistes ou amendements que nous
souhaitons un moment pour être précis
que nous souhaitions
donc la maman de Monsieur
politique de le mettre parce que vous
auriez pu ne pas le mettre et donc c'est
un choix politique qui fasse même sur le
ministre de le conserver et que c'est ce
texte avec cet amendement premier piste
que vous avez expliqué
entre nous et donc si c'est un choix
politique assumé qui dit que
il va falloir revenir
vous ouvrez l'amendement ou toutes les
possibilités répartition aujourd'hui
qui est pas la même chose que
capitalisation ou capitalisation
individuelle ou collective donc vous
ouvrez toutes les possibilités y compris
la capitale
approche-toi au signaler dans les
conditions dans lesquelles nous voulons
avec une protection séance de l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales et de la
très grande majorité des Français
franchement au point de nous
pour que nous puissions à nouveau
avoir que vous reprenez les négociations
avec une nouvelle proposition la
retraite par point qui était celle de
2019 donc quand vous le redis il y a un
agenda caché vous ne voulez pas du
système par un partition vous avez
d'autres questions et retenu et en
réalité votre véritable
ambition je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci
Monsieur Jacquin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez vraiment pas
convaincu par vos explications
avec un caractère d'urgence les Français
ne peuvent rien y comprendre c'est
complet de cohérence quand vous revenez
avec le régime
universel qui a été rejeté facilement
par les Français lors du premier Macron
et qui est obligé le président de la
République à jouer
son texte de surcroît le 10 janvier
dernier on présente une nouvelle réforme
des retraites cette fois-ci paramétrique
la première ministre a signé le même la
reine définitive de la retraite mais
vous y revenez il n'y a donc pas lieu
d'agiter de nouveau le futur mise en
œuvre d'un système universel de retraite
intégrant qui plus est je cite les
paramètres de la réforme prévue par la
présente et franchement les Français ont
clairement exprimé qu'ils veulent aucune
aide non seulement le gouvernement de
rien entendre des centaines de 2 ans sur
la Bible de France
il leur dit en plus pour une réforme ils
vont en avoir deux c'est de la
provocation supprimer
la réforme et manifeste relativement ce
mardi devant le temps d'un cohérence le
rejet est considérable et de la cohésion
et l'adhésion seront dans la rue je vous
remercie merci Madame Monnier
la technique la technique
un compliment des éléments que j'ai déjà
évoqué précédemment je porte une
explication de votre demande 15-47 je
souhaitais appuyer dans cette
explication de votre l'impuissance du
pouvoir politique qui traduirait que
traduireait le maintien de cette demande
de rapport et en effet que cette réforme
complète et que le gouvernement doit une
fois de plus revoir sa copine
prochainement sur le sujet et jusqu'à
mes collègues je vois qu'on partage
nombre c'est inquiétude ce constat nous
sommes pas en réalité seulement sur ses
bains de partager puisque il me semble
que c'est aussi le cas du Conseil d'État
qui est très critique envers cette
réforme mais ce n'est pas ainsi que vous
communiquez depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois sur ce projet de réforme mise en
avant comme étant la bonne solution
d'une part pour sauvegarder le système
de répartition votre parc renforcer son
équité et voilà que l'on remettrai sur
les rails la préparation d'un système
universel de retraite se reposant sur
les recules sociaux déjà opérés par le
présente puisqu'il est bien préciser que
doit être intégré les paramètres la
réforme actuelle si vous souhaitiez
réellement prendre davantage compte en
compte les spécificités inhérentes à
chaque métier et à chaque parcours alors
il ne fallait pas supprimer les régimes
spéciaux adaptés à la réalité des
métiers qui les concernés il ne fallait
pas encore pénaliser les femmes par
cette réforme il fallait rétablir les
critères de pénibilité supprimer en 2017
par le gouvernement oui la copie doit
être revue mais alors allons jusqu'au
bout de la cohérence et doit-on pas être
réforme
merci monsieur
le Président je suis très frustré parce
que je ne peux pas demander la vie du
Conseil d'État sur cette amendement qui
a été réintroduit par le gouvernement
pour ce texte je voudrais
réinsister sur un sujet parce qu'on en
présente on passe du temps ensemble un
dimanche après-midi mais ce texte a-t-il
à faire dans un proche de loi de
finances rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale
rien à y faire et donc on revient sans
cesse outre le fait de l'incohérence de
recouvrir ce débat qui monte vous-même
savez que votre réforme est faite ni à
faire mais à chaque fois ça revient au
fait que votre choix de ce projet de loi
de finance rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale est une ruche procédurienne pour
éviter d'avoir un débat de fond sur le
travail sur les retraites donc monsieur
le ministre je vous dis retirer la
réforme évidemment de votre compas cette
article premier bises mais surtout
retourner devant les partenaires sociaux
parce qu'on ne peut pas imaginer une
réforme des retraites sans que les
partenaires sociaux ils soient associés
de façon réelle et continue donc si vous
voulez un an et bien prenez cette année
retirer la réforme et protéger cette
année de dialogue avec les partenaires
sociaux ils ont toujours prêt à défendre
les retraites des salariés
merci Madame
merci monsieur le Président
pourquoi nous allons voter pour les
amendements de suppression de cet
article il y a eu en 2019 la proposition
d'une réforme des retraites pour
instaurer un régime de retraite
universel à cette époque il y a eu la
publication d'une étude d'impact sur un
système de retraite universel
cette réforme a été abandonnée nous
avons maintenant quelque chose de tout à
fait différent qui est proposé dans la
précipitation vient un véhicule
législatif que nous considérons une
opportunité et on nous dit la majorité
on dit le gouvernement nous dit dans
cette même réforme que nous allons
réfléchir à faire un rapport pour
réfléchir à la raison que nous avons
abandonné il y a 2 ans alors il y a deux
solutions soit vous avouer en réalité
que le rapport que vous aviez eu que
vous aviez lu j'espère
publier en janvier 2020 était un sincère
un complexe insatisfaisant dès qu'elle
permettait pas au fond de savoir si le
système de retrait d'universel à point
était donc pas parce que à l'époque nous
disions soit vous reconnaissez que vous
les appelez cette information j'imagine
bien que si vous avez choisi cette
réforme là c'était basé quand même sur
les informations j'espère que c'était
basé sur des comparaisons entre les
différents systèmes il y a ce moment-là
vous avouer en réalité le fait de mettre
cet article dans cette réforme c'est
bien pour nous préparer une étape
suivante c'est bien pour nous dire que
ceci est que la première étape la mise
en place d'un système qui a déjà été
rejeté il y a quelques années donc nous
nous pensons que si vous êtes toujours
pas très clair ni avec vous-même ni avec
les Français et les Français la solution
la plus simple puisque apparemment vous
avez besoin d'un an pour savoir
exactement ce que vous voulez faire en
tout cas ce que vous voulez dire et bien
prenez cette année on n'est pas pressé
revenez à l'année prochaine et puis nous
verrons ce que je prends avec votre
proposition finale
merci Madame le louer
alors moi aussi je voterai pour les
amendements je suis pression de cet
article premier bises cet article 1er
Brice premier bus est hors sujet dans un
PLFSS rectificatif il prévoit que dans
un délai d'un an à compter de la
promulgation de cette présentation loi
vous nous demandez de prévoir que le
gouvernement remettre au Parlement un
rapport sur un la possibilité de les
conditions 3 le calendrier de mise en
œuvre d'un système universel de retraite
faisant converger les différents régimes
et intégrant les paramètres de réforme
prévus par la présence de loi alors le
président de la République nous demande
et demande aux Français de faire preuve
de bon sens alors le bon sens indique
que si ce rapport est utile il aurait dû
être réalisé avant que vous nous
présentiez les premiers éléments d'un
nouveau système de retraite il est donc
inutile
retirer cette réforme et retirer donc
cette demande dans la porte
merci monsieur
je vais m'y opposer avec avec mes
collègues il donne le service
de la de la panique au plus haut niveau
de la République en matière de de
retraite moi je confirme que cette
derrière la réforme qui nous est proposé
et qui fait l'objet centrale de ce texte
il y a la mise en œuvre de régime
interne par capitalisation absolument
certain
à quoi je voudrais
aussi ce que je voudrais aussi ok c'est
le climat dans lequel on est dans lequel
on est dans lequel sont les Français
depuis 2019
a été rappelé on dit ce qu'il pensait de
la de la réforme qu'il aurait été
proposé en 2019 ils sont toujours sur la
même ligne et là avec cet amendement en
gros on met le feu quoi on en rajoute on
en rajoute les théoriciens du management
de l'entreprise
il voit que entre autres techniques le
management par le chaos
voilà il y a des entreprises donc c'est
pas c'est pas les techniques durable le
temps mais qui utilise ce type de de
façon de faire mais pour passer un cap
voilà pour changer le paradisme je
trouve vous connaître typiquement
là-dedans le management par le chaos
voilà on provoque la population
française et j'espère je suis je suis
certaine elle sera nous dire mardi
prochain et les jours à venir les
semaines à venir les mois à venir
qu'elle ne veut ni avec forme qui nous
est proposé en premier ce texte ni de ce
qui est par le biais parce que l'article
appelant un rapport sur les régimes de
capitalisation même si on a plutôt à les
appeler les régimes systémique voilà
donc je propose fermement à cet article
qui a dit beaucoup d'esprit au plus haut
niveau de ce que notre pays ne la
République veut faire de nos retraites
et de la retraite des Français merci
Monsieur le compte
prépare une étude sur la faisabilité
d'un système universel des retraites
rappelle évidemment la réforme des
retraites avorté de 2019 que le
gouvernement a finalement retiré qui
avait donné lieu à 20 ans se
manifestation alors sur tout les bords
et surtout les bancs du canal et ne
comprennent pas pourquoi le gouvernement
a réintroduit cet article dans ce projet
de loi et Marie-Noëlle limon la
sénatrice attache à notamment fustiger
ce point du gouvernement
sur l'incohérence de la position
gouvernementale
on oublie dans un an on parle même sur
le tapis les conditions n'a pas de Sage
vers une retraite bon à quoi
mais je ne demande pas simplement le
retrait de cette article c'est bien le
retrait de la forme parce que
sur le tapis c'est pas la peine de
continuer à mettre le paysant
la Commission a dit être pour la
suppression de cet article Sénat de
suivre merci merci beaucoup
effectivement il n'y a pas beaucoup de
suspense sur liste de cet article qui
devrait être supprimé par le snap
puisque une fois n'est pas coutume la
droite et la gauche sont d'accord pour
supprimer cette article premier bis
notez toutefois que l'on pouvait penser
et très très bon sur cet article qu'on
avait vu une cinquantaine 60 ans de
suppressions qui devait être égrainer
beaucoup à gauche finalement renoncer à
prendre la parole donc il y a une petite
accélération et on peut donc espérer
bientôt débattre de l'article 2 à notre
article majeur celui qui porte sur
l'index Sen tout de suite on va prendre
la direction de la musique ou les
discussions se poursuivent sur cet
article premier Bitcoin
je crois qu'il faut dire il y a un
moment donné il faut le dire cette
proposition aujourd'hui qui est faite
dans la loi que l'on discute elle
prévoit d'accélérer la mise en place de
la réforme Touraine justement en 2027
Pluton qu'en 2035 donc et je t'en veux
demain que nos enfants nos
petits-enfants nous puissions avoir un
système de retraite où il y aura
certainement plus de retraités que
d'actifs il faut quand même que l'on est
des décisions à prendre alors je
voudrais aussi répéter que dans cette
assemblée il n'y a pas les méchants qui
méprisent les Français ce que j'ai
entendu ce matin il est bon sénateurs
qui eux sont vertus et du cœur pour
reprendre une citation d'un politique
extérieure auvergnat donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne doit pas s'empêcher
ça a été ce matin
prévoir et c'est aussi anticipé merci
parce que
oui merci monsieur le Président je tombe
à pic juste après cette belle
intervention
vous présenter d'ailleurs cette réforme
comme étant celle qui allait pas sauver
notre régime de retraite
ce qui est un peu inquiétant c'est
logiquement si ça se trouve le régime de
retraite alors pas besoin d'autre sinon
donc si on regarde vos stratégies en
plus vous n'utilisez toujours qu'un seul
paramètre de manière assez idéologique
qui nous amène à reculer dans le futur
finalement sans cesse là je l'égale de
départ à la retraite
dans deux ans vous nous proposerez 66
après 68 70 et on arrêtera plus puisque
vous le souhaitez agir que sur le
paramètre en plus le plus ingéniste
alors il y en a plein d'autres ça fait
deux jours qu'on vous expose mais vous
voulez rien entendre d'ailleurs ce qui
est d'autant plus inquiétant et qui
renforce cette impression c'est que vous
prenez toujours par exemple tous ceux
qui ont poussé le plus là je les garde
de départ la retraite c'est votre modèle
vous dites regardez dans les autres pays
ils font 67 mais avez-vous regardé dans
ces pays le taux de pauvreté chez les
retraités seulement vous l'avez pas vous
l'avez pas regardé d'ailleurs il y a un
bon exemple dans notre propre pays quand
on est passé de 60 à 62 ans ça a
augmenté les allocataires au RSA parmi
les personnes les plus âgées ça a
augmenté le nombre de chômeurs et de
chômeuses qui plus est avec la réforme
que vous avez fait monsieur dupes vous
allez encore plus les précariser parce
que leur droit au chômage va être donc
en fait c'est ça votre modèle bah oui
nous c'est pas le modèle que nous
défendons c'est pour ça que je vous
demanderons à nouveau de retirer cette
réforme injuste et
merci monsieur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre chers
un peu trop sur les braises
à un moment donné après
beaucoup avec ce cavalier législatif on
peut dire que vous allez avoir un
résultat immédiat ce que vous allez
doubler voir triplés le nombre de
manifestants pour la journée du Mardi 7
mars qui jouont sans doute les
prolongations sur le 9 et 10 mars nous
ne comprenons pas l'intérêt de cet
article dont vous connaissez maintenant
le la destination et votre
soutenir puisque
nous sommes déjà dans une conclusion
totale que je peux vous voulez
véritablement en terme d'origine mais
nous devions de plus en plus la cible
qui est la boîte et c'est vrai que à
terme la volonté de plus en plus
explicite c'est d'arriver à un régime de
retraite par capitalisation et je vous
disais déjà tel que nous l'avons affirmé
mais une image de façade nous sommes
dans la retraite à répartition il n'est
pas question de la retraite la
capitalisation et donc nous vous
demandons est-ce seulement de retirer
cet article mais plus que cela de
retirer votre réforme puisque elle n'est
pas abouti elle n'est pas réfléchie et
donc elle nécessite encore beaucoup
beaucoup de temps de travail je vous
remercie
merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre Michel
collègues
tente de faire revenir la réforme
avortée de 2019 par une porte d'Europe
nous ne sommes pas du tout le régime de
retraite à pointe et universel a été
massivement rejeté par les Français et
ils ne veulent pas tout comme il ne
veulent pas du produit social
représenter aujourd'hui dans cette
mystique
avec la présentation du texte que nous
examinons la première ministre a
pourtant signer la règlement définitive
de la retraite à pourquoi dès lors
revenir à l'achat avec cette demande de
rapport pourquoi
l'opposition des Français à ce qui est
un texte unique votre mépris à l'égard
de nos concitoyens vont jusqu'à
envisager l'idée de leur poser deux
réformes
qui ne veulent pas vous compter jusqu'à
ministre sur la latitude le renoncement
des Français empêché par l'inflation la
perte de pouvoir d'achat de ce mobiliser
les grèves des manifestations
historiques depuis le 19 janvier montre
pourtant le contraire il n'oublie pas
les Français que vous avez refusé
d'augmenter le SMIC et n'oublie pas que
vous avez fragilisé la Surate chômage
ils savent que vous ne dites pas la
vérité sur les retraites monsieur le
ministre écoutez la grande majorité
d'actifs qui vous demande le retrait de
ce texte restez sourd à leur
mobilisation démocratique serait nourrir
des lendemains de colère et de
ressentiment il ne se lasseront pas
jusqu'à l'abandon de cette réforme une
réforme qui est rejetée et vous le savez
par toutes les organisations syndicales
merci merci
merci monsieur le Président
de la Commission
à votre proposition de loi de gauche
alors comme vous l'avez constaté la
gauche de cette mystique refuse avec
énergie
argumenté et ne pas le texte
il ne peut pas non plus
monsieur le ministre écoutez les
partenaires
ici écoutez ceux qui sont dans la rue et
qui seront encore dans la rue le 7 et
ceux qui font peur
au moins elle n'a pas mis le pays à la
rue en occultant les partenaires sociaux
je vous remercie
merci Madame
moi je vais refaire un petit peu
d'histoire restante je l'ai déjà fait
pour répondre c'est pour répondre à mon
collègue la réforme pour elle à l'époque
si lointaine c'était 30 milliards
d'euros de déficity annoncé à courtes
elle a maintenu François Hollande avait
mis la retraite anticipée à 60 ans
quelques mois avant et la réforme
Touraine elle a maintenu les 60 ans et
62 ans
elle a maintenu les 62 ans alors d'aucun
me disent oui mais ça sert à rien
puisqu'il faut cotiser 43 ans et donc je
répète que tout le monde ne sait pas des
études supérieures qu'il y a des gens
qui commencent à travailler jeunes dans
ce pays et qui viennent nous ras
toujours et que ces gens ont le droit de
partir à la retraite à 60 ou à 72 ans la
réforme Touraine ça a été absolument pas
la même chose moi j'assume ce que je
suis j'assume ce que j'ai un moment
soutenu je ne veux pas laisser dire
n'importe quoi et en l'occurrence vous
avez dit n'importe quoi
monsieur
oui merci monsieur le Président je te le
ministre mais
je viens relire encore cette partie 1er
c'est annoncé
et pas très respectueux du Parlement le
ministre donc vous avez parlé de la
sagesse du Sénat moi je vous appelle la
sagesse retirer retirer cet article et
c'est fini pourquoi
on va pas vous donner un nom de plus et
y compris sous l'impulsion de votre
collègue quand même c'est Monsieur
Ferracci qui était rapporte chômage
c'est à dire qu'on discute de travailler
les travailleurs les travailleurs de
l'année de plus et on prend un article
qui vient d'un député qui a rapporté sur
la loi d'assurance chômage qu'à moduler
les conditions de l'accès de
l'indemnisation quand on n'a pas de
travail donc la question c'est un moment
c'est quoi
c'est les retraites mais c'est aussi le
travail d'une nouvelle précarité d'une
nouvelle flexibilité d'une nouvelle
chasse à des gens qui sont privés
d'emploi donc franchement on va pas vous
donner un nom de plus pour ça et je vous
dis il y a une question de respect moi
je pense je vous le dis là quel que soit
nos divergences etc mais quand il y a
l'unanimité ici pour retirer l'article
la sagesse peut aussi être du côté du
gouvernement pas d'opération politique
pas d'opération politique tienne donc
retirer cet article c'est pas il y a pas
de honte à le faire voilà il fait
l'unanimité contre donc retirer le et là
on débat dans des bonnes conditions mon
débat pas avec quasiment un fusil dans
le dos en nous disant ça va être 64 ans
ça va être deux années de plus ça va
être en plus et attendez ici non on va
encore aggraver sur les mêmes conditions
la réforme retirer le monsieur le
ministre ça sera votre honneur et celui
de votre gouvernement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
[Musique]
suppression de cet article puisque le
gouvernement souhaite passer par un
rapport pour annoncer sa vraie réforme
un système universel après une première
tentative en 2019 alors que nous sommes
censés discuter d'une réforme de la
retraite par répartition il pose
légèrement pour le coup d'après et sans
aucune garantie de concertation de
négociation de dialogue social avec les
partenaires sociaux bien curieuse
méthode que de dire aux Français que la
réforme de discutons aujourd'hui et qui
conduit les Français dans la rue pour
prier leur opposition et bien que cette
réforme n'est pas celle que l'on veut
vraiment faire c'est vrai le pire n'est
jamais certain
et si je sors de cette article semble
heureusement télé monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez faire mieux en retirant
purement et simplement cette réforme
ajuster inutile
merci le président rénal
merci
monsieur le président
cette
réforme des retraites vous avez été
présenté où vous avez été présenté je
m'en souviens avec combien de qualité
sous le terme de la mer de toutes les
réformes la mer
c'est pas bien la mère de toutes les
réformes
de rassurer nos jeunes sur le devenir de
la retraite par cette partition alors
après cette demi-journée aujourd'hui on
est où et puis
finalement deux propositions
la première c'est de dire bon écoutez on
a fait ça mais c'est important c'est
demain d'introduire
de la capitale
et là à l'instant nous sommes sur plutôt
revenir au projet de retraite
alors moi je vous pose la question
de cette mère des réformes qu'en est-il
entre deux idées totalement finalement
séparé totalement divergente et qui font
que finalement ce que vous appelez tous
la mer de toutes les réformes ce n'est
jamais que le plus petit commun des
nominateurs entre les forces droites de
notre émission
merci monsieur
en écoutant l'ensemble au collège je me
pose deux questions je dois être un
petit peu naïf et je me demande pourquoi
quand on présente un rendement on a
besoin de revenir pour ce combat
de voter première question deuxième
question
c'est une question c'est une question
si c'est pas ça la réponse à ma question
c'est que vous considérez que les
adversaires ceux qui sont en face de
vous et qui pense pour une fois la même
chose que vous non
pour nous voilà ce que je voulais dire
donc maintenant j'aimerais qu'on passe
au vote parce que je pense qu'il est
aujourd'hui
merci Monsieur
évidemment
nous allons passer au vote nous allons
passer au vote sur
[Musique]
cette donc sur ces amendements de
suppression je vous rappelle que je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrute en public
par les groupes
et socialistes avec un avis favorable de
la commission et un avis défavorable du
gouvernement il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
le scrutin
est ouvert
voilà les sénateurs maintenant voter par
un scrutin public sur sa partie le
premier bus en cet article qui prévoit
la mise en place d'un rapport pour
réfléchir à la mise en place d'un
système universel vous l'avez entendu à
droite comme à gauche cette mesure qui
finit du député
contre elle il n'y a donc pas beaucoup
de suspense a priori les sénateurs
devraient et bien rejeter cette cette
mesure cet article 1er bisque qui a fait
son apparition entre la
d'Emmanuel Macron tout simplement
puisque marc est un proche d'Emmanuel
Macron Olivier dites-lui a répondu que
et bien tous les amendements qui avaient
été adoptés à l'Assemblée nationale
avait été conservée par le gouvernement
dans le texte qui le présente au Sénat
voilà le Clos on va entendre le résultat
343 exprimé 293 pour
292 contre 1 le Sénat à adopté les
amendements de suppression
donc les amendements les amendements qui
nous restent exactement
à votre contrat et 2080 12 pour cet
amendements de suppression qui a vu et
bien la droite et la gauche sur cette
mesure on reprend toute l'année
l'amendement 31 08
alors
question à donner
une situation anormale en effet
l'article 14 de la loi du 26 juillet
à disposition relative
des applications dans la constitution et
la liquidation du droit de la pension de
retraite des enseignants ces allocations
prévues ne sont jamais n'ont jamais été
publié alors l'obligation de prendre une
résidence réglementaire d'application de
la loi est une compétence du
gouvernement et l'administration est
tenue de prendre dans un délai
raisonnable on y est les dispositions
réglementaires étant donné le débat
étant donné la situation que nous
évoquerons aujourd'hui nous souhaitons
entendre monsieur le ministre ce point
important et donc l'occasion de porter
cet amendement sur le rapport pour
l'occasion de nous donner votre position
merci Madame la rapporte
la Commission demande la vie du
gouvernement pour régler cette vieille
affaire
le ministre excusez-moi monsieur
problématique il y a longtemps comme
vous pouvez le constater
dans mon esprit
politique des années 80
Notre-Dame
il s'est traduit par la création par des
questions d'entraînement à destination
des candidats
la première année de formation à l'IFM
et cet engagement a été prolongé par
Laurent
avec 14 la loi du 26 juillet 91
et qui prévoit cette période de
perception allocations
fixées par des constitution des pensions
des années 80
en réalité 18 au fil des ans et cela
tout simplement jamais été présente
compte et jamais été publié je rejoins
sur le fait que ce n'est pas
satisfaisant je vous invite auprès de
l'amendement pour une raison
particulière de 1991 est toujours en
vigueur et votre commandement propose de
supprimer ta mention fixée par des
studio votre raisonnement le
gouvernement ne pourrait plus prendre de
l'écrire et ne pourrai pas
la correction que nous pouvons apporter
passe par un décret mais une difficulté
très matérielle très concrète qui fait
que les étudiants inscrits en
préparation en première année comment la
période couverte par la bonne 291 sont
en réalité des enseignants qui
aujourd'hui
sont prêtes soit dans une situation
à la retraite donc il faut qu'on trouve
quelque chose à moyen pour le valoriser
je ne sais pas le dire à l'instant je
vous parle sur un chantier
la réalité des choses que nous devons
ouvrir mais pour l'ouvrir il nous faut
un véhicule législatif permettant de
prendre le décret nous la demande
merci
j'ai les bandes de prise de parole
madame la
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues en effet depuis 1991
certains agents titulaires sont
pénalisés lors de la constitution leur
dossier de retraite par l'absence de
publication de ce décret et certains
d'entre eux découvrent que leur première
année à l'IFM en tant qu'allocataire ne
peut être validé pour la liquidation de
l'endroit attention alors monsieur le
ministre vous indiquait que vous
découvrez ce problème à l'occasion de
cette réforme je crois que le ministre
de l'éducation nationale a été saisie en
19 en 2017 pardon d'une question écrite
d'un parlementaire
à laquelle il avait répondu en 2021
2017-2021 le ministre de l'éducation
nationale indiqué un examen terme
ministériel du dispositif avec le
ministère chargé des publics de la
fonction publique et le secret chargé
des retraites était engagé à pas
d'identifier les évolutions à apporter
de la terre de nature législative ou
réglementaire pour répondre à cette
situation visiblement quand même le
dossier c'est perdu puisque le
gouvernement le connaissait depuis
plusieurs années suite à l'acétine de
parlementaire et je m'étonne que rien
n'a été fait rien de passer donc c'est
pour cela que nous soutenons cette
amendement pour réparer cette injustice
je vais retirer mon regard de la
présentation du ministre en sachant que
les cas alors la recherche de solution
le message entendu
simplement et donc je retire
l'abonnement
et retirer donc
pardon non mais l'amendement est retiré
pardon
vous reprenez l'amendement
est repris par Madame Patrick
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre oui c'est un beau geste de
Madame Florence
nous avions avec elle et Jacques Bernard
manier demander des rapports respectifs
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat Audrey on a
entendu plusieurs fois de la gauche
prendre la parole dans l'hémicycle et
notamment mettre la pression sur la
droite en parlant de la grande journée
de mobilisation et grande journée de
blocage qui s'annonce celle du 7 mars de
toute façon de mettre la pression oui
peut-être que notre téléspectateurs
longtemps dû au fur et à mesure que les
prises de parole s'enchaînent il y a un
point qui revient de plus en plus
souvent la grande journée de
mobilisation du 7 après demain donc les
socialistes victoires jardin ou encore
Serge mériou lancer au gouvernement
le premier disque discussion il allait
mettre les Français dans la rue ce n'est
pas un autre temps à l'approche de
l'échéance la gauche fait monter la
pression une manière de
mais ça va ça va permettre de me donner
mon avis de la vie tout simplement
madame rossignol
un instant je vous donne la parole enfin
le Président vous redonnera la parole
pardon comme j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
un peu d'émotion au moment madame
Laprise compta a dit qu'elle reprenait
l'amendement que je vois que le ministre
qui n'a jamais été sénateur mais qui
connaît certainement mieux règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale que celui du Sénat
est aussi un peu perplexe
c'était un hommage aux députés qu'il a
été franchement pour une fois j'essaye
d'être gentil vous pourriez être
soutenant
comme la Présidente
[Musique]
je vais vous lire monsieur le ministre
je vais vous dire l'article 46 6 un
amendement retiré par son auteur après
que sa discussion a commencé peut-être
immédiatement repris par un sénateur qui
ne n'était pas signataire la discussion
se poursuit à partir du point où elle
était parvenue donc Madame Bertrix
comptin reprend l'amendement vers toute
cet article du règlement du Sénat
donc je donne la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre à Monsieur le Ministre
mais merci monsieur le Président mais
madame voilà nous interrompons les deux
bas car je suis avec le président du
groupe LR au Sénat Bruno retaille au
bonjour bonjour à vous un mot déjà sur
le fait qu'Olivier du soft à qualifié
cette réforme dans Le Parisien
Aujourd'hui de réforme de gauche c'est
une réforme que vous soutenez est-ce que
vous nous faites votre coming out de
gauche aujourd'hui comme il y a de
gauche je pense d'abord que le régime de
retraite paraît partition il n'est ni de
droite ni de gauche il était inventé au
sortir de la Seconde Guerre pour réduire
la pauvreté des anciens de nos aînés et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui si moi je me
bats pour la réforme c'est pour sauver
pour faire en sorte notamment que pour
les jeunes générations il y a pas de
retraite à payer la leur et puis la
nôtre en même temps donc je crois que
dans cette réforme en tout cas au Sénat
on va s'attacher à y mettre des
marqueurs de droite que ce soit sur la
politique familiale que ce soit sur un
certain nombre de choses par exemple la
lutte contre la fraude comme l'article 2
on va y venir dans quelques instants non
je pense que c'est une réforme qui
enrichit avec le Sénat doit être une
réforme qui doit être soutenue et tout à
l'heure également l'adoption d'un
amendement qui prévoit de réfléchir à
introduire une dose de capitalisation
dans notre système par répartition ça
aussi c'est un marqueur de la droite
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il va bien
pouvoir rester dans le texte final je ne
sais pas mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que nous sommes d'abord et je le redis
la droite est pour la retraite par
répartition parce que tout simplement
nous croyons au lien intergénérationnel
qui permet de matérialiser de
concrétiser que nous sommes dépendants
des uns des autres qu'il y a un lien
entre nous au-delà du temps au-delà des
générations ça c'est la première chose
en revanche comme la retraite par
répartition est un est une
pardon un régime avec une dimension
démographique il faut impérativement
assurer le renouvellement des règles
générations ce qui n'est pas le cas donc
la retraite par capitalisation viendrait
enrichir on aurait finalement j'ai
utilisé de substituer l'un à l'autre non
je pense que si on doit arriver un jour
à la capitalisation elle peut être
solidaire mais il y aura d'abord le
premier étage de la fusée c'est la
répartition le second étage le deuxième
étage c'est la retraite à points agir
Carco la complémentaire et il y aurait
un troisième étage qui serait une
capitalisation solidaire pour ne pas
désavantager ceux qui n'ont pas de
moyens un mot sur le fait qu'Aurélien
Pradier il est députés LR qui sont
opposés à la réforme vont voir mercredi
Laurent Berger est-ce que pour vous
Aurélien sera dit encore sa place chez
elle
non mais il a comment dirais j'étais
débarqué de l'équipe dirigeante et de
son poste de numéro 2 par eriki et il a
bien fait mais
qu'il voit ce qu'il veut voir les
syndicalistes et les autres voilà ça me
gêne pas et en plus j'en ai marre mais
il peut rester sa carte je peux pas
commenter et passer mon temps à
commenter tous les faits les agissements
de tous nos sénateurs de tous nos
députés de tous nos élus locaux j'y
perdrai mon temps je crois non on va
parler de cet article 2 que le Sénat
s'apprête à discuter c'est cet article
sur l'index seniors la droite veut en
profiter pour instaurer un CDI senior
avec une exonération de cotisation
famille pour ce type de contrat est-ce
que vous avez chiffré cette mesure
c'est une mesure difficile à chiffrer
puisque je peux vous dire c'est que
c'est une mesure qui rapportera de
l'argent le gouvernement fait une
mauvaise approche du gouvernement de
nous dire cette mesure elle est terrible
elle va coûter 800 millions d'euros
cette mesure elle consiste je le
rappelle à remettre en situation
d'emploi des seigneurs qui sont au
chômage parce qu'on a un problème en
France on a un des taux les plus bas de
l'emploi du taux d'emploi des seniors
après 60 ans et comment repousse de deux
ans il faut impérativement avoir des
leviers pour remettre les seniors dans
l'emploi pour les garder dans l'emploi
et gouvernement nous propose un index
une statistique donc c'est pas
satisfaisant simplement ce que je veux
dire c'est que 1 le fameux coup du
gouvernement 800 millions est faux
puisque ça voudrait dire que tous les
seniors
viennent aujourd'hui bénéficier de cette
mesure ce qui serait sans doute pas le
cas mais surtout surtout c'est que nous
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on active des
dépenses sociales passives des
indemnisations de chômage et on les
active pour que les gens rentrent dans
l'emploi et ça rapporte à chaque fois
que vous faites
seniors en emploi ça rapporte un
milliard dans les caisses de l'État donc
la mesure non seulement elle est pas
négative en termes budgétaire elle est
positive Bruno Retailleau merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à mes questions on va
tout de suite rejoindre l'hémicycle car
vous ne l'aviez dit un petit peu il y
avait une émotion une procédure une
suspension possible au début de cette
article 2 un problème soulevé par la
gauche et pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe et bien nous allons tout de
suite rejoindre Audrey buttaz qui nous
attend dans l'hémicycle merci Bruno
Retailleau oui Tam il vient d'avoir une
motion de renvoi ça veut dire que les
sénateurs qui l'ont déposé demande à ce
que cet article soit renvoyé en
commission pour être étudié l'article de
Tom je vous le rappelle c'est celui sur
l'index senior c'est loin l'un des
points névralgiques de la réforme je
rappelle aussi qu'il a été rejeté par
l'Assemblée nationale mais comme
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas examiné le
texte jusqu'au bout il son retour dans
le texte transmis par le gouvernement au
Sénat la mesure prévoit d'obliger les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés à
publier le taux d'emploi des seniors la
majorité sénatoriale a fait des
propositions elle aimerait que l'on
passe de 50 à 300 employés parce qu'elle
estime que 50 c'est trop peu elle veut
aussi mettre en place un CDI senior qui
serait exonéré de certaines cotisations
oui tout de suite et bien on va aller
voir exactement comment se passe les
discussions en séance tout de suite on
prend la direction de l'hémicycle il y a
une motion des recevabilité que nous
avons rejeté on a un peu dans la même
veine et dans le même esprit donc voilà
pourquoi je donne un avis contre et puis
je voulais aussi préciser que le renvoi
en commission moi je veux bien mais
lorsqu'on a fait la commission mardi
dernier on a passé deux heures en
commission et il y a eu très peu de
prise de parole mais ce que je n'en vous
reproche pas nous disons on se réserve
pour le débat alors si on se réserve
pour le débat et on a vu en effet que
vous vous réserviez pour le débat ça
c'est indéniable on a bien remarqué je
vois pas l'intérêt tu as renvoi en
commission c'est donc un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
mais ma vie pour le gouvernement donc il
y a la possibilité d'une explication de
votre part groupe est-ce que certains
souhaitent madame ponce allez-y
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
pour mon groupe moi je vais je vais
soutenir cette demande de renvoi et pour
une raison bien précise parce que je
souhaite qu'on rediscute des amendements
que la commission a jugé il recevable
sur l'index des seniors alors qu'on est
en plein paradoxe parce que le
gouvernement laisse l'index cela tout en
te tenant compte lui qui a pris
connaissance de la vie je dis bien de la
vie du Conseil d'État qu'il risque
peut-être supprimer donc il le maintient
c'est normal parce que
c'est censé atténuer non pas atténué
mais là avoir une obligation une petite
demande une petite contrainte envers les
employeurs alors il aimerait bien
laisser cette illusion qui demande
quelque chose aux employeurs bien
pourquoi pas mais moi ce que je vois
c'est que beaucoup d'amendements ayant
très à l'index ont été non pas refusé
c'était des demandes de rapport sous
prétexte que c'était l'article 40 tout
ça mais quand même indirectement parce
que il semblerait que c'est pas de lien
direct ou indirects j'ai bien compris
avec la réforme donc il faut savoir si
l'index est maintenu pour donner ce
semblant
de demander quelque chose aux employeurs
et on en reparlera ou s'il n'a pas lieu
d'être là et que déjà on va le discuter
alors que le Conseil constitutionnel
risque de le retirer dans ce cas là il
faut peut-être revisiter
la décision sur plusieurs amendements
demandant des rapports la décision donc
de les juger y recevable comme étant
paraît-il sans lien immédiat direct ou
indirect avec la réforme merci Madame
Lubin
rien de surprenant à ce que je vous dise
qu'effectivement nous soutenons cette
demande de renvoi en commission puisque
c'est la nôtre
mais parce que nous estimons bon alors
on aura l'occasion on a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur cette index des
seniors et sur la forme et sur le fond
mais nous estimons effectivement que
cette réforme des retraites ne prend
absolument pas en compte la situation
des seniors qu'elle n'a que nous n'avons
aucune étude chiffrée qui nous permet à
part quelques approximations de temps en
temps qui nous permet de savoir quelle
sera la situation des seniors après
c'est ces deux années supplémentaires
de de travail de chômage pour certains
enfin bref donc nous nous considérons
que même si nous avons eu une réunion de
commission effectivement mais à la
limite ça n'est ça n'est presque pas ça
que nous remettons en question c'est les
éléments dont la commission aux
républiciers pour travailler j'estimons
que nous n'en avez pas eu suffisamment
dans ce projet de réforme des retraites
et puis bon même en arrêtant de
gamberger sur cette fameuse note dont
nous aimerions avoir connaissance
il nous en a été parlé à l'Assemblée
nationale nous savons à peu près ce
qu'il y a dedans et nous savons que ce
cet article 2 va certainement être
intimement est un cavalier législatif et
donc nous allons y passer beaucoup de
temps dessus pourquoi au final et
peut-être juste pour le vote d'un projet
de loi qui abîme rat considérablement la
situation des seniors
merci Monsieur Savoldelli
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mais mes chers collègues
nous soutenons la motion en renvoie en
commission de l'article 2 relatif à
l'index senior qui est déposé par le
groupe socialiste en effet le
gouvernement met en place un index pour
les entreprises depuis 300 salariés avec
pour seul obligation j'irai dire
l'unique obligation c'est la publication
de ce dernier et une sanction pouvant
aller jusqu'à 1% de la masse salariale
le cas échéant faut savoir que cette
rédaction là je vais retrouver texto
dans les affirmations et les volontés ça
va étonner personne du hop des grandes
entreprises et pour pas le nommer c'est
le Medef
donc sans contrainte c'est index n'aura
aucun pouvoir de contrainte alors que
les trajectoires entre l'emploi et la
retraite ne sont pas linéaires tout le
monde le sait ici en effet nous pouvons
ignorer qu'à 60 ans près d'une personne
sur trois n'est ni en emploi ni en
retraite
et que la majorité d'entre elles sont en
situation des fois malheureusement
d'invalidité de RSA ou de chômage les
tous dans une grande précarité ainsi
nous dénonçons cet allongement du ce
qu'on peut appeler le sas de précurité
des seniors qui aura des conséquences
désastreuses pour trop de personnes et
puis je voudrais faire aussi un petit
revenir un petit peu en arrière j'espère
que ça nous rassemblera unean ici parce
que l'expérience la preuve du pudding
c'est qu'on le mange c'est qu'à l'instar
il y a eu un index égalité homme-femme
rappelez-vous il a été créé en 2018 et
bah c'est index il n'a pas favorisé
l'application de la loi sur l'égalité
salariale donc on a aussi l'expérience
pour nous
et si on pouvait l'avoir communément ça
serait bien d'avoir cette expérience
pour nous un index ne fait pas les
changements que la société doit opérer
donc ça a été vrai pour l'égalité
salariale homme-femme il faut que ça
soit pareil pour les seniors c'est pour
ça tout le bon sens de cette de cette
renvoi en la motion en commission et
puis tout le travail d'amendement de
l'ensemble des parlementaires que nous
sommes merci merci il n'y a pas d'autres
groupes qui ont demandé la parole donc
nous allons passer au vote sur cette
notion de renvoi donc qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstore
elle n'est pas adoptée
donc nous allons attaquer la discussion
et les paroles sur article à propos de
l'article 2 et
voilà un dessinateur ont donc rejeté
cette motion de renvoi aux commissions
qui étaient demandées par les
socialistes sur l'article 2 de ce projet
de loi l'article 2 c'est celui qui porte
sur l'index senior cette notion de
procédure vise et bien à dire que l'on
ne peut pas et bien débattre de ce texte
dans l'hémicycle c'est une motion de
procédure qui avait été déjà utilisée
sur l'ensemble du texte un jeudi premier
jour de débat mais cette fois-ci et bien
les sénateurs socialistes pendant
qu'utilisés sur un seul artiste un seul
article l'article 2 ça a été plutôt une
péripétie parce que vous l'avez vu après
des prises de parole des différents
groupes et bien les sénateurs ont
finalement rejeté et bien cette notion
de renvoi en commission tout de suite et
bien on prend la direction des débats
c'est René Paul ça va rien rapporteur de
la branche vieillesse qui s'exprime à
présent sur cet article 2 un article
très important qui partent sur l'index
seniors
et qu'il ait été plus judicieux de
prendre en compte cette tranche de vie
avant de passer à un projet définitif de
retraite c'est ce qui nous a animé à
travers nos réflexions pour vous faire
des propositions d'ailleurs ça déjà été
pris en compte par des gouvernements
précédents puisque nous sommes face à
une augmentation de la durée nécessaire
de cotisations 43 ans qui a été voté il
y a quelques années sous le gouvernement
Hollande et qui fait que on est amené
effectivement à travailler beaucoup plus
longtemps donc il faut prendre en compte
ceux qui peuvent être
usés à travers cette longévité que l'on
admet bien volontiers dans l'emploi
c'est la raison pour laquelle il nous a
semblé important de bâtir dès à présent
bien que ce soit une loi retraite une
politique vis-à-vis de l'emploi des
seniors qu'on pourra appeler monsieur le
ministre
un seigneur une solution il y avait le
plan un jeune une solution car manquer
et marquer une ambition justement de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une une
dimension collective pour la prise en
compte des emplois des jeunes et ben là
nous souhaitons une dimension collective
pour la prise en compte des seniors
trois volets il y a les seigneurs qui
sont au chômage les Seigneur qui sont en
emploi et puis ceux qui voudraient un
peu une période transitoire en ce qui
concerne les seniors au chômage nous
proposons un nouveau CDI le CDI senior
nous aurons l'occasion d'un article un
article suivant d'en parler en ce qui
concerne les seniors en emploi nous
proposons des dispositifs qui permettent
à la fois d'être plus généreux sur les
pensions notamment pour ces mères de
famille dont vous nous avez dit toutes
les difficultés rencontrées autour de
leur carrière c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons une surcote et
nous proposons aussi d'autres
dispositifs la retraite progressive des
60 ans et puis également que le temps
partiel dans le cadre du C2P qui donne
cette possibilité nous le réservions
pour la fin de carrière de façon à
aménager prendre en compte les
difficultés des seniors et pour que le
côté des employeurs il y a aussi une
certaine attractivité et bien nous avons
développé les positions de mutualisation
de la prise en compte sur les
cotisations ATMP pour que ce soit pas le
dernier employeur qui paye la note pour
l'usure de notre salarié qui aurait que
eu connu différentes
emplois et d'autre part nous avons pensé
qu'il fallait dissuader cette rupture
conventionnelle de deux trois ans avant
le départ à la retraite est un consensus
social où tout le monde s'y retrouve ma
foi le salarié en lui dit voilà peut y
avoir une fin de carrière en passant par
la case chômage avant la retraite et
puis l'employeur qui il voit
effectivement quelques indemnités sans
qu'il y ait une taxation suffisante donc
nous avons souhaité augmenter la
taxation 30% de la rupture
conventionnelle ça une réflexion
d'ailleurs qui qui venait de l'Assemblée
nationale qui nous a
qui nous a paru pertinente voilà un
petit peu le dispositif qui va être
décliné lors des différents articles en
ce qui concerne l'index aussi Niort
l'index le Seigneur s'est effectivement
quelque chose je dois vous le dire je
suis pas un grand fan de l'index au
senior il s'agit de faire une une
photographie a publié un certain moment
ça veut dire que une entreprise qui a
beaucoup de seniors c'est pas pour
autant qu'elle aime les seniors c'est
parce que au fil du temps il en est
assis elle a des seniors elle aura un
très bon index puis quand il suffira de
remplacer ces personnes on va embaucher
des jeunes l'index va se dégrader à
contrario une entreprise qui a beaucoup
de jeunes parce que c'est une entreprise
de technologie de biotechnologie madame
la Présidente et bien ces entreprises là
elles ont que des jeunes pourquoi parce
que les compétences ne sont pas
retrouvées forcément à travers des
seniors sont plus volontiers des
compétences plus récentes et qu'il n'y a
que des jeunes qu'il les possèdent donc
elle va avoir un mauvais index senior
néanmoins néanmoins nous avons convenu
que il fallait effectivement lancer ce
plan senior et convaincre les
entreprises c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons accepté de reprendre
ce dispositif index senior mais en le
mettant à 300 salariés et non pas des 50
salariés pourquoi parce que 300 salariés
c'est le seuil où il y a ces discussions
au niveau de l'entreprise pour la
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
c'est là que l'on peut définir une
politique des Sen et faire en sorte
qu'elle soit clairement déclinée pour
être éventuellement reprises dans le
cadre des index voilà ce qui nous a
animé dans notre réflexion et que je
souhaitais vous présenter
merci monsieur le rapporteur donc nous
allons passer aux paroles sur article
puis nous examinerons d'abord tous les
amendements de suppression puis ensuite
le reste des amendements sur cet article
2 donc les paroles sur article et je
passe tout de suite la parole à Madame
Cathy apource
merci monsieur le Président nous n'avons
pas proposé de supprimer cet article
bien évidemment que l'index des seniors
tels qui nous est proposé est à l'heure
c'est une facétie du gouvernement pour
faire croire que vous parlez du travail
et du ciel des seniors nous aurions voté
plutôt contre deux fois qu'une mais
voyez-vous nous avions l'espoir d'en
faire un outil réellement contraignant
au service de l'emploi des seniors nous
proposions une réécriture intégrale de
cet article cet amendement est
irrecevable écoutez le motif c'est assez
drôle cet amendement qui concerne le
droit du travail et l'emploi des seniors
et ne prévoit pas d'affectation de la
pénibilité à la sécurité sociale n'a pas
d'effet sur les recettes des régimes
obligatoires de base de la sécurité pour
2023 il est donc irrecevable en
application de l'article L au
111-3-12 du code de la sécurité sociale
donc nous créons
nous créons une
pénalité financière de 10% des
rémunérations et gains pour les
entreprises de plus de 5000 salariés qui
ne respectent pas les critères de
l'index que nous fixons nous ajoutons
des pénabilis
[Musique]
moins importantes pour les entreprises
moins avec moi de salariés nous en
faisons un véritable outil au service
des seniors dont l'impact budgétaire je
veux vous dire que c'était autre chose
que la maigre sanction facultative si
enfin peut-être les entreprises ne
daignent même pas publier le fameux
index senior et ça aurait été une
incidence financière si c'est même
entreprise ne le respectent pas c'est le
régime 0 sanction il est impératif d'en
faire un outil au service des
entreprises incitatives nous reviendrons
sur le dévoiement du sens de ce terme
dans le débat public pardonnez-moi mais
le Conseil d'État dont nous attendons
toujours la note qui vous a été
transmise monsieur Savary et que vous
allez vous faire
un plaisir de nous remettre disez
l'index Seigneur était un cavalier
social car sans incidence budgétaire
merci Madame pour ce poly la parole est
à notre collègue Monique Lubin
cet article va nous permettre
un débat sur
l'index d'emploi des seniors mais avant
de rentrer dans le vif du sujet il faut
parler de la forme mais il faut parler
du fond
sur la forme
sur la forme le gouvernement s'est
pertinemment que dans une loi de finance
de la sécurité sociale rectificative on
ne peut pas parler d'autre chose que de
mesures budgétaires et donc on ne peut
pas
valablement discuter de la situation des
seniors et surtout mettre en place de
véritables mesures en faveur des seniors
ce qui est proposé
dans cette dans cet article relève du
gadget et encore le mot est modéré
sur le fond le gouvernement
ignore-t-il la situation des 10 seniors
alors on va en discuter on aura le temps
Seigneur c'est à quel âge 50 ans 55 ans
pour certaines entreprises c'est même 45
ans mais allez on va dire que la
situation écrite à partir de 55 ans et
très tendu à partir de 50 ans donc
gouvernement
ignorait-il cela le gouvernement
s'est-il que de très nombreux seniors
après 55 ans ne retrouve pas d'emploi et
se retrouve après une vie de labeur dans
la spirale du chômage des fins de droit
des minima sociaux et attend la retraite
avec impatience pour pouvoir enfin avoir
une un revenu qui leur assure un minimum
de dignité et ça n'est certainement pas
à travers de ce projet de loi que les
choses vont s'améliorer alors nous nous
proposerons la supp ression non pas je
vais terminer Monsieur le Président que
nous n'ayons pas confiance aux
rapporteur parce que je le dis je le
connais la volonté du rapporteur de
traiter ces sujets là et son attachement
à ces sujets là mais nous ne pouvons pas
cautionner ce que le gouvernement nous
propose
et la parole est à notre collègue Fabien
gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Richard collègue pour ma part
je considère que l'index est aussi utile
qu'un numéro vert pour lutter contre la
canicule l'été dernier c'est à dire nul
et non avenu
d'ailleurs
c'est index il la redire mon collègue
Pascal s'envole des lits il sera pas
contraignant
on ne sait pas ce qu'il y aura parce
qu'il y aura par décret seulement
peut-être le nombre de seniors dans
l'entreprise et sur les questions de
formation même l'index
d'égalité salariale femme homme qui est
déjà pas assez contraignant il propose
qui est quand même une sanction si des
mesures correctives ne sont pas faits là
vous allez même pas vers là seuls les
entreprises
qui ne l'auront pas publié se verront
infligés une amende qui sera évidemment
extrêmement faible moi je pense qu'on
aurait se poser deux questions la
première c'est comment conserver les
seniors au-delà 55 ans en âge de partir
à l'entraide qui sont au travail parce
que plus de 40 % n'atteignent déjà pas
les 62 ans et les entreprises au-delà de
55 ans les pousses dehors donc quelle
mesure concrète vous nous proposez pour
conserver des seniors
au travail il va falloir bien qu'on
débattre de ça parce que c'est pas
l'index qui poussera les entreprises à
les conserver puis la deuxième c'est un
chiffre c'est l'adresse qui nous le
donne
1,4 millions de personnes
âgées de 53 69 ans ne perçoivent ni
pension de retraite ni revenus
d'activité oui c'est dans l'humanité
spéciale retraite
très bon numéro d'ailleurs si vous
l'avez pas vous pouvez le prendre là et
là le recul de 62 à 64 ans
n'agira pas sur ces 1,4 millions ces
personnes-là continueront à être sans
ressources et sans emploi donc qu'est-ce
que concrètement vous allez faire sur
ces questions là je vous remercie merci
Monsieur
la parole à la présidente Eliane
assassin oui merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
lors de la discussion générale vous avez
affirmé que cette réforme allait
mécaniquement monter le taux d'emploi
des personnes en fin de carrière alors
pourtant France stratégie et j'ai les
documents ici France stratégie nous
rappelle que je cite l'effet des règles
du système de retraite sur l'emploi des
seniors et loin d'être mécanique même
des règles coercitifs tels que le
relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits se heurte à l'hétérogénéité des
situations de fin de carrière fin de
ne permettra pas et nous le savons tous
de remédier aux représentations
négatives qui sont liées à l'âge l'âge
constitue je dirais avec le sexe avec
les origines des individus parmi les
premiers motifs déclarés des expériences
de discrimination et au travail l'autre
fait que vous n'y est c'est quand même
un fait important c'est l'état de santé
toujours selon France stratégie plus de
la moitié des personnes prématurément
sorties de l'emploi impute leur décision
à des problèmes de santé un chiffre à
prendre je crois très au sérieux dans un
contexte de quasi stagnation de
l'espérance de vie sans incapacité à 50
ans depuis le début des années 2000
concrètement la taxe senior ne remettra
pas en cause des pratiques délétères par
exemple ce qu'on appelle le harcèlement
moral démissionnaire qui consiste à
dégrader les conditions de travail d'un
salarié pour provoquer son départ à
moindre coût la mise au placard dans les
entreprises concernerait 200 000
salariés écouteraient écoutez-moi bien
10 milliards d'euros par an bref vous
avez la prétention je vous cite de poser
les bases d'une nouvelle société du
travail rien de moins mais je crois que
c'est surtout une société du travail qui
ressemble plus à un grand retour en
arrière plus qu'à une véritable
nouveauté
merci notre collègue maintenant voilà
nous interrompons quelques instants les
débats car je suis avec Laurence
Rossignol bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vice-présidente du Sénas sénatrice
socialiste de l'Oise un mot tout d'abord
ce qui s'est sur ce qui s'est passé
avant et bien l'examen de cet article 2
une motion de renvoi en commission
prévue par le groupe socialiste elle n'a
pas été adoptée ce n'était pas une
surprise mais lorsque vous avez entendu
la droite dire et bien votre bébé
objectif il est de ralentir les débats
pour les ralentir parce que c'était pas
le cas quand même avec cette motion de
renvoi en commission écoutez dans ce
débat notre objectif est clair
nous ne voulons pas Nick ce projet de
loi soit adopté ni qu'il soit mis en
oeuvre et c'est pas un caprice de
l'opposition sanatoriale c'est parce que
nous pensons que nous sommes légitimes
de par le mouvement social les enquêtes
de pignons cette française sur 10 sont
opposés à cette réforme en particulier
au recul d'âge et il y a un mouvement
social mardi il y en a eu de nombreux
depuis le début janvier nous sommes là
pour traduire ce mouvement social dans
l'hémicycle vous savez on a un
gouvernement qui a décidé de passer en
force il est passé en force contre
l'assemblée et il espère avec l'appui de
la droite sénatoriale
réussir au Sénat ce qui n'a pas réussi à
l'assembler donc nous avons un règlement
parfois se règlement du Sénat il est
défavorable aux oppositions souvent il
peut être nous conduire à renoncer à nos
exprimer et puis parfois le règlement du
Sénat nous permet effectivement de nous
exprimer mais vous savez dans le débat
qui se tient depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant nous sommes toujours sur le
sujet de Fond la réforme des retraites
le contenu de cette réforme souligné on
n'est pas dans l'invective on n'est pas
dans l'obstruction telle que elle a été
menée à l'Assemblée nationale non mais
moi je passe enfin mon sujet n'est pas
le comparatif de benchmarket les vertus
de l'Assemblée nationale contre celle du
Sénat ou réciproquement c'est pas pareil
quand même c'est pas la même temps
plus feutrés c'est plus courtois même si
c'est une opposition frontale c'est une
opposition frontale à l'Assemblée il y a
aussi des débats courtois et sur le
travail qui a fait effet à l'Assemblée
il faut quand même respecter qu'un
certain nombre de supercheries de la
réforme ont été mises à jour grâce au
travail des députés à l'Assemblée
nationale donc moi je suis pas en
compétition avec l'Assemblée nationale
je pense qu'on poursuit le travail
qu'ils ont fait avec la spécificité du
Sénat effectivement et une habitude de
débat un peu différente vous avez
mentionné bien sûr ce mouvement social
que l'on attend pour le 7 mars et
l'enjeu aussi est bien c'est de pouvoir
calibrer vos débats pour que cet article
7 cet article majeur de la réforme sur
le report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans soit débattu
après les manifestations qu'est-ce que
c'est l'enjeu côté quelque chose qui est
rapport dans les sondages depuis le
début de ce mouvement c'est que il y a
autant de français quasiment qui disent
qu'ils sont aussi à la réforme presque
autant disques par ailleurs il pense
qu'elle va finir par être adoptée
c'est-à-dire une forme de fatalité
effectivement et il y a aussi le fait
que les Français n'ont pas confiance
dans leur propre pouvoir de mobilisation
ça c'est ce que le gouvernement
imprime c'est ce dont il veut les
convaincre que de toute façon il a
changé le gouvernement lâchera jamais
que les gens peuvent descendre dans la
rue se mettent en grève faire tout ce
qu'ils veulent le gouvernement ne
bougera pas moi je crois que ce que l'on
fait aussi au Sénat et avec ce
calendrier effectivement que vous
évoquez et nous ne voulons pas que
l'article 7 soit examiné avant le
mouvement social du 7 mars c'est pour
donner confiance aux mouvements social
pour les envoyer vous vous êtes dans la
vous vous êtes en grève nous nous sommes
au Sénat et nous sommes coordonnés et
vous pouvez obtenir ce que vous voulez
on peut obtenir ensemble l'abandon et le
retrait de cette réforme ensemble nous
pouvons y arriver moi je vous redonner
confiance aux gens qui sont mobilisés
dans leur capacité à gagner vous y
croyez même si et bien on le sait la
droite sénatoriale est favorable à cette
réforme presque elle en assume la
paternité et bon bien sûr et bien elle
est majoritaire ici au Sénat elle a un
certain nombre d'armes qu'elle va
pouvoir utiliser pour accélérer les
procédures bien sûr la majorité
sanatoriale a des armes qu'elle peut
utiliser le gouvernement aussi en avait
à l'Assemblée n'est pas tout utilisé
n'est pas dit que la majorité centrale
puisse utiliser toutes les siennes non
plus et moi j'intériorise pas les armes
du règlement nous nous avons des
convictions vous savez il y a une
armurerie exceptionnelle dans les dans
les armoires du gouvernement ou des
majorités parlementaires et si au Sénat
pour
gagner sur les oppositions
cette nous on a nos convictions notre
capacité d'expression et notre sérieux
de notre travail à opposé à toute cette
armurerie nous userons totalement de
tout ce que nous avons pour faire échec
à cette réforme merci merci beaucoup
Laurence Rossignol d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et tout de suite on reprend et
bien la direction de l'hémicycle où il
me semble que c'est Marie-Noëlle linman
qui s'explique qui s'exprime
actuellement sur donc cet article de
avec la mise en place de cette index
senior avant la date légale de départ en
retraite
et par ailleurs il faut savoir que dès à
présent la zone grise des salariés
seniors qui sont mis en employés en
retraite et considérable
16,7% des personnes de 62 ans en 2021
était dans cette zone
3% étaient au chômage
13,7 en acte d'une activité ou au RSA
si la réforme de 2010 que nous dit en
allongeant la durée de pour pouvoir
passer légalement en retraite ça va
inciter ça va allonger et améliorer
l'emploi du senior alors on a déjà le
bilan de la réforme 2010
la réforme 2010 qui a fixé à 62 ans le
départ n'a fait gagner que 20 points
d'activité pour le Seigneur 20 points et
par contre à augmenter considérablement
la fameuse zone grise des salariés en
question
ça n'a pas été une amélioration de
l'emploi du seniors ça a été une
détérioration de la situation massive
des seniors qui sont dans cette zone
grise évidemment c'est très inégalitaire
c'est très inégalitaire parce que le
nombre d'ouvriers en zone grise a
pendant ce temps là lui augmentait de
16%
et en 2019 à 61 ans il y a plus de
seniors qui sont dans la zone grise que
de seniors qui sont en emploi
c'est donc on voit bien qu'on est en
train de changer structurellement les
dernières années de la vie des seniors
avant conclure l'endroit à la retraite
alors on aura le temps de poursuivre
l'argumentaire mais l'indice seniora
côté tout ça c'est évidemment absolument
l'impuissance merci la parole à notre
collègue Daniel brouiller merci monsieur
le Président une fois de plus je vais
revenir sur ce véhicule législatif
choisi qui est proprement scandaleux et
dont je regrette que les protestations
dans la majorité sénatoriale sur ce
véhicule ne soit pas plus nombreuse nous
allons donc discuter d'un indice d'un
index senior dont l'avis du Conseil
d'État que nous n'avons pas dit qu'il
est manifestement inconstitutionnel moi
je fais une totale confiance aux
rapporteur Savary qui sur ce sujet a un
désir de travailler et d'amélioration de
la situation je suis surpris parfois par
les propos puisqu'il dit nous avons
accepté les indices comme chez au fond
la loi avait été dilée et déjà négocié
avant de venir dans l'hémicycle mais je
suis certain que c'est exactement le
genre de sujet qui mérite un débat dans
notre assemblée et qui mérite de trouver
des solutions parce que garder
l'expertise des seniors dans
l'entreprise est un enjeu pour notre
pays et parce que garder des conditions
de rémunération d'emplois de qualité de
travail et de santé au travail est un
enjeu pour tous les salariés concernés
donc voilà un beau sujet manque de
chance nous sommes dans un projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale et
donc ce débat qui mériterait d'être mené
nous allons le mener à partir de cet
article 2 mais vous avez évacué les
amendements que un très bien présenté
Cathy a pourchaud notre collègue et qui
traitait justement de cette question des
seniors au travail avec une vision
alternative c'est dire à quel point le
détournement de procédure auquel vous
vous livrez malmaine la possibilité d'un
véritable débat sur le fond du travail
et je le redis ça n'est pas acceptable
enfin puisqu'il me reste plus que
environ 3 secondes et que je veux pas
dépasser je vais vous dire que cette
indique senior ça a été dit par d'autres
il y a déjà un indice de l'égalité femme
homme qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il y a 8%
des cas de rémunération entre les femmes
et les sommes mais cet indice senior moi
je vais vous le dire pour moi c'est
l'indique l'indice qu'est 9-3/4 d'Harry
Potter à King Cross il suffit de
traverser le mur vous arrivez et puis
d'un seul coup ça va aller mieux non il
y a beaucoup d'illusions je pense qu'il
faut travailler avec les partenaires
sociaux pour améliorer le travail des
seniors merci chers collègues la parole
à Jean-Yves Leconte
voilà les prises de parole se succèdent
autour de cet article 2 un autre temps
fort de ce projet de loi Audrey puisque
cet article 2 c'est celui qui met en
place l'index senior oui c'est un
article le névralgique dans un texte qui
prévoit de faire travailler les Français
plus longtemps et quand on sait par
exemple Tam qu'un tiers des Français à
61 ans sont inactifs faute de trouver un
emploi alors en commission des affaires
sociales les sénateurs ont émis
plusieurs propositions il souhaite créer
un CDI senior qui serait exonéré de
certaines charges pour inciter les
employeurs à employer justement des
seniors il voudrait aussi que cette
index soit imposé aux entreprises à
partir de 300 salariés et non 50 comme
le voudrait le gouvernement 50 c'est
trop contraignant estime les sénateurs
de la commission des affaires sociales
merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes
ces explications alors que et bien les
prises de parole se poursuivent sur cet
article 2 et sont prévus ensuite et bien
de très nombreuses amendements de
suppression une cinquantaine
d'amendements de suppression qui ont été
déposées par la gauche sur cette index
senior tout de suite donc on prend la
direction des débats dans l'émission
et les allocations d'invalidité tout
cela certaines estimations les montent
après de 5 milliards d'euros donc plus
du quart des économies entre guillemets
envisagées par la réforme alors Monsieur
le Ministre pouvez-vous nous donner une
estimation sérieuse de la situation à
taux d'emploi des seniors constants du
coup de ce report de 62 à 64 ans pour
l'ensemble des autres prestations
sociales enfin bien entendu cette
publication c'est juste une publication
c'est-à-dire que finalement cet article
ne prévoit rien pour répondre aux
problèmes simplement une obligation
d'information qui finalement ne changera
rien s'il n'y a pas d'autres politiques
qui sont développées et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je voulais saluer les
l'intervention préalable de notre
rapporteur merci
la parole à Corinne ferait
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en matière
d'emploi des seniors les statistiques
nationales officielles sont là pour en
attester le taux d'emploi des 60 64 ans
et seulement de
35,5%. en repoussant de en repoussant de
deux ans là je légale de départ en
retraite on va augmenter d'OTAN la durée
de chômage d'une grande partie des
travailleurs âgés qui sont à la
recherche d'emploi tout en réduisant
encore davantage leurs droits à retraite
quand ils seront en âge du prétendre le
gouvernement se garde bien aussi
d'évoquer les coûts cachés de sa réforme
paramétrique une étude de l'inédit qui
était publiée cette semaine portant sur
les liens entre assurance chômage et
système de retraite depuis la réforme de
2010 confirme un pic de rupture
conventionnelle trois ans avant l'âge
légal de tes parents à la retraite se
faisant les dépenses d'indemnisation
chômage des plus de 55 ans ont augmenté
de 38% depuis 2010 et sont passés de 4,8
milliards d'euros au moment de la
Réforme à 6,7 milliards en 2022 des
montants qui devraient nous éclairer sur
les stratégies des entreprises pour se
préparer à leur pour se séparer pardon
de leur salarié les plus âgés et sur
l'impact de la prochaine réforme tantôt
recette qu'en dépense dans ce contexte
on voit mal comment créer un index
senior pour valoriser je cite les bonnes
pratiques en matière d'emploi des
seniors comment donc c'est un excédent
pourrait avoir le moindre impact sans
sanction c'est un texte n'aura aucun
pouvoir de contraintes sur pour les
entreprises au final les seniors sans
emploi non encore à la retraite n'auront
pas d'autre choix que de tourner de se
tourner vers d'autres filets de sécurité
revenus de solidarité active allocation
chômage ou invalidité
merci la parole à Marie Harley de
Carlotti merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues le
gouvernement jure qu'il veut prendre à
bras le corps le problème du chômage des
seniors mais nous constatons une fois de
plus que vous nous faites encore de
fausses promesses monsieur le ministre
la moitié des salariés ont déjà perdu
leur emploi lorsqu'ils prennent leur
retraite sans salaire sans retraite les
conséquences sont désastreuses pour
beaucoup certains sont pris en charge
par d'autres filets de sécurité RSA
location chômage ou invalidité mais pour
tous absolument tous c'est la précarité
face cela à votre réponse est
extrêmement décevante vous proposez de
créer un index senior fin de carrière
pour valoriser les bonnes pratiques une
mesure qui se limite pour les
entreprises à publier des indicateurs
sans prévoir de sanction mais vous
pensez vraiment monsieur le ministre que
les chefs d'entreprise vont être
sensibles à tout ce qui touche à leur
bonne réputation nous le savons vous
avez reculé sous la pression du Medef
encore en revanche vous restez sourd par
rapport aux manifestants qui tous les
mois vous disent et le 7 encore ça va
être le cas que de votre retraite ils
n'en veulent pas en fait vous faites un
pari le pari qu'un recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite va augmenter
automatiquement l'emploi des seniors
mais vous le savez il y a un vrai risque
que le prolongement de l'âge légal
provoque justement un pic de rupture de
contrat aucune de vos mesures ne nous
donne satisfaction
et de là je parle encore que des seniors
actifs ceux qui sont encore sur le
marché de l'emploi mais que fait-on des
plus éloignés de l'emploi il serait 1,4
millions d'hommes et de femmes surtout
de femmes d'ailleurs de 53 65 ans à ne
pas avoir suffisamment cotisé pour
pouvoir partir à la retraite et qui
survivent comme ils peuvent en attendant
le taux de pauvreté des seniors n'ayant
ni emploi ni retraite atteint le chiffre
de 32% mais c'est énorme c'est 5 fois
plus que pour les seniors en emploi ou à
la retraite et monsieur le ministre il y
a fort à penser que votre votre réforme
prolonge malheureusement leur calvaire
merci Madame Mélanie le gel merci
monsieur le Président sur cet article de
tout d'abord moi je vais vous dire que
je ne comprends même pas pourquoi on
discute de l'article 2 pour deux raisons
la première ça a été dit à de nombreuses
reprises ce que l'on sait dans la presse
de la vie du Conseil d'État c'est qu'il
est probablement anticonstitutionnel et
pourquoi parce que dans un projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale voie
de finance pour être constitutionnel il
faut que les mesures est un impact
financier direct sur les finances de la
sécurité sociale sur l'année en cours or
apparemment il est fort probable que ça
ne soit pas le cas ce qui veut dire que
ça ne sert à rien puisque si ça servait
à quelque chose on aurait un meilleur
emploi des seniors plus de cotisations
sociales et donc ça aurait un impact si
ça n'en a pas c'est bien que cette
mesure ne sert strictement à rien la
deuxième raison c'est que l'article a
été rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale
alors le gouvernement c'est beaucoup
plein de latitude de l'opposition de
l'obstruction qu'on n'avait pas pu voter
discuter de tous les articles et quand
il y a un article qui est voté qu'il est
rejeté
ça vous intéresse pas moi je comprends
pas la deuxième chose que je voulais
dire c'est sur sur le fond qu'est-ce que
c'est cette index au fond on a déjà
l'exemple avec l'index sur les
inégalités salariales et le résultat
c'est quoi c'est que ça ne sert
absolument à rien hein parce que il y a
pas de sanction deux parce que c'est
tellement mal fait que même les
indicateurs sont faux on a en France des
entreprises où il y a des inégalités
salariales énormes et qui ont des notes
magnifiques
100% 90% etc donc c'est comme essayer de
soigner la fièvre avec un thermomètre
cassé ça ne sert absolument à rien si
vous voulez vraiment améliorer l'emploi
des seniors faites des choses qui
améliore l'emploi des seniors et il y a
des sanctions investissez dans la
reconversion des seigneurs qui sont dans
les dans les entreprises des activités
polluantes qui vont disparaître et qui
s'y sont pas formés à se reconvertir ne
trouveront pas de boulot après avoir été
licencié là en l'occurrence qu'on a ne
sert absolument à rien et je ne
comprends pas qu'on soit même en train
d'en discuter
et je passe la parole à Jacques Pernic
oui merci monsieur le Président
l'examen de ce cavalier social pardon je
reprends l'examen de cet article sur
l'index senior ça nous apporte une
illustration assez claire de la façon
dont le gouvernement considère la
démocratie parlementaire ce fameux index
a été son nom libre prédestinait mis à
l'index puisque cet article a été rejeté
ça vient d'être dit par les députés et
il sera peut-être sans doute
probablement censurer par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais le gouvernement
renvoie cet article devant le Sénat sans
doute pour espérer atténuer si c'était
possible
l'impopularité lourde de cette réforme
brutale en Alsace les adeptes du vélo
ont une expression pour appeler ça ils
appellent ça pédaler dans la choucroute
passez-moi l'expression
alors que que l'unedique estime que le
report de l'âge de départ à la retraite
de 60 à 62 ans a entraîné entre 2010 et
22 une hausse de cent mille
bénéficiaires de l'assurance chômage de
plus de 60 ans le gouvernement s'obstine
à vouloir détériorer encore un peu plus
le taux d'emploi des seniors en France
et ne pouvant plus donc nier que leur
réforme aura logiquement un impact
négatif sur l'emploi des seniors le
gouvernement est prêt à toutes les
manœuvres pour tenter de de cacher les
conséquences
catastrophiques de cette réforme et pour
laisser penser qu'ils œuvrent en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors cependant
personne n'est dupe c'est index
obligeant seulement les entreprises à
publier chaque année les indicateurs de
suivi relatifs à l'emploi des seigneurs
dans l'entreprise n'est qu'un écran de
fumée qui n'améliorera en rien l'emploi
du seniors puisqu'il oblige pas les
entreprises à présenter des résultats
satisfaisants alors c'est ça a été dit
inspiré de l'index d'égalité
professionnelle alors que même que
celui-ci n'a pas montré d'impact
particulier dans la lutte contre les
inégalités hommes-femmes comment le
gouvernement hostile exiger des Français
qui travaillent jusqu'à l'âge de 64 ans
alors même que nous savons qu'en 2021
seulement 56% des plus de 55 ans occupé
un emploi merci
la parole à Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre on a lu ce matin que cette
réforme était une réforme de gauche
on répond que c'est une réforme qui
résulte d'une initiative du PLFSS de la
majorité sénatoriale pour partir
d'autres pour être tenté de dire que
c'est le en même temps finalement peu
importe ce qu'on cherche c'est l'intérêt
commun et le bien général et je pense
que cette index senior il participe et
nous sommes au groupe Ussé favorable à
cette index senior sur la question de la
forme et du droit le Conseil d'État rend
un avis mais enfin le Conseil
constitutionnel on verra bien ce qu'il
rendra comme comme avis lui-même il sera
bien toujours temps de voir si c'est un
cavalier et donc il est intéressant
d'aborder cette question parce que
l'emploi des seniors et est
indispensable si on veut équilibrer
cette réforme et plus largement le
système de répartition et là il y a du
travail disons-le il y a du travail 57%
des des 55 64 ans sont en emploi dans
notre pays contre 75% en Allemagne et
nous pensons nous que le seuil de 300
est raisonnable pourquoi parce que c'est
à partir de ce seuil que nous abordons
que les entreprises abordent des
questions comme le bilan social mais il
y a une différence mes chers collègues
avec ce que vous venez de dire nous on
désespère pas du tout de l'emploi des
seniors nous pensons que les seniors
peuvent être très utiles dans les années
à venir dans l'entreprise on nous
pensons aussi que cette index senior et
cette question de l'emploi des seniors
c'est une question qui concerne le
paritarisme qui demande du grain à mood
son nez du grain à moudre à l'image de
ce qui se passe dans le modèle drainant
et enfin on désespère pas non plus à la
différence de ce qu'on entend de la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
sociales et sociétales des entreprises
et des entrepreneurs et c'est tout le
sens de cette index senior je vous
remercie merci la parole est maintenant
à
Monsieur Jacquin
merci bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ce matin j'ai
évoqué le rêve ou plutôt le cauchemar
que j'avais fait d'une flopée de livreur
à vélo de plus de 65 ans qui pédalait
trop doucement et qui vous livrer des
repas froids déclenchant votre courroux
j'ai évoqué cela parce que je souhaitais
parler de la sous-déclaration massive de
leurs revenus un article précédent je
souhaite poursuivre lors de cet article
2 de vous décrire une réalité
contemporaine d'une catégorie de
travailleurs pauvres soumis à une forte
pénibilité et qui gagne très peu vous
conviendrez qu'ils ne sont pas des
fainéants
j'insiste lourdement selon la sociologue
Laetitia dablan spécialiste de la
question il gagne en moyenne beaucoup
moins que le seuil de pauvreté aux
alentours de 590 euros par mois le
revenu pas le seuil de pauvreté celui de
pauvreté presque au double par ailleurs
la proportion de travailleurs
irréguliers est en forte croissance sans
que vous ne mettiez monsieur le ministre
les moyens de contrôle nécessaires pour
fixer des limites j'ai eu lors de la
défaite de la Saint-Nicolas à Nancy un
échange avec un groupe de travailleurs
pauvres livreurs à vélo dans un français
tout à fait approximatif en même temps
qu'il part qu'il parle de leur situation
extrêmement pénible et il nous demande
de les laisser travailler parce qu'ils
n'ont véritablement rien donc quand on
parle de faire travailler au-delà d'un
certain âge dans certains métiers sans
prendre en compte véritablement la
pénibilité ce n'est absolument pas
acceptable je vous remercie
merci Monsieur dessus merci monsieur le
Président alors ça a beaucoup de choses
ont été dites mais on attaque vraiment
la partie la plus gadget de ce projet de
loi avec cet article 2 sur la création
d'index senior la publication pour
certaines entreprises un certain nombre
d'indicateurs relatifs à l'emploi des
salariés les plus âgés mais alors
au-delà de la fragilité législative de
la présence de cet article dans ce
périphér de la sécurité sociale cet
article il existe parce que vous êtes
bien conscient que c'est de votre
réforme arrive dans un contexte
extrêmement dur concernant l'emploi des
seniors et vous allez aggraver
évidemment tout ça en recurant l'âge de
62 à 64 ans vous allez voler aux
Français deux ans de vie pour beaucoup
les meilleures années de la retraite
vont être transformées en les pires
années de travail pour ceux qui
travaillent parce qu'en fait vous
peignez d'ignorer les informations
relatives vous en demandez aux
entreprises mais les données on les
connaît ça a été dit je suis sur
plongeait dans les rapports de la DARES
ou de l'adresse 35% des 60-74 ans
occupent un emploi la DARES comptabilise
1,4 millions de chômeurs de plus de 50
ans au dernier trimestre 2022 environ
865 000 depuis plus d'un an 20% des
ruptures conventionnelles individuelles
ont concerné les plus de 50 ans en 2020
un tiers des seniors sans emploi ni
retraite vivant sous du seuil de
pauvreté alors votre ex Il va rien
corriger il va juste contester
ce que l'on sait déjà et sans
contrepartie ou contrainte liées à la
publication des données et donc sans
impact sur les Français dans le budget
de la campagne dans les finances pardon
de la sécurité sociale donc vous avez
déclaré que vous allez peut-être mettre
des dispositifs concernant
l'employabilité des seniors dans un
futur projet loi sur le travail c'est
pas anodin comme un nom puisque vous
êtes bien conscient de la brutalité de
cette réforme même et de la faiblesse de
vos mesures d'atténuation de cette
brutalité donc vous annoncez
d'hypothétique mesure à venir mais en
n'attendez pas de nous un chèque en
blanc nous combattrons en bloc votre
projet de report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite et votre gadget senior
monsieur Chantrel
merci monsieur le Président
on a effectivement un souci quand même
avec cet article puisque comme cela a
été très bien rappelé avec par mes
collègues c'est quand même un article
qui a été rejeté par par l'Assemblée
nationale que vous avez décidé de
représenter devant le Sénat ça montre
quelque part le pet fait que vous faites
vous faites du Parlement
en nous le proposant à nouveau c'est un
irspect par rapport à l'autre assemblée
mais Paso je vais en 2019 Emmanuel
Macron faisait lui-même constat que les
gens avaient du mal à rester en emploi
après l'âge de 55 ans il déclarait alors
je cite on doit d'abord gagner ce combat
avant d'aller expliquer aux gens mais
bons amis allez travailler plus
longtemps voilà des propos frappés au
coin du bon sens le taux d'emploi des 60
64 ans en France est inférieur à la
moyenne européenne deux seniors sur 3
sont au chômage en invalidité ou
bénéficiaire du RSA en plus d'être
socialement insupportable c'est cette
cette situation et la première cause du
déséquilibre de notre système de
retraite et au lieu d'améliorer la
situation votre mesure d'âge va aggraver
la précarité des seniors plutôt que
découper les arguments à la limite de la
schizophrénie de ceux qui veulent se
débarrasser des plus de 55 ans tout en
demandant le report de l'âge de légal de
départ en retraite écoutons les manuels
Macron de 2019 écoutons aussi Hervé
Lorenzi titulaire de la chair transition
démographique transition économique de
la fondation du risque il explique
qu'une hausse de 10 points du taux
d'emploi des seniors permettrait au
système retraite d'être à l'équilibre il
faudra évidemment plus que cette index
senior qui est plutôt un cash sec senior
scar sans contrainte significative
l'effet sur la réputation de
l'entreprise ne suffira pas à lui faire
changer bien évidemment son approche de
l'emploi des seniors surtout s'il ne
s'adresse qu'aux entreprises de plus de
300 salariés vous citez souvent l'index
de l'égalité professionnelle alors que
justement cela n'a aucun effet en tout
cas sur l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
merci la parole à Madame gréaume
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez bien compris je
suis pas d'accord avec cette index
senior et cela vous vous en doutez car
en plus de tout ce qui a été dit cela va
aurais-je donner de nombreux emplois
précaires mais j'aurais besoin de
connaître à partir de quand on est
seniors parce que selon la définition de
l'Insee on est seigneur à partir de 55
64 ans il y a sur le site du
gouvernement c'est CDD seniors à partir
de 57 ans sur quatre emplois on est
seigneur à partir de 45 à 50 ans et
selon certaines entreprises on est
seniors à 49,6 oh donc je voudrais bien
connaître vous comprenez monsieur le
ministre c'est important pour la bonne
raison c'est que plus qu'on est âgé plus
qu'on a des accidents notamment ça va
avoir un effet sur l'assurance maladie
vous comprenez bien et je suis sûr que
demain il y aura encore des exonérations
qu'on va donner aux employeurs pour
prendre ces seniors donc on asséchant la
sécurité sociale comment on va pouvoir
payer ses arrêts maladie et notamment
Sarah aussi une répercussion sur toutes
les aides sociales parce que si on a des
personnes qui sont en invalidité il
faudra aussi forcer les rémunérer et
avec la réforme chômage ces personnes
âgées vont aussi arriver à un moment ou
un autre sur le RSA donc je me pose
sincèrement toutes ces questions là et
en plus de celle là des nombreux
critères qu'on n'a pas abordés comme les
critères de salaire les tourneurs qui
risquent d'arriver dans les entreprises
parce que j'ai du mal à voir un senior
qui va travailler à la chaîne chez
Renault par exemple les taux de mobilité
professionnelle en interne et la part
des sonores dans l'embauche et la
formation donc j'espère que j'aurai
réponse à toutes ces questions et
notamment comment on va régler ces
problèmes financiers merci
madame lehouërou
merci monsieur le Président alors vous
avez l'ambition d'améliorer l'emploi des
seniors pour cela vous rendez
obligatoire pour les entreprises la
publication d'indicateurs la publication
d'un index et une faible sanction
associée puisque les entreprises seront
pénalisées uniquement en cas de non
publicité pourquoi les projets de
sanctions ont été abandonnés
de suppression qui sont défendus par la
gauche on a entendu certains qui
parlaient de gadget senior d'autres de
cache sexe seniors un vocabulaire très
fleuri employé par la gauche Audrey
alors que mon se passe bien ses prises
de parole dans l'hémicycle beaucoup de
prises de parole et il y aura aussi une
cinquantaine d'amendements pour
supprimer tout bonnement cet article 2
pour pourquoi car nous sommes dans un
texte légiste l'index financier pardon
et que la publication d'un index senior
par les entreprises n'est pas une mesure
financière d'après certains sénateurs ce
serait un cavalier social c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle quand un article n'est pas
un article budgétaire cet article
pourrait donc être censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel les sénateurs
seraient donc en train de travailler en
ce dimanche après-midi pour rien la
demande aux yeux suppression et
supprimer et motivé aussi pardon par une
note du Conseil d'État qui a des doutes
sur la constitutionnalité de cet article
cette note du Conseil d'État avait
vocation à rester privé mais elle a
fuité dans la presse les sénateurs de
gauche demandent au gouvernement de la
publier voilà quand vous entendrez
parler de notes ou d'avis du Conseil
d'État c'est de ça qu'on parle merci
merci beaucoup Audrey pour tous vos
éclairages sur ces débats un rappelons
également que cet article 2 avait été
rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale et que
néanmoins le gouvernement a choisi de le
représenter devant le Sénat ce que
certains à gauche ont jugé comme une
atteinte un non-respect du
parlementarisme on continue les débattes
à présent David à souligne sénateur
socialiste de Paris qui prend la parole
c'est hypocrite de décaler l'âge légal
de départ en retraite quand on est
soi-même en difficulté
il faut du courage pour arriver à 62 ans
Emmanuel Macron donc lui il dit
hypocrite c'est l'article hypocrite dans
l'hypocrisie de cette loi parce que vous
le savez lunédique vient de donner une
étude au 1er mars de cette année
qui se penche sur le moment où on est
passé de 60 à 62 ans et
son évaluation c'est que il y a eu 100
000 de
bénéficiaires des allocations
d'indemnisation du chômage en plus
100000 mécaniquement et si on regarde la
période 2010 aujourd'hui
l'augmentation du chômage des plus de 55
ans a été de 38%. donc ça c'est
la réalité et vous le savez très bien et
le président de la République quand il
disait ça en 2019 savait très bien que
mécaniquement dans un pays où le chômage
des seniors et massifs augmentaient de
deux ans c'est prolonger ce chômage et
bien sûr la croître et créer une
situation de fragilité parce que là
c'est les bénéficiaires d'indemnisation
chômage mais tous ceux qui sortent des
circuits d'indemnisation à ce moment-là
il y en a beaucoup et ils sont dans une
situation de précarité bien plus grave
bien plus difficile et donc très
franchement venir nous dire parce que
vous avez conscience de ça donc le seul
sujet je le répète de cette loi c'est de
faire de 62 à 64 ans le reste c'est de
l'habillage c'est de l'hypocrisie totale
et je pense que là-dessus ou le
démontrera à travers les nombreuses
discussions qu'il aura encore sur cet
article
merci
Monsieur Assouline donc nous en avons
terminé avec les prises de parole sur
article et je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le Président quelques
mois à mon tour sur la question de
l'index le Seigneur et au-delà sur la
question de l'emploi des seniors quelle
est l'intention du gouvernement et
quelle est la démarche dans laquelle
nous sommes l'intention du gouvernement
c'est ce que portait le projet de loi
tel qu'initialement proposé devant
l'Assemblée nationale et créer un outil
de mesure de l'implication des
entreprises pour l'emploi des seniors de
faire en sorte que cet outil s'applique
aux entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
et de la sortir finalement de deux
conditions ou de deux outils de
contraintes ou d'encouragement premier
outil l'obligation de publicité de
l'index de l'emploi des seniors pour les
entreprises depuis 300 salariés dès 2023
pour les entreprises de plus de 1000
salariés et j'insiste sur le fait que
ces deux 2023 pour les entreprises
depuis 1000 salariés puisque dans la
mesure où nous avons prévu et que nous
proposons au Parlement d'adopter ces
dispositions que les pénalités versées
par les entreprises qui se soustraient à
cette obligation de publicité soit
versée directement à la caisse nationale
ce mécanisme qui a un effet direct sur
les comptes sociaux de l'année 2023
puisque des entreprises qui se
soustraient à cette obligation de
publicité permettront devront pardon
verser une pénalité qui permettra
d'augmenter les cotisations les recettes
de l'assurance vieillesse dès 2023 nous
avons un deuxième outil que nous avons
prévu qui est de réintégrer la question
de l'emploi des seniors dans les items
de négociation obligatoire tous les
trois ans pour les entreprises depuis
300 salariés au titre de la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
parcours professionnels c'est ce que
monsieur le rapporteur Savary a
mentionné il y a un instant et c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs nous
avions prévu dans le texte initial que
cette obligation de publicité s'applique
aux entreprises depuis 300 salariés
puisque l'obligation de négociation
triennale en matière de gestion des
emplois et des parcours professionnels
pour tous les autres items auxquels nous
ajoutons l'item de l'emploi des seniors
concerne les entreprises de plus de 3
plus de 300 salariés
toutes ces raisons j'aurais l'occasion
mais j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure si
les amendements de suppression ne sont
pas adoptés mais à l'occasion de
l'examen des autres amendements de
donner un avis de sagesse à l'amendement
de la commission qui est propose de
ramener le seuil d'application de 50 à
300 la deuxième chose que je voulais
souligner concernant l'index c'est que
la majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée
nationale proposait un amendement qui
prévoyait d'ajouter un troisième outil
d'encouragement ou de contraintes selon
le point de vue que l'on a cet outil
consistait à dire que après avoir rempli
l'index après que les résultats étaient
publiés et au bout de la première
période d'observation puisque dans tous
les index il y a une période
d'observation il y a un durcissement des
conditions pour faire en sorte que les
entreprises qui ayant respecté
l'obligation de publicité ayant de droit
et parfois de manière formelle mais
ayant été contraintes à cette obligation
de négociation tribunal sur l'emploi des
seniors mais n'ayant rien fait ayant
refusé d'agir n'ayant pas amélioré la
situation on voit rayon les c'est la
situation se dégrader soit obligé de
mettre en place un plan d'action
volontaire un plan d'action obligatoire
pardonnez-moi sous peine d'épopée d'une
sanction financière supplémentaire cet
amendement qui est finalement à durcir
et à rendre effectif les résultats de
l'index senior pour les entreprises ne
jouant pas le jeu a été repoussé et dans
la mesure où ces et ceux qui présentant
une position à l'occasion de cette
discussion de l'article celles et ceux
qui nous ont reprochés de ne pas avoir
un outil assez incitatif sont sur les
bancs de la gauche il faut souligner que
l'intégralité des députés de gauche ont
repoussés cet amendement qui prévoyait
de durcir les conditions de mise en
oeuvre et donc de rendre l'index plus
efficace la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire et de nature plus technique
mais c'est un d'entre vous au travers de
leurs interrogations sur la recevabilité
ont interrogé le gouvernement
directement
sur les effets financiers je l'ai dit
l'absence de publicité et le refus de de
publicité sera durable par une fonction
dès 2023 affectée directement la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse et pour
plus de précisions vous me permettrez de
renvoyer à l'annexe 2 dans ces pages 22
et 23 qui précise justement les effets
attendus en la matière je voudrais
profiter de cette occasion du renvoi à
la Next pour dire que oui nous sommes
aussi inspirés de l'index en matière
d'égalité professionnelle que cette
index en matière d'égalité
professionnelle dont les résultats pour
la dernière période d'observation on se
rendus public dans la semaine qui vient
présente des particularités et les
premiers résultats dont je dispose font
que ces particularités sont
intéressantes d'abord parce que la note
moyenne et la note est déterminée par
des critères qui n'ont pas évolué et
donc on peut garantir la stabilité de la
méthodologie la note moyenne des
entreprises qui sont assujetti à
l'obligation de publication ne fait que
croître et c'est tant mieux et par
ailleurs nous sommes entrés depuis
l'année dernière dans la période de mise
en oeuvre des pénalités pour les
entreprises qui voient leur mode se
dégrader ou rester substantiellement
inférieur à la moyenne de le secteurs
son plusieurs dizaines d'entreprises
depuis 1000 salariés qui sont assujettis
à sanctions depuis 2022 et 2023 bah a
priori mais j'attends les résultats
consolidés marquez le même mouvement
vous avez certainement vu ou lu que la
première ministre soit aussi avec nous
puissions regarder si le maintien
durable avec une note inférieure à 75
points ce qui est véritablement le bas
du classement ne pourrait pas être ne
pourrait pas être pardon une condition
ou un motif pour écarter ces entreprises
d'un certain nombre d'appels publics
mais c'est un sujet qui est un cours
d'instruction
et pour revenir la question de l'index
et de l'emploi des seniors peut-être
pour élargir le sujet au-delà du sol
index si je me présentais devant le
Sénat en indiquant que la politique en
matière d'emploi des seniors du
gouvernement se réduit se réduit à
l'index ça serait évidemment très
insuffisant c'est une première pierre et
nous voulons aller vite la raison pour
laquelle c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons que défunt 2023 y est
cette possibilité de fonctionner les
entreprises qui se soustraient à cette
obligation de publicité pourquoi afin
2023 et pas plus tôt si nous sommes dans
l'hypothèse ou la loi est adoptée par le
Parlement tel que nous le proposons
parce que nous devons avoir un peu de
temps pour permettre différentes
branches de négocier sur cet index
négocier deux choses la première
concerne les critères les indicateurs
que nous voulons soumettre à négociation
une concertation pardon
interprofessionnelle au titre de
l'article L1 du code du travail et puis
il y a une deuxième chose que nous
devons laisser pour laquelle nous devons
laisser un peu de temps de discussion
c'est que nous avons indiqué notre
volonté que les branches
professionnelles puissent procéder à
quelques adaptations si elles le
souhaitent aux critères de l'index parce
que nous savons que d'une branche à
l'autre le nombre de seniors la
possibilité d'employer les seniors
peuvent varier et il nous paraît utile
de confier aux branches le soin de
négocier quelques adaptations mais
au-delà il faut évidemment aller plus
loin aller plus loin avec des
dispositions qui sont dans ce texte
notamment le fait de faciliter l'accès à
la retraite progressive pour les
salariés affiliés au régime général et
de l'ouvrir pour les agents de la
fonction publique le fait mais cela
renvoie à une disposition que nous
prendrons par voie réglementaire si les
critères d'assouplissement
du contre du compte professionnel
prévention sont adoptés le fait que nos
facilitons l'accès au temps partiel pour
les salariés titulaires d'un C2P
actuellement pour bénéficier de trois
mois de temps partiel avant le départ à
la retraite il faut disposer de 10
points nous souhaitons qu'avec 10 points
la période de temps partiel soit portée
de 3 mois à 4 mois et donc ainsi
permettre pour des salariés titulaires
d'un C2P d'avoir accès à plus de temps
partiel pour le même nombre de points
c'est une des pistes de renforcement
nous poursuivons et puis enfin mais cela
a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises je ne
le cite que pour mémoire le fait de
maintenir la plupart de des âges de
départ anticipé tels que nous l'avons
prévu pour les questions liées au
handicap pour les questions liées à
l'amiante permet aussi d'accompagner et
cela un coût en termes de perte de
rendement mais c'est un coût utile
permet d'accompagner la mise en place de
cette politique je sais Monsieur le
Rapporteur parce que vous l'avez dit que
votre commission est plutôt favorable si
j'ai bien entendu cela à deux
dispositions adoptées par l'Assemblée
nationale la première conc la
mutualisation du toit TPMP pour les
salariés plus de 55 ans puisque nous
savons que ça peut être un frein à
l'emploi pour les entreprises que de
qu'ils souhaitent recruter un salarié de
plus de 55 ans en matière de maladie
professionnelle les maladies
professionnelles généralement se
déclenchent après une période
d'exposition et si un chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui recrute un sénior de plus de
55 ans en l'occurrence et que ce
seigneur déclenche une maladie
professionnelle c'est la dernière
entreprise qui a recruté qui connaît la
majoration du toit ATMP le fait de
mutualiser ce taux permet de réduire le
risque si on peut dire lié à l'embauche
d'un seigneur exposé précédemment à des
critères pouvant déclencher une maladie
professionnelle la deuxième disposition
qui est me semble de recueillir votre
approbation et celle qui permet
d'aligner le régime fiscal et social des
ruptures conventionnelles pour celles
qui sont passées avant ou après l'âge
d'ouverture des droits jusqu'à présent
une rupture conventionnelle décidé avant
l'âge d'ouverture des droits avait un
régime fiscal et social à 20% alors
qu'une rupture conventionnelle décidait
après l'âge sur des droits et dans
l'hypothèse ou le salarié continue
notamment pour atteindre la durée
d'affiliation requise au régime de
retraite et avait un taux de un taux
fiscal et social un régime fiscal et
social de
30%. mettre tout le monde à 30%, c'est
casser cet effet de Ben et c'est éviter
d'encourager à des ruptures
conventionnelles avant l'ouverture des
droits je crois que ça va dans le bon
sens en plus de générer quelques
recettes pour nous permettre de tenir
notre objectif partagé d'équilibre je
sais vous avez enfin travaillé et j'ai
terminé par ces deux points sur la
question d'un CDI réservé au Seigneur
dans des conditions particulières et
vous savez monsieur rapporteur notre
volonté de continuer à avancer discuter
avec vous pour faire en sorte que les
effets d'aubaine soient les plus minimes
possibles nous le savons et que ce soit
le plus efficace possible aussi je
terminerai par un dernier point pour
dire que comme je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises ce projet de loi de financement
la sécurité sociale n'est qu'une étape
et nous aurons effectivement un projet
de loi sur le travail l'emploi
l'insertion dans les prochaines semaines
et qui sera présenté à votre assemblée
au cours de l'année 2023 je l'espère
avant l'été 2023
ce projet de loi permettra de porter
d'autres dispositions en matière de
formation pour les seniors c'est un
enjeu aujourd'hui les salariés plus de
50 ans ont un accès à la formation
continue moitié inférieur aux salariés
de moins de 50 ans soit parce que
eux-mêmes considèrent que
l'investissement en temps en énergie et
moins utile soit parce que leur
employeur considère cet investissement
est moins utile nous travaillerons aussi
sur des questions relatives à
l'articulation entre les règles
d'assurance chômage et la reprise
d'emploi nous savons par définition que
reprendre un emploi lorsqu'on est un
locataire d'un minima social et toujours
une opération gagnante si je puis dire
par contre nous savons aussi qu'il y a
quelques semaines quelques mois quand on
passe d'un système à l'autre quand on là
je ne parle pas des seniors mais c'est
un exemple quand on assure soi-même la
garde de ses enfants mais que la reprise
d'activité impose de trouver un système
de garde le temps de voix de voir
arriver pardon c'est l'expression les
aides à la garde d'enfant peut créer
quelques décalages et empêcher la
reprise d'A c'est un phénomène qu'on
retrouve aussi chez les seniors parce
que souvent des seigneurs qui ont perdu
un emploi
ont lorsqu'il perd cet emploi une
rémunération qui tient un fond quant à
la fois de leurs compétences mais aussi
de leur ancienneté dans l'entreprise et
lorsqu'il trouve une entreprise qui
accepte de les réemployer le chef
d'entreprise accepte évidemment de payer
les compétences mais pas nécessairement
de reprendre à son compte l'ancienneté
qui n'était pas dans son entreprise et
donc il faut qu'on voit comment trouver
des systèmes d'incitation pour les
seniors à la reprise d'emploi tout en
tenant compte de ces différences de
revenus et enfin mais vous l'avez
compris je souligne à plusieurs reprises
la complexité de ce que nous faisons
madame greom a posé la question de de
l'âge à partir duquel on est senior
c'est une des raisons parmi celles que
j'ai évoquées qui nous amène à
privilégier la concertation et notamment
le renvoi de branche parce
qu'effectivement et vous l'avez dit
Madame dans votre intervention là
j'appartient duquel on est seniors et
est assez variable ce qui a peut-être 55
ans il y a des CDI des départs à 57 ans
il y a des indices statistiques disent
50 ans et je pense qu'il est même des
secteurs d'activité qui considèrent qu'à
45 ans ce qui me terrorise on est aussi
on est déjà un senior et donc nous
préférons renvoyer à cet âge là parce
que en réalité dire à partir de quel âge
on est seniors c'est quelque chose qui
est finalement assez différent d'un
secteur à l'autre et parfois même d'une
personne à l'autre raison pour laquelle
vous ne trouverez aucun moment dans le
texte sur l'index des seniors en tout
cas dans ce qui en sait les dispositions
législatives un renvoi explicite à l'âge
pour ne pas gêner et ne pas figer le
débat que nous attendons des branches
professionnelles voilà monsieur le
Président j'irai un peu plus vite je
vous en je vous en fais la promesse sur
les explications de vote les
explications de position du gouvernement
pardonnez-moi sur les différents
amendements mais je pensais utile de
rappeler l'état d'esprit qui est le note
pour cette question de l'emploi des
seniors
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc nous
allons commencer à examiner les
amendements et commencer par 49
amendements de suppression et le premier
de ses amendements est présenté par
Monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues après les
interventions sur article des différents
collègues de gauche mais aussi après
l'intervention du ministre à l'instant
finalement
assez longue et assez précis sur cette
question de l'emploi des seniors je vous
propose le premier amendement de
suppression de l'article et y compris
l'intervention du ministre me renforce
dans la conviction qu'il faut le
supprimer non pas parce que nous
n'aimons pas les gadgets après tout cet
article pourrait ne servir pas rien mais
à pas grand chose et ce n'est pas grave
sauf qu'on ne résout pas un problème
aussi grave que celui des chômages des
chômage des seniors dans notre pays par
un gadget et peut-être que le seul
caractère financier de cette article
enfin
si ce qu'on sait de la note du Conseil
d'État est exact et bien peut-être que
son seul caractère financier c'est que
cet article soit pour solde de tout
compte en matière d'emploi des seniors
or c'est un sujet absolument dramatique
dans notre pays et la réforme des
retraites que vous proposez va bien plus
l'aggraver que vous ne vous ne le dites
dans les différents éléments ces
dernières semaines qui se sont révélées
et qui montrent les approximations les
contre-vérités les erreurs aussi du
gouvernement dans la présentation de sa
réforme et bien il y a l'étude de
lunédique qui indique que votre réforme
pourrait augmenter de 100 000 personnes
le nombre de seniors au chômage dans
notre pays pour quel coût pour les
finances publiques dans leur ensemble
d'ailleurs nous ne le savons pas et pour
combien de difficultés sociales accrues
prolongées aggravé là nous ne le savons
pas non plus et nous aurions évidemment
besoin de le savoir alors nous proposons
cet amendement de suppression de
l'article pour que vous ne puissiez pas
mettre comme ça la charrue avant les
boeufs vous proposez beaucoup de
concertations et beaucoup de reports à
la fin 2023 pour travailler sur l'emploi
des seniors commencez par faire de même
avec votre réforme des retraites
merci Monsieur plan n'est pas là donc je
passe la parole pour l'amendement
suivant madame briquet merci à monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues un monde suppression de
cet article là aussi puisque avec cet
article le gouvernement donc mis en
place un index senior fin de carrière
pour valoriser les bonnes pratiques dans
les entreprises pour ce faire il rend
obligatoire pour les entreprises la
publication d'indicateurs
c'est index senior aurait du sens à la
limite s'il s'inscrivait dans une
véritable loi en faveur de l'emploi des
salariés âgés j'ai bien entendu monsieur
le ministre vos propositions tout à
l'heure et nous attendrons bien entendu
cette ces dispositions en faveur de
l'emploi des seniors avec impatience
dans le cas d'une vraie loi travail en
l'espèce un index sans objectif ni
sanction du non-respect de l'objectif
n'aura aucun effet sur les entreprises
qui ont plutôt tendance à pousser les
plus âgées vers la sortie nous le savons
les deux tiers des licenciements et des
plans sociaux sont en effet subis par
ces salariés la situation des seniors
sont marchés du travail en France n'est
pas bonne et ce n'est pas un index
senior qui va échanger quoi que ce soit
à ce titre les chiffres de la DARES
parlent de même en 2021 le taux d'emploi
des seniors en France et nettement
inférieur à celui de l'Union européenne
par ailleurs la part de temps partiel
augmente considérablement avec l'âge
pour ceux qui sont en emploi
car pour les autres la réforme des
retraites du gouvernement conjugué à la
réforme de l'assurance chômage va faire
basculer dans la précarité les
demandeurs d'emploi proche de la jungle
l'égal de départ à la retraite
aujourd'hui fixés à 62 ans ceux-ci vont
voir leur durée d'indemnisation chômage
amputée de 6 mois la seule perspective
sera alors le RSA lui-même conditionné à
15 heures d'activité par semaine il est
sûr qu'à la fin d'une vie de labeur ça
fait rêver
merci cher collègue et la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Corinne
Ferret
merci monsieur le Président mes
collègues Lubin et Savary dans leur
rapport sur l'emploi des seniors publiés
en 2019 indiqué j'ouvre les guillemets
qui n'existent aucun dispositif miracle
ni incitatif ni punitif qui puisse
régler à lui seul à lui seul le problème
de l'emploi des seniors ainsi avec cette
index senior le Gouvernement fixe une
obligation de publication d'indicateurs
aux entreprises et non une obligation de
résultats notre nuance est là elle est
importante cette index au senior risque
donc d'être
inefficace dans l'amélioration de
l'emploi des seniors pourtant l'emploi
des seniors est un paramètre clé du
système de retraite sans même toucher à
l'âge de départ une augmentation du taux
d'emploi des 55-64 ans de 10 points
équilibrer le système des retraites
d'ici à 2032 en tenant compte des 30
milliards d'euros de surcoût compensant
compensés par l'État employeur notamment
pour les fonctionnaires un régime
spéciaux des entreprises publiques à
l'inverse l'adresse a ainsi estimé qu'un
report de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite engendrerait un
surcoût pour l'ensemble des prestations
oragement assurance chômage de l'ordre
de 3,6 milliards d'euros soit 30% des
économies recherchées d'ici 2027 par la
réforme du gouvernement d'autres mesures
ont été plus efficaces pour améliorer
l'emploi des seniors mais démonstrations
est faite que cette proposition de
mettre en place une un index n'apporte
rien de plus
merci maintenant l'amendement 456
monsieur Fichet oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est une un drôle de
raisonnement ça qu'on dit ben voilà on
va reporter le départ de l'âge à la
retraite à 64 ans donc on met deux ans
de plus de travail au Seigneur en
question et puis on dit aux entreprises
vous allez nous à travers un index nous
donner des indications sur le niveau
d'emploi des des seniors c'est à dire
que on va leur donner une charge
administrative en plus alors qu'elle se
plaignent déjà d'en avoir beaucoup pour
donner des informations qui sont toutes
de serviront à rien les seniors qui sont
du coup mis à l'index ne sont pas des
fainéants sont pas des gens qui ne
veulent pas aller travailler c'est des
gens qui malheureusement pour une grande
majorité passer 60 ans se retrouvent
soit au chômage soit en arrêt longue
maladie je suis à la recherche du
travail il leur faut des dispositifs
d'accompagnement qui sont de la
formation professionnelle mais aussi des
offres d'emploi qui sont à constater
alors situation d'hommes ou de femmes de
60 ans ça veut dire que si je prends un
exemple qui me touche de près
l'industrie agroalimentaire en Bretagne
on sait aujourd'hui qu'une personne qui
a travaillé pendant 25 30 ans à la
chaîne et totalement épuisée a souvent
fait l'objet d'ailleurs d'intervention
chirurgicale pour des troubles ce que
l'aube musculo-squelettique et donc
cette personne là est en difficulté pour
retrouver un travail donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre des mesures
d'accompagnement il faut lui trouver des
postes adaptés et croyez moi elles
seront vraiment très heureuses de
pouvoir s'épanouir dans des nouveaux
dans des nouveaux boulots donc le sens
de cet amendement ça veut dire que
l'index n'est pas signifiant et donc on
demande le retrait de l'article je vous
remercie
merci l'amendement 511 monsieur
chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre votre réforme est injuste et
l'article 2 sera
inefficace pour maintenir les seniors en
emploi jusqu'à 64 ans il suffit de
consulter les études de la DARES et de
l'adresse pour mesurer l'ampleur de
l'enjeu seul 35% des 60 64 ans occupe un
emploi et 20% des 427 000 ruptures
conventionnelles individuelles concerner
les plus de 50 ans en 2020
selon l'adresse
1,4 millions de personnes âgées entre 53
et 69 ans ne perçoivent ni revenu
d'activités ni pension de retraite
prolongée de deux gens l'âge du départ
légal de la retraite sans avoir obtenu
au préalable des résultats tangibles en
matière d'emploi des seniors n'est pas
responsable compte tenu des conséquences
d'une telle mesure cela se traduira par
une aggravation de la précarité des
seniors après avoir épuisé leurs droits
au chômage que vous avez déjà rogné
réduit par votre précédent très fort ils
seront poussés vers les minimas sociaux
et devront recourir à d'autres filets de
sécurité en attendant d'accéder à leur
pension de retraite maladie incapacité
préjugés négative des employeurs
manquent d'accès à la formation quelles
sont les principales raisons qui
expliquent le faible taux d'emploi des
seniors ce n'est donc pas un index aux
modalités inconnues qui permettra d'y
remédier mais
véritable plan pour les seniors passant
par l'amélioration des conditions de
travail et l'investissement dans
l'information vous avez déclaré que des
dispositifs consacrés à l'employabilité
des seniors sera annoncé dans un futur
projet de loi sur le travail n'attendez
pas de nous un chèque en blanc des
mesures hypothétiques et longues à se
concrétiser contre la présente réforme
des retraites qui aura un impact
immédiat sur les individus fragilisant
davantage une tranche en grande
difficulté d'accès à l'emploi
merci Monsieur gilet n'est pas là donc
on passe au 574 madame de La Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président je défends
donc comme mes collègues un amendement
de suppression et je voudrais simplement
dire au gouvernement et
à la majorité sénatoriale que ici le
problème est pris à l'envers parce que
ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure une
étude montre que 10 % d'augmentation de
du taux d'emploi des seniors permettrait
de résoudre le problème financier qui
est évoqué par le gouvernement et donc
il lui fallut présenter d'abord un
projet de loi sur la réforme du travail
des seniors avant de faire cette réforme
des retraites le deuxième point c'est
pour répondre aux répondre commentez en
tout cas une une intervention du
ministre tout à l'heure qui a détaillé
de manière très précise l'ensemble du
dispositif et qui a évoqué le fait que
la sanction financière hypothétique mais
néanmoins prévue par le texte serait
reversé à la caisse et on voit peut-être
point de là une forme d'habileté
habileté parce que de ce fait peut-être
le gouvernement
imagine pouvoir contourner la difficulté
de la recevabilité constitutionnelle de
ce dispositif dans un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif et à cela je dis au
ministre et à ceux qui pourraient être
convaincus éventuellement par cet
argument qu'il n'en est rien pourquoi
parce que les sanctions n'arriveraient
qu'après l'échéance d'un an qui
constaterait l'éventuelle non-respect de
la publication du dit du dit papier
ensuite du dis indicateur ensuite
rappeler Michael Zemmour qui a fait une
célébrité depuis qu'il a débusqué la
tartufferie de la tension à 1200 euros
que on peut estimer que la réforme des
retraites augmentera le nombre
d'allocataires des minima sociaux RSA et
ass de 60 000 le nombre de personnes au
chômage indemnités de 84000 et que de ce
fait on aura environ 150 000 à 200 000
personnes dans le sas de précarité entre
l'emploi et la retraite c'est pour cela
que nous n'en voulons pas et nous aurons
l'occasion de dire pourquoi est-ce que
ce qui est proposé par la droite du
Sénat est encore pire que ce qui est
proposé dans cet article
merci Monsieur renonçais n'est pas là
donc le
673 madame le héros
par cet amendement donc 673 je demande
la suppression de l'article 2
oui c'est ça sans contrainte pour les
entreprises ce dispositif n'aura aucun
impact concret sur l'emploi des seniors
je le rappelle à 60 ans près d'une
personne sur trois n'est ni en emploi ni
à la retraite la majorité d'entre elles
en situation d'invalidité de RSA ou de
chômage et donc dans une grande
précarité et insécurité en fin de
carrière selon le ministère du Travail
en 2020 le taux d'emploi des 55 64 ans
était de
53,8% sous la moyenne européenne bien
sûr et très loin de la Suède et de
l'Allemagne qui dépasse les 70% deux
tiers des licenciements et des plans
sociaux sont subis par ces salariés
seniors alors plutôt que de repousser
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
permettons au seniors une meilleure
insertion dans l'emploi déjà jusqu'à
l'âge légal aujourd'hui fixé à 62 ans
pour
pour aider les politiques anticipées
anti-seniors de certaines entreprises
travaillant sur la pénibilité au travail
sur l'amélioration des conditions de
travail or les quatre critères de
pénibilité qui vous ont que vous avez
supprimés en 2018 explique les
difficultés d'emploi des seniors qui
sont cassés à 50 ans et même avant elle
souffre de troubles musculaires
musculoosquelettiques c'est-à-dire de
douleurs intenses pour avoir travaillé
dans le froid dans des postures pénibles
avec des vibrations mécaniques ou
exposées à des risques chimiques ces
conditions de travail empêchent le
travail proposé par certaines de nos
entreprises employeuses de main d'oeuvre
et notamment je pense aux industries
agroalimentaires qui se trouvent dans
cette situation dans ma région et donc
en l'absence de demande de contrepartie
aux entreprises pour améliorer des
conditions de travail je crains qu'à
l'image de l'index femme homme égalité
famome ce dispositif ne soit ni utile ni
efficace
merci maintenant le 7002 madame blatrix
comptable merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise également à
supprimer l'article 2 qui prévoit la
création d'un index senior en effet la
réforme qui nous est proposée obligerait
à travailler plus longtemps alors même
que les seniors connaissent des
difficultés à trouver un emploi
notamment en particulier dans les
grandes entreprises donc c'est index et
nous interrompons quelques instants les
discussions autour de cet article 2
article qui prévoit la mise en place
d'un index senior car je suis avec la
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales la sénatrice Union
centriste Elizabeth Doisneau bonsoir
un mot tout d'abord de cette index
senior il n'a pas convaincu à
l'Assemblée nationale il avait été
rejeté est-ce normal qu'il revienne au
Sénat selon vous on a entendu certains
notamment à gauche dire que c'était un
non respect du Parlement
écoutez pour le groupe sans triste et
très important parce qu'on estime qu'il
est essentiel de responsabiliser
l'échelle d'entreprise au maintien ou à
l'embauche de Seigneur dans les
entreprises alors un index comme
certains disent c'est peut-être un
gadget mais en l'occurrence on voit bien
que l'index femme homme a été aussi un
moment significatif pour se rendre
compte pour mettre un peu plus de
transparence dans l'embauche en général
et donc c'est index Seigneur permettra
j'espère la même chose vous dites que
c'est mieux que rien mais vous entendez
quand même ceux qui disent c'est un
gadget c'est c'est un cache sexe on a pu
entendre et puis on a même entendu René
Paul Savary qui disait qu'il était pas
très index senior lui-même oui mais je
pense qu'il faut essayer quand même de
se convaincre que c'est un outil parmi
d'autres et justement René Paul Savary a
pris la parole au tout début de cet
article pour expliquer quel était la
panoplie que nous proposions ici au
Sénat parce qu'il y a cette index senior
mais il y a des à mesure comme par
exemple un CDI senior qui pourront
apporter des des commander des résultats
qui seront beaucoup plus significatifs
on y vient justement à ce CDI senior il
va être des battues à la suite de
l'article 2 c'est une proposition de la
majorité sénatoriale c'est un CDI qui
serait exonéré des cotisations familles
quel est le budget pour cela on a
entendu ce matin François Patrick il n'y
a pas fermé la porte mais qui a dit
qu'il attendait de voir combien ça coûte
alors on n'a pas les chiffres et on veut
en débattre en fait avec le ministre
très précisément parce que vous
embauchez un seigneur vous êtes exonéré
de la part patronale sur la location
familiale il reste la location familiale
des salariés et puis il y a toutes les
autres cotisations aussi à toutes les
lignes qu'on voit sur les bulletins de
salaire et donc ça ça va rapporter à
l'état ça va rapporter à la sécurité
sociale ça ne doit pas si cher puisque
toutes les cotisations
sur le bulletin de salaire donc c'est
une petite partie regardez sur un
bulletin de salaire vous avez 60% plus
de 60% de cotisations quand on ajoute
l'ensemble des cotisations salariales et
patronales donc c'est une petite part et
ça peut être significative par rapport à
l'embauche de quelqu'un de plus jeune
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment faire ce
cadeau aux entreprises va vous dire la
gauche écoutez les cadeaux c'est quand
même pas un gros cadeau mais ça peut
faire la différence parce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui on a les chiffres qui sont
arrivés sur l'apprentissage un seigneur
ça peut aussi en termes de passage de
témoin apporté beaucoup pour les jeunes
générations il y a eu ce fameux contrat
de génération qui n'a pas fonctionné qui
a été très vite stoppé et bien là le CDI
senior c'est peut-être la promesse d'un
passage de témoin et puis passer les
bonnes pratiques le savoir-être le
savoir-faire dans l'entreprise un mot
serait bien la façon dont se déroule les
débats dans l'hémicy est-ce que vous
estimez que le rythme des débats est
aujourd'hui satisfaisant il y a eu des
longs débats ce matin sur l'introduction
d'une part de capitalisation dans notre
système de retraite par répartition
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on va pouvoir
voter sur ce texte dimanche prochain car
c'est bien l'enjeu moi j'ai trouvé que
la qualité des débats ce matin était
plein de promesses parce que finalement
on voit bien que on nous avons besoin de
de se frotter de frotter la pertinence
des projets des uns des autres et ça
parle français aussi pourquoi pas une
part de capitalisation pourquoi pas la
retraite à points enfin ce sont des
questions qu'on se pose tous parce que
chacun travaille en se disant je paye
des cotisations à quoi servent-elles
elles servent en ce moment à payer les
retraites mais ce que je pourrais pas
avoir une part qui me servirait aussi à
Moi quand je serai en retraite donc ce
sont des questions qu'on doit se poser
et je pense que la capitalisation mes
collective en quelque sorte avec des
fonds de pension avec une attention
particulière posée par je dirais des
syndicats peut être intéressant de
regarder la Gire Carco par exemple où il
y a un véritable dialogue social sur que
fait-on chaque année s'il y a des
excédents ou pas est-ce qu'on diminue
finalement les cotisations quand on a
des excédents est-ce qu'on augmente les
pensions quand on a des excédents ou
est-ce qu'on baisse les pensions quand
on augmente les cotisations quand voilà
le besoin s'en fait sentir une dernière
question sur bien sûr ce mouvement
social très important que l'on attend un
mardi à peut-être plus d'un million et
demi deux personnes dans la rue et cela
va intervenir juste avant normalement
l'examen de l'article phare de ce projet
de loi l'article 7 qui prévoit le report
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
de 62 à 64 ans est-ce qu'une telle
mobilisation peut être à même et bien de
d'entraîner et bien le capotage de la
réforme bon mais moi je suis vraiment
consciente que ce projet de loi il a du
mal à passer
c'est difficile de toute façon à chaque
fois que projet de loi ce sont
positionnés sur ce sujet des retraites
ça a été très compliqué c'est difficile
ce sont des efforts et puis en plus
c'est très technique donc tout le monde
n'y comprend pas forcément grand chose
quelquefois en plus le gouvernement n'a
pas été voilà forcément très pédagogue
il a été parfois maladroit et donc il
faut le dire aussi il faut l'accepter
donc ici au Parlement on continue dans
des battre on continue d'expliquer
j'espère qu'un certain nombre d'éléments
seront plus facilement compréhensibles
en tout cas on a aussi essayé
d'améliorer le texte et nous espérons
que
ces mesures bien seront débattues ici au
Sénat qu'on ira quand même au-delà de
l'article 7 et qui aura bien un vote sur
l'ensemble du texte
merci beaucoup Elisabeth de nous d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
qui vous inquiète tant chers collègues
une réforme
ambise par des mesures des mesures
d'envergure pour mettre un terme à ce
chiffre cruel à 60 61 ans une personne
sur quatre didactive ou au chômage des
mesures d'envergure pour mettre un terme
à cette injustice car dans ces données
les femmes sont particulièrement
surprises des mesures d'envergure pas la
création d'un index comment pouvez-vous
croire une seule seconde que la solution
passera simplement par la
responsabilisation des entreprises pas
d'obligation pas de sanction rien mais
regardez les études et les chiffres de
ludique monsieur le ministre déjà votre
Paris du retour mécanique à l'emploi il
concerne le plus souvent les seniors les
mieux insérés tels que les cadres ou les
professions intermédiaires ensuite les
répercussions de la réforme de 2010 qui
décalait l'âge de départ à la retraite
de 60 à 62 ans sont terribles ce sont
100 000 locataires supplémentaires
âgés de 60 ans et plus entre 2010 et
2022 alors quelles conséquences pour
l'assurance chômage au total les
dépenses d'indemnisation des plus de 55
ans ont augmenté de 38% depuis 2010 et
comme la réforme de l'assurance chômage
est venue modifier les règles
d'indemnisation des seigneurs des
seniors pardonneront la seule chose
finalement que vous avez à leur offrir
ce n'est pas le maintien dans l'emploi
c'est la précarité avec pour seul filet
de sécurité le RSA et ce serait là une
réforme de gauche telle que vous
l’affirmiez ce matin votre argumentation
de l'agitation budgétaire d'une réforme
des retraites
mais c'est peut-être là votre objectif
fonctionne
mais ça va bien se passer vous énervez
pas alors
[Musique]
donc monsieur Houlgate n'est pas là et
je passe la parole à Monsieur Éblé pour
le 11 03
c'est le président Laurent
mes chers collègues l'article 2
instaurant un index dit seniors
constitue bien sûr un cavalier social
une relève pas du financement de la
sécurité sociale mais d'une loi travail
en faveur de l'emploi des salariés âgés
l'affectation des pénalités relatives à
la non production du dit index Seigneur
affectation au financement de
l'équilibre de la branche vieillesse de
la sécurité sociale
outre qu'il soit extrêmement choquant
que plus la loi est respectée moins on
dispose de moyens pour équilibrer une
branche essentielle de notre système de
sécurité sociale c'est quand même un
paradoxe je vous en conviendrai mais
surtout mais surtout en droit il
contrevient gravement au principe
d'universalité budgétaire qui est l'un
des cinq grands principes budgétaires
des finances publiques en France
principe d'annualité principe d'unités
budgétaire principe de spécialités
budgétaires principes de sincérité
budgétaire et donc principe
d'universalité il s'agit d'une règle
fondamentale du droit budgétaire
l'universalité implique le rassemblement
dans un document unique en une seule
masse de l'ensemble des recettes brutes
sur laquelle doit imputer l'ensemble des
dépenses brutes c'est donc un motif
juridique totalement suffisant pour
refuser cet article 2 et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous invite à voter la
suppression de cet article
merci Madame Lubin merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre j'ai
entendu votre intervention tout à
l'heure et à la fin j'ai entendu que
nous allions débattre prochainement
d'une loi travail
j'ai entendu que vous lanciez quelques
pistes qui peuvent être intéressantes
et notamment des des choses qui ont
existé moi je me souviens nous avons
tous connu une époque où un senior
pouvait reprendre un emploi avec un
complément de d'allocation de Pôle
emploi
des choses voilà des choses
intéressantes qui ont été abandonnées
les pré-retraite progressives qui ont
été abandonnés petit à petit donc tout
ça ça peut franchement être intéressant
et bon moi j'attends cette loi travail
en espérant que il y aura vraiment des
choses que l'on pourra discuter mais la
seule question que j'ai et qui m'amène
effectivement à vouloir supprimer cet
article c'est pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
mis cette loi travail avant la loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour allonger la durée de
cotisation enfin ça paraît d'une logique
absolue
et nous sommes quand même un petit peu
inquiets moi je suis toujours beaucoup
d'espoir dans la parole publique et donc
je compte sur le gouvernement pour que
cette loi travail et du contenu mais
quand je vois ce qui s'est fait sur
l'assurance chômage et le fait que vous
avez trouvé le moyen de réduire et
l'indemnisation des chômeurs de longue
durée âgées de plus de 57 ans je crois
alors qu'on sait très bien un castajola
la possibilité de retrouver un emploi de
manière pérenne et quasiment nulle enfin
il faut se dire les choses alors
aujourd'hui ça se passe un peu mieux
parce que les entreprises manquent de
personnel bref voilà nous avons quand
même quelques doutes sur la sincérité
merci pour le 1212 monsieur meriou
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues n'est pas
Houdini qui veut alors Woody lit pour
ceux qui ne le sauraient pas
c'est le magicien le plus célèbre de
l'Histoire c'était un grand
illusionniste et la création de cet
indice senior est finalement tour de
passe-passe un écran de fumée dans le
seul but est de donner l'illusion que
vous vous souciez un temps soit peu du
devenir et de la situation des salariés
seniors qui vont bâtir du report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite car c'est
un fait votre réforme aux objectifs
purement comptables ne prend pas en
compte une triste réalité on l'a déjà
dit à 60 ans près d'une personne sur
trois n'est ni en emploi ni à la
retraite la majorité d'entre elles sont
en situation d'invalidité allocataire du
RSA ou du chômage souvent elles vivent
dans la précarité et avec l'âge rien ne
s'avance rien ne s'arrange puisque à 62
ans c'est plus de 73% des salariés qui
n'existent qui n'exerce plus d'activité
cette réforme constitue donc un sas de
précarité inacceptable face à cela votre
solution un index senior qui rend
obligatoire pour les entreprises d'une
certaine taille la publication
d'indicateurs tels que le recrutement ou
le maintien d'emploi une véritable
révolution quand on sait que la non
publication n'entraînera pas ou peu de
sanctions en d'autres termes cette
situation ne changera rien car les
entreprises ne seront pas contraintes
d'embaucher davantage de seniors cette
mesure est une preuve de plus que cette
réforme ménage et les entreprises au
détriment des salariés vous cédez un
effet à la loi des marchés vous
succombez à la fascination d'un
capitalisme financier qui broie les
femmes et les hommes au service de
l'intérêt les plus cupides vous
confondez valeur travail et exploitation
justice sociale et servilité face aux
grandes actionnaires à qui vous ne
cessez de donner des gages votre
réflexion
et maintenant le 1242 madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président c'est
l'opacité monsieur le ministre c'est
l'opacité l'index senior c'est une forme
de maltraitance quelques instants les
discussions et les amendements de
suppression qui s'égrènent sur cet
article de articles qui prévoit la mise
en place d'un index senior et on a
entendu Audrey et bien largement
l'opposition de la gauche sur ce sujet
oui nous sommes en train d'examiner les
amendements qui visent à supprimer tout
bonnement l'article 2 sur l'index senior
il y en a une cinquantaine qui a été
déposée par les groupes de gauche 49 59
pardon par les socialistes un par les
écologistes donc 49 par les socialistes
1 par les écologistes je vais y arriver
à raison de deux minutes pour étudier
chaque amendement ça me laisse le temps
de vous expliquer pourquoi ils sont pour
la suppression de cet article sur le
fond il y a un problème d'emploi des
seniors en France on le sait un quart
des 55 62 ans son non actif
un index non contraignant ne servirait
pas à régler le problème pour la gauche
écouter
faut le supprimer non pas parce que nous
n'aimons pas les gadgets après tout cet
article pourrait ne servir pas rien mais
à pas grand chose et ce n'est pas grave
sauf qu'on ne résout pas un problème
aussi grave que celui des chômages des
chômage des seniors dans notre pays par
un gadget et peut-être que le seul
caractère financier de cette article
enfin si ce qu'on sait de la note du
Conseil d'État est exact et bien
peut-être que son sol caractère
financier c'est que cet article soit
pour solde de tout compte en matière
d'emploi des seniors or c'est un sujet
absolument dramatique dans notre pays
d'autres sénateurs de gauche veulent
supprimer à cet article car il ne
convient pas sur la forme d'après eux
pour eux ce n'est pas une mesure
financière ça n'a rien à faire dans un
texte budgétaire on est dans un projet
de loi rectificatif de la sécurité
social projet de loi financier pour eux
donc cet article n'a rien à faire dedans
je ne comprends même pas pourquoi on
discute de l'article 2 pour deux raisons
la première ça a été dit à de nombreuses
reprises ce que l'on sait dans la presse
de la vie du Conseil d'État c'est qu'il
est probablement anticonstitutionnel et
pourquoi parce que dans un projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale va
être finance pour être constitutionnel
il faut que les mesures est un impact
financier direct sur des finances de la
sécurité sociale sur l'année en cours or
apparemment il est fort probable que ça
ne soit pas le cas ce qui veut dire que
ça ne sert à rien la deuxième raison
c'est que l'article a été rejeté par
l'Assemblée nationale ces sénateurs
s'appuient aussi sur une note du Conseil
d'État qui avait vocation à rester
confidentielles mais qui a été publiée
qui a fuité dans la presse et dans cette
note il aurait émis des doutes sur la
constitutionnalité de cet article Tam
merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes
ces explications oui pour prolonger les
discussions sur cet article de je suis
avec Daniel Breuillet bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur écologiste on vient
d'entendre à l'instant votre collègue
Mélanie Vogel qui est bien ne comprenait
même pas pourquoi est-ce que l'on
débattait de cette article 2 parce que
et bien c'est un cavalier social
probablement anticonstitutionnel nous
dit elle vous trouvez aussi que l'on est
en train de perdre du temps
perdre du temps je ne sais pas parce que
je pense qu'il y a place dans notre pays
pour un débat sur les sujets du travail
en revanche le gouvernement nous fait
perdre du temps en introduisant cet
article et en introduisant une loi
injuste injustifiée dans un projet de
loi de financement rectificatif la
sécurité sociale ça n'est pas l'objet de
ces financements de ces projets de loi
de financement sont de rectifier des
comptes publics et en l'occurrence c'est
index seniors c'était d'ailleurs
souligné dans un avis du Conseil d'État
que le gouvernement ne veut pas rendre
public et visiblement un cavalier social
et sera sans doute déclaré un
constitutionnel
cavalier social il a été rejeté par
l'Assemblée nationale vous regrettez du
coup qu'il soit et bien remis sur la
table ici au Sénat auto les cas ça
témoigne de la part du gouvernement
d'une certaine conception du respect du
travail parlementaire parce qu'au fond
il se plaint qu'il y a eu peu d'articles
examinés à l'Assemblée nationale mais
celui-ci a été examiné il a été rejeté
assez massivement et le gouvernement le
réinstalle dans le document qu'il nous
soumet c'est donc une façon de regarder
le travail de nos collègues députés qui
est assez peu valorisante sur le fond
est-ce que un index senior ce n'est pas
mieux que rien alors sur le fond le
sujet du travail des seniors est un beau
sujet qui mérite un débat et même qui
mériterait une loi sur le travail c'est
un des sujets d'une loi travail que nous
appelons de nos vœux et d'une vraie
concertation sociale d'un rôle social
que nous appelons de nos vœux j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire d'ailleurs au
moment des explications et même de
reprendre une proposition de nos
collègues de nos collègues centristes de
commencer par un débat sur les sujets du
travail avant d'évoquer cette réforme
des retraites parce que oui le très
faible taux d'emploi des seniors le fait
entièrement d'entre eux ne sont ni au
chômage ni au travail c'est un problème
immense c'est d'abord un problème de
gâchis des ressources pour les
entreprises et pour le pays de leurs
compétences de leur intelligence et puis
un problème pour les personnes
concernées par cette zone grise sans
droit en ou avec des droits liés à
l'incapacité de travail au RSA
effectivement il y a là une situation
très difficile pour des centaines de
milliers de personnes donc il faut s'y
attaquer mais la façon dont le
gouvernement le fait n'est ni fait ni
affaire c'est c'est un article magique
cet article de l'index des signaux vous
avez dit c'est le quai 9 3/4 on a
découvert votre connaissance d'Harry
Potter à cette à cette occasion certains
en parler d'oudini il y avait des
références à la magie tout à l'heure
dans l'hémicycle est-ce que vous êtes
personnellement favorable à des mesures
contraignantes à l'égard des entreprises
pour et bien quelle garde ces seniors
dans les dans les entreprises moi je
suis d'abord favorable au dialogue
social avec les partenaires sociaux sur
ces sujets là qui sont des sujets
importants et parfois complexes mais
évidemment je n'exclus pas qui puisse y
avoir aussi des sanctions je pense
notamment aux très grandes entreprises
parce que quand vous êtes dans des
entreprises qui ont 20 30 40 ou 50
salariés la proportion de seniors est
assez difficile à évaluer quand on est
dans une très grande entreprise bien sûr
qu'il y a aujourd'hui une politique
d'entreprise qui se débarrassent des
seniors parce qu'au fond il coûte plus
cher ils sont souvent plus qualifiés ils
ont une ancienneté qui fait que leur
rémunération est plus élevée et on
profite de failles de des lois actuelles
pour pouvoir s'en séparer donc bien sûr
qu'un outil plus contraignant serait
sans doute une nécessité mais aussi
d'abord une négociation sociale avec les
partenaires sociaux parce que quand on
parle du travail c'est la première des
choses à faire c'est ce que ce
gouvernement ne fait pas au fond il
méprise un peu les parlementaires il
méprise des partenaires sociaux de la
même façon on s'achemine avec la droite
sénatoriale non pas vers une mesure
contraignante mais vers une mesure
incitative la mise en place d'un CDI
senior qui serait exonéré de cotisations
familles de la part patronale des
cotisations des cotisations familles
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire parce que
c'est une bonne mesure au tous les cas
c'est une proposition moi je reconnais à
nos collègues de la majorité la volonté
de chercher des propositions pour
améliorer cette question du taux
d'emploi des seniors mais je suis assez
partagé sur la sincérité de leur volonté
sociale dans la mesure où ils viennent
de voter aussi une réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui a diminué les
droits des seniors sur cette assurance
chômage donc moi j'ai peur que dans
l'ensemble le gouvernement plus une
volonté assez conservatrice de cette
majorité sénatoriale n'aboutissent
plutôt à des tricoter les droits
maintenant cette idée d'un CDI senior
elle mérite d'être mise dans dans un
débat avec d'autres idées j'en profite
pour souligner ce grand paradoxe on a
refusé des amendements de plusieurs de
nos collègues des bandes de la gauche et
de l'écologie sur cette index senior au
motifs qu'ils étaient hors de propos
d'un texte de loi de finances
rectificative et on va débattre
l'amendement d'ailleurs de nos collègues
LR est également un amendement qui est
tout à fait hors sujet d'un texte de loi
rectificatif en plus il est adossé à cet
article
qui court un risque fort d'un
constitutionnalité bon écoutez ça ça
occupe le Sénat qui est sans doute assez
expert en termes d'emploi des seniors ou
c'est ça que vous nous dites en tous les
cas il n'est pas sain que des
amendements est passé le cap de
l'article 45 et se retrouve en débat et
que d'autres ne l'est pas passé ça ça ne
me paraît pas tout à fait juste et je
pense ça mériterait d'ailleurs une
discussion en conférence des présidents
des droits de l'opposition n'ont pas été
non les droits de l'opposition sont
massivement respectés mais il y a quand
même eu quasiment un millier
d'amendements qui ont été supprimés ce
que je conteste plus que le non respect
des droits de l'opposition par le Sénat
c'est encore une fois la procédure
choisie par le gouvernement qui en
enfermant dans un texte rectificatif de
financement
Michel objectivement le fait d'amander
sur le fond sur des sujets qui ont très
au travail on ne peut pas faire une loi
sur les retraites si on traite pas du
travail des conditions de travail de la
façon dont on permet au Seigneur de
rester en bonne santé alors qu'il
continue leur travail malgré l'âge bien
merci beaucoup Daniel Breuillet d'avoir
répondu à mes questions on va revenir
tout de suite dans l'hémicycle ou le
débat c'est poursuit autour et bien de
cet article 2 qui prévoit donc la mise
en place d'un index senior après des 60
ans c'est à peine 36% des gens qui sont
employés en reculant l'âge de départ de
60 à 62 ans par la réforme verte de 2010
on a créé 100000 chômeurs de plus quand
sera-t-il en la regardant à 64 ans 90
000 îles d'Arès et si on compte comme
Marine Noël appelle la zone grise c'est
à dire les seniors qui sont au chômage
Anaëlle D
un invalidité ou au RSA alors le FCE
parle de 300 000 personnes quel sera le
coût social monsieur ministre dites-nous
le et comment vivront ces personnes ce
qui est encore plus important le rapport
de l'indique Paris le premier mars 2023
montre un pic de rupture conventionnel
quand on approche de l'âge légal de la
retraite l'arme de la rupture
conventionnelle collective a été
parfaitement comprise par les grandes
entreprises qui en font un mode banal de
gestion précarisant les salariés
durcissant les conditions de travail et
sacrifiant la santé et la sécurité des
travailleurs c'est donc un index inutile
qui n'oblige en réalisant des
entreprises tout comme est inutile
l'index de l'égalité homme-femme qui n'a
pas lui non plus de sanctions
financières et qui n'a rien changé
l'index senior ne changera rien non plus
il faut donc supprimer cet article
merci Madame meunier n'est pas là madame
Bonnefoy non plus donc je passe
maintenant la parole à Monsieur Lecomte
le 1698
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues un chiffre
un chiffre assez terrible 55% des
Français valides un trimestre l'année de
la liquidation de de leur retraite alors
bien entendu si
ils ne peuvent la liquider que deux ans
après la situation sera encore pire
pourtant nous n'avons eu aucune réponse
monsieur le ministre aux questions
posées sur le coup
en matière
d'allocation chômage de RSA que cette
situation allait faire peser sur des
personnes qui seront encore plus
précarisées qu'aujourd'hui
des estimations sont de 5 milliards
d'euros à quoi bon faire des prétendus
économiques si c'est pour précariser et
engendrer de telles dépenses enfin nous
avons entendu les arguments de Vincent
et blé et j'aurais souhaité que notre
rapporteur nous dise puisque finalement
alloué à la CNAV le bénéfice des amendes
liés à la non publication de l'index au
seniors relève d'une d'un détournement
complet de de de des lois relatives au
financement de la sécurité sociale
puisque c'est ce qui permet de prétendre
aujourd'hui qu'on peut l'intégrer dans
le dans cette loi alors parce que ce
dispositif
n'est absolument pas efficace parce
qu'il n'a pas sa place dans une loi nous
proposons de supprimer cet article qui
n'a aucune aucune aucune efficacité par
rapport au but poursuivi
merci
Monsieur todéchini J'ai oublié de ne
sont pas là le président canner
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué l'article un
bis en l'appelant article Macron là
c'est plutôt l'amendement ou l'article
en l'occurrence l'article route des yeux
nous sommes finalement face à une
démarche qui est celle je crois que
c'est notre collègue Joël Bigot qui
l'évoquait la démarche d'une même chaîne
c'est-à-dire on nomme les gens et on
crée une honte autour de leur pratique
je vous cache pas que en tant que
ministre de la Ville fin 2016 au début
2017 je crois j'avais porté cette idée
avec ma collègue mini du travail de
l'époque en disant mais il faut que en
matière de diversité sociale
les entreprises qui ne jouent pas le jeu
puissent être repérés et mise non pas
l'index son jeu de mots mais mise devant
le responsabilité chers collègues ça n'a
pas marché je le dis ça n'a pas marché
parce que c'est pas comme ça que nous
fonctionnons dans notre pays dans les
pays anglo-saxons ça peut marcher mais
pas dans un pays comme la France
moralité j'ai regardé le l'exposé les
motifs monsieur le ministre notamment la
première phrase l'expéritifs issus du
texte initial afin de faire de l'emploi
des seniors une priorité des entreprises
le présente article prévoit la création
d'un index senior qui a pour objectif
d'objectiver la place des seigneurs en
entreprise d'assurer la transparence en
matière de gestion des âges et de
valoriser les bonnes pratiques en la
matière très honnêtement
c'est du violon quoi disons-le entre
nous c'est de la bonne intention qui
n'est pas la hauteur de l'enjeu l'emploi
des seigneurs dans notre pays est très
faible trop faible et ce n'est pas votre
index monsieur le ministre qui permettra
de régler la situation
merci la parole à Monsieur Assouline
pour le 1851
oui quel dommage ça a été souligné par
plusieurs de nos collègues quel dommage
parce que c'est un vrai grand sujet qui
est jamais abordé à la hauteur de
l'enjeu de l'enjeu y compris de
prospective parce que là il y a il y a
du débat à voir on est dans une société
où effectivement
l'espérance de vie augmente et de
l'autre côté
le marché du travail rétrécit en classe
d'âge
aujourd'hui les entreprises à partir de
50 ans considère qu'on est plus du tout
à ces productif puisque c'est maintenant
le seul étalon sur lequel on fonctionne
pour toujours faire plus de bénéfices
quel que soit les vies-combois ou
les dégâts que l'on cause sur le plan
social mais c'est un fait pas la peine
je sais bien la droite elle a ses
atavismes mais ouvrez les yeux sur ce
qui est une réalité
or aujourd'hui nous dire qu'un index de
ce type va faire quelque chose alors que
s'il y a un domaine où nous avons essayé
d'avancer parce que il y a des sanctions
à la clé
des personnes en situation de handicap
seulement 30% des entreprises respecte
les obligations de 6% de la masse
salariale dire que malgré le fait que on
peut dire qu'il y a eu des avancées en
termes de conviction de l'opinion en
termes de sanctions malgré cela même pas
un tiers des entreprises respectent et
là on nous ferait croire que parce que
il y aurait une publicité
qui ne sert qu'à justifier effectivement
le fait de d'éviter qu'on dise que c'est
un cavalier mais c'est un cavalier et je
veux redire ici que Monsieur le Ministre
on vous lâchera pas car il n'y a aucune
raison pour la transparence de nos
débats de ne pas nous fournir la note du
Conseil d'État qui dit que c'est un
cavalier il faut conclure merci alors
Monsieur kozic monsieur Joly ne sont pas
là je passe la parole à présidente
rossignol
merci monsieur le Président alors moi
j'aime beaucoup les index je suis pas
une spécialiste de l'emploi des seniors
mais
en ce qui concerne l'emploi des femmes
j'ai la mode des style penser que ça
fait quelques années que je m'y penche
et que je travaille dessus et je sais
que les index c'est ce qui permet
d'objectiver des réalités souvent
invisibles dissimulées ou masquer par
des argusies des explications
relativistes relativisant elle est
donnée objectives donc je suis plutôt a
priori favorable à ce qu'on mette des
index partout à chaque fois qu'on peut
mesurer ce qui doit être mesuré parce
que ce n'est pas suffisamment visible
pour autant je ne considère pas que les
index sont un outil de politique
publique les index sont ce sur quoi on
va pouvoir fonder des politiques
publiques des politiques de l'emploi des
sanctions ou éventuellement des
incitations or dans l'index que vous
avez choisi il n'y a en fait que l'index
et la publication de l'index et puis il
y a toute beaucoup est renvoyé au décret
c'est bien normal la Constitution le
veut ainsi mais ça pousse quand même une
série de sujets comment va être pris
comment va être appréhendé le temps
partiel des seniors dans la l'index sur
l'emploi des seniors c'est pas tout à
fait une histoire que pour les femmes on
va pas calquer exactement l'index
égalité femme homme pour le faire sur
l'index senior et c'est d'autre
paramètres et en plus sur l'index
égalité femme homme on connaît les biais
et les insuffisances de l'index comment
vous allez croiser les deux par exemple
pour le choix pour les femmes
seniors on sait qu'il y a une prévalence
du temps partiel est-ce que le temps
partiel des femmes va être considérée
comme étant de l'emploi de seniors et
est-ce qu'on va ainsi renforcer le temps
partiel il y a toute une série
d'interrogations qui auraient mérité si
nous avions eu un projet de loi normale
en fait pas un pfss avec un raccord un
rapprochement et une extrémiste de cet
article dans la loi retraite que on
puisse travailler finement pour que
l'index égalité femme homme on en tire
le pardon président oui excusez-moi
j'avais pas vu je regardais le ministre
en espérant qu'il me regarde et donc
j'ai oublié de regarder le compteur je
reviendrai
merci donc
j'en étasse madame espagnol ne sont pas
là madame ponce
oui merci puisque Laurence Rossignol n'a
pas pu finir ben moi je vais un petit
peu reprendre un petit peu pareil
un index si vous voulez un index et les
indicateurs qu'on va choisir dans
l'index seront pertinents et donc
efficaces que si il le commence par un
diagnostic partagé de ce qui fait les
discriminations on prend les femmes
effectivement quand vous partez de plus
de 20% de discrimination
la pare prise par le temps partiel
souvent subi quelques quelques fois je
mets entre guillemets choisis
effectivement et la première cause de
l'écart la deuxième cause c'est ce sont
les secteurs féminins qui pour des
raisons diverses on dit reviendra pour
la pénibilité
sont structurellement moins rémunérés
que les secteurs dit masculins ça
recoupe l'industrie les services et on y
reviendra pour les critères de
pénibilité qui sont des critères
d'industrie et d'hommes
la troisième chose bah oui mais ça c'est
bref la troisième chose c'est la
discrimination pure et c'est la part la
plus petite elle est importante c'est à
peu près 6% si je crois si 7% j'ai pas
mis mon truc
et donc effectivement c'est celle que
traque l'index et quand l'index sera
traité
à travers quand même des choses comme la
promotion l'augmentation individuelle
qui sont il y a pas par exemple la
formation bref alors pour terminer pour
les seniors c'est pareil les seniors si
vous commencez pas par dire que le fait
que 11% des retraités étaient au chômage
avant si vous traitez pas le travail
l'intensification du travail qui les
exclut si vous ne traitez pas les
contraintes de rythme de travail donc si
vous ne changez pas de travail étonnez
compte par exemple qu'ils ont besoin
d'anticipation qu'ils ont besoin de
transmettre qu'ils ont besoin de se
former vous pouvez mettre n'importe quel
ind ex ça changera rien à la réalité de
la discrimination
bien merci donc nous en avons terminé
avec les présentations des amendements
de suppression que je vais soumettre aux
voies y a-t-il des explications pardon
excusez-moi
excusez-moi avis de la commission
d'abord
merci monsieur le Président vous m'avez
fait peur j'ai cru qu'après 48
amendements
identique sur lesquels nos collègues ont
pu s'exprimer le rapporteur n'aurait pas
quelques minutes à leur consacré en
réponse donc merci de vous être d'avoir
remarqué cela alors oui j'ai remarqué
qu'il y en avait deux trois différents
mais si vous voulez j'en prends un au
hasard et puis je regarde s'il est pas
identique d'accord bon voilà il y en a
un qui est pas identiques c'est issus de
Monsieur Jacquin
voilà qui est repris d'ailleurs par
quelqu'un d'autre et je l'ai pris en
main pourquoi parce que il parle de
quelque chose d'intéressant puisqu'il
dit que les salariés plus de 55 ans
sont trop souvent une variable
d'ajustement oui nous le constatons et
quand on va décaler là je ça va paraître
les salariés de plus de 55 ans ça va
être après voyez-vous c'est comme ça que
ça se passe c'est dans tous les pays
étrangers ils l'ont fait partout ils ont
augmenté l'âge partout il y a un emploi
des seniors et beaucoup plus important
que chez nous c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous venons prendre des mesures
pour faire en sorte que on accompagne
cette dimension haute qui fait qu'on
travaille plus longtemps et d'ailleurs
vous êtes tellement impatient de
d'appréhender les mesures qu'on vous
propose à l'article 9 que je vois bien
que vous traduisez votre impatience par
une répétition des amendements il
n'empêche que c'est une théorie qui ne
vous a pas échappé
puisque la réforme Touraine c'était bien
un allongement de cette durée de travail
un passage de 41 ans et demi à 43 ans un
peu différé puisque sont les générations
d'après et qu'ils sont celles de
maintenant que l'on prend et pourquoi
vous avez augmenté la durée de travail
parce que vous avez constaté qu'en
France nous ne produisions pas assez
680 heures de travail quand ramener à
l'habitant 800 en Allemagne une balance
commerciale complètement négative nous
ne produisons pas assez c'est la raison
pour laquelle il nous paraît tout à fait
important de prendre les mesures
nécessaires et d'accompagner
d'accompagner le travail c'est mieux
travailler pendant compte effectivement
le bien-être et peut-être pas forcément
faire en 35 heures ce qu'on pourrait
faire en 39 heures ne l'oublions pas que
mieux prendre en compte le travail c'est
aussi peut-être réfléchir à tout ça ça
nous paraît important alors qu'est-ce
que nous devions faire vous parlez d'une
menace d'inconstitutionnalité sur cet
article 2 oui oui ça nous a pas échappé
ça n'avait pas échappé à nos
administrateurs on en a parlé bien avant
de lire la note du Conseil
constitutionnel qui reprend du Conseil
d'État excusez-moi merci de suivre du
Conseil d'État qui reprend exactement ce
que nous nous pensions c'est la raison
pour laquelle cet avis est très clair et
mais il y a aucun problème juste sur ce
point et excusez moi laissez le
rapporteur
[Musique]
vous m'interpellez vous cassez mon
raisonnement je vous réponds qu'on en
parle plus je vous réponds qu'on a par
le plus il y a un respect la loi ce sont
une ce sont des notes confident les
présidents de commission savent bien ce
que c'est c'est notre confidentielle moi
j'en suis respectueux elles sont à la
disposition de certaines personnes dont
les membres de La Mecque voilà et quand
je suis interpellé par Cathy
elle est membre de la Mecque qu'est-ce
que j'ai dit il y a je ne sais combien
d'heures que j'étais à disposition pour
rencontrer celles et ceux qui membres de
La Mecque parce que la loi est ainsi
faite il y a une confidentialité j'y
peux rien celles et ceux qui souhaitent
voir avec moi cette note que je ne peux
pas vous confier vous confier vous
pouvez prendre contact avec moi et c'est
avec beaucoup
de convivialité que je vous la montrerai
vous devez savoir si vous êtes membre de
la Mecque ou pas quand même d'accord
merci il vous appartiendra il vous
appartiendra ensuite de voir comment
vous en parler à vos collègues c'est
ainsi fait c'est ainsi fait de façon à
ce que si vous en êtes d'accord on en
parle plus hein d'accord mais vous serez
déçu parce que tout est écrit dans le
monde et vous le savez très bien que
vous verrez qu'il y a rien neuf mais
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît c'est le
rapporteur continué seul et ensuite on
poursuivra la discussion et donc j'en
reviens j'en reviens à la position de la
Commission une fois qu'on a dit ça nous
avions deux solutions d'accord soit dire
c'est ce sera un constitutionnel hop on
supprime comme vous le proposez cet
article là mes chers collègues aurait pu
Urien sur l'emploi des seniors vous
venez 48 fois de 48 fois consécutifs
nous dire que vous étiez interpellé par
rapport à l'emploi des seniors qui ne
figurerait pas dans cette loi qui aurait
dû figurer dans une loi travail ce que
nous disons les choses sont mis à
l'envers effectivement mais nous
récupérons
cette dimension de l'employabilité des
seniors en le remettant dans la loi
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
pas rejeté cet index et puis nous
écoutons nous avons consulté énormément
ça fait vous savez ça fait 4 ans quand
même qu'un certain nombre d'entre nous
se penchent sur l'affaire donc les
partenaires sociaux on les connaît bien
quand même qu'est-ce qui nous ont dit
les partenaires sociaux notamment ceux
de la CFDT nous sommes attachés à
l'index à quelque part on a écouté nous
avons également des partenaires il y a
Olivier Hainaut qui s'est penché Olivier
Hainaut m'a dit ah moi je pense que
l'index c'est pas suffisant mais nous
avons écouté nos partenaires pour faire
en sorte plutôt que de rejeter d'un
revers de main prendre en compte c'est
index et trouver une disposition nous
permettant d'inscrire une avancée dans
la prise en compte de l'employabilité
des seniors à travers le CDI senior
qu'on vous proposera tout à l'heure avec
justement une exonération de cotisations
familles pourquoi
cotisation famille pourquoi parce que
c'est dans la dimension d'un plfsr
qu'une exonération d'une cotisation
chômage qui ait été plus judicieuse et
hors PLFSS vous le savez aussi bien que
moi donc on a raccroché cette
disposition pour faire en sorte que le
gouvernement puisse prendre en compte
cette dimension nouvelle qui sera
monsieur le ministre et on se rejoint
dans ce dispositif là à discuter avec
les partenaires sociaux c'est une
avancée une proposition et ensuite les
partenaires sociaux ils veulent ils
veulent s'inscrire dans ces dimensions
ils nous l'ont demandé c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avançons dans ce
domaine là et puis un point également
particulier c'est que vous l'avez bien
dit moi nous trouvons inacceptable
inacceptable c'est seniors qui se
retrouvent au chômage ce n'est pas
variable d'ajustement c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut prendre en compte
un certain nombre de difficultés et on
sait que certains peuvent être usés par
le travail c'est la raison pour laquelle
à travers l'article 9 on a une avancée
considérable je ne peux pas entendre
permettez-moi de dire que on a écarté
tous les facteurs de risque en dehors du
ces deux P non dans le C2P il y a quatre
facteurs de risque qui ont été retenus
on peut mieux les identifier qui sont
bien pris en compte dans le cadre de la
prévention dans le cadre derrière d'une
d'un travail à temps partiel ou
éventuellement au titre de la réparation
par un agent anticipé de départ à la
retraite mais dans les autres facteurs
notamment les facteurs
ergonomiques il est important de les
prendre en compte il y a une avancée qui
a été faite dans le dispositif puisqu'on
crée un fond spécial donc ils seront
pris en compte et nous avons encore à
faire avancer le dispositif car certes
les âges d'invalidité d'incertitude
d'inaptitude au travail resteront à 60
ans mais par contre je pense que nous
pouvons avancer et si vous êtes d'accord
pour aller jusqu'à l'article 9 en
évitant un certain nombre de monologues
nous pourrons avancer pour faire en
sorte que l'incapacité permanente puisse
être prise en compte en considération
des 60 ans sans attendre 62 ans vous
voyez ces avancées sociales on les a
annoncé les seniors les attendent me
semble-t-il et nous voulons des
garanties monsieur le ministre on espère
nous donnera pour que ce soit inscrit
dans la prochaine loi sociale voilà
comment nous avons
envisagé les choses et nous avons même
poussé encore plus loin puisque il y
avait pas de prise en compte sur les
expositions aux agents chimiques
dangereux que nous réinscrivons dans les
dispositifs pour qu'il y ait à travers
ce qui est proposé la prévention de ces
agents soient mieux pris en compte voilà
ce que je souhaite et vous dire
que notre ambition s'éclaire et ça a été
dit par certains d'entre vous on a
besoin de prendre en compte de façon
spécifique l'emploi des jeunes on a
spécifique l'emploi des seniors voilà ce
que je souhaitais vous dire dans le
cadre de cette suppression d'articles
pour lequel vous l'avez compris je
donnerai un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur et la vie de
monsieur le ministre sur ces mêmes
amendements
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président la
ville du gouvernement est évidemment
défavorable incisamment de suppression
j'ai promis le bref tout à l'heure je
vais l'être de points cependant d'abord
à écouter monsieur Céline je ne voudrais
pas interrompu quand vous avez partagé
avec nous votre connaissance de
l'entreprise et de l'économie donc
laissez-moi aller au bout de cette
explication de la vie du gouvernement
la première chose c'est que j'ai parfois
entendu un certain nombre de
justifications autour de ces amendements
qui me donnait le sentiment qu'on
cherchait toutes les bonnes raisons de
le supprimer je prends un seul exemple
tout à l'heure monsieur montoger nous
dit mais vous auriez dû vous devriez
plutôt des plafonner les points que l'on
peut obtenir au titre du CDP ça tombe
bien c'est ce que nous faisons donc vous
voterez l'article 9 avec nous vous avez
cité d'action que nous mettons en œuvre
ou sur lesquels nous sommes engagés
comme la rappeler monsieur le rapporteur
donc assumer de vouloir supprimer un
outil qui va accompagner l'emploi des
seniors sont nécessairement chercher des
raisons qui n'en sont pas ou qui sont
différentes de celles que nous avons mis
dans le texte la deuxième chose c'est
vrai que l'Assemblée nationale a fait le
choix et en particulier parce que un
amendement portant le dispositif à 2-300
à 50 abaissants pardon le seuil de
déclenchement du dispositif de 300 à 50
salariés elle était adoptée a fait le
choix de rejeter l'article et c'était
pour moi une déception et j'ai vu que
cette sécurité partagée puisque le
lendemain de cette suppression votre
commission les affaires sociales
auditionner les organisations syndicales
et Monsieur ricordo qui serait
internationale la CFDT a dit qu'il
regrettait la suppression d'index a dit
qu'il considéraits ne progressera
qu'avec le dialogue social et qu'en
supprimant l'index l'Assemblée nationale
avait pris le chemin inverse et ils
disent ça notamment parce qu'on renvoie
la définition des critères et la
possibilité de leur adaptation au
dialogue social interprofessionnel pour
le décret de fixation des critères et au
dialogues sociales de bronches pour
l'adaptation c'est pour ça que nous
avons un index qui renvoie à ce rôle des
partenaires sociaux pour définir les
bons indicateurs et la bonne mise en
oeuvre donc je m'arrête là mais
évidemment pour ces deux raisons
complémentaires en plus de ce que j'ai
dit la vie est défavorable
bien donc nous avons un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
ministre sur ces amendements de
suppression avant de les soumettre aux
voix j'ai des demandes d'explication de
vote madame Carlotti
et oui merci monsieur le Président moi
je souhaite soutenir les amendements de
suppression de cet article 2 car nous
devrions même pas en discuter ça a été
très bien dit par ma collègue tout à
l'heure et oui d'après la vie secrète du
Conseil d'État il s'agirait d'un
cavalier social qui pourrait même être
inconstitutionnel alors tout à l'heure
la droite n'a pas voulu que cet article
soit renvoyé en commission mais c'est
vraiment fort dommage surtout quand je
viens d'entendre le président de la
Commission on aurait pu ensemble
remettre tout à plat faire de vraies
propositions pour le maintien en emploi
des seniors pour envisager des
procédures de reconversion la
transmission des savoirs la valorisation
de leur de leur expérience personnelle
et aussi parler de du niveau de leur
pension il y a vrai véritablement là un
enjeu de société qui mériterait qu'on
s'y attarde j'espère d'ailleurs que le
projet de loi sur le travail en sera
l'occasion puis du coup en fait au lieu
de ça au lieu d'avoir de se débat
complet finalement on tourne autour de
la mesure gadget de l'index senior donc
c'est pas normal c'est pas sérieux c'est
pas suffisant c'est pas comme ça qu'on
devrait répondre à la situation des
seniors on demande donc et je soutiens
le retrait de cet article et même je
soutiens monsieur le ministre le retrait
de votre réforme car vous voyons voyait
bien qu'au fur et à mesure elle n'est
pas aboutie
monsieur Kerrouche
voilà nous interrompons quelques
instants à ces explications de vote
autour de l'article 2 alors que de très
nombreux amendements de suppressions ont
été déposées défendues par la gauche
Audrey c'est vraiment le moment de
l'offensive de la gauche contre c'est
index senior à laquelle on assiste cet
après-midi oui et ça a peut-être surpris
nos téléspectateurs avant les avis de la
commission et du gouvernement ce sont
les groupes de gauche qui ont eu la
parole pendant de très nombreuses
minutes ils avaient déposé une
cinquantaine d'amendements rien que pour
supprimer l'article de à part une
parenthèse enchantée de débat avec la
droite ce matin on voit que la gauche
pardon multiplié les prises de parole
officiellement pour donner aux Français
le débat qu'ils n'ont pas eu à
l'Assemblée nationale officieusement on
nous dit en coulisses qu'on ne veut pas
que l'article 7 celui sur l'allongement
de l'âge de départ en retraite soit
examiner et voter avant la grande
journée de manifestations de mardi en
face on voit une droite quasi mutique
qui ne prend pas la parole car elle ne
veut pas ralentir d'autant plus les
débats la droite qui aimerait un vote
sur le texte dans son entier d'ici
dimanche merci merci beaucoup Audrey
pour toutes ces explications la droite
que l'on entendra peut-être un petit peu
plus sur les articles additionnels après
l'article 2 pour soutenir et bien l'une
de ces propositions la mise en place
d'un CDI senior avec des exonérations de
charges patronales famille pour inciter
les entreprises et bien à garder les
seniors dans les entreprises l'emploi
des seniors un vrai sujet de
préoccupation dans le cadre de cette
réforme des retraites retour tout de
suite au débat dans l'hémicycle c'est à
présent Thomas d'aussi le sénateur
écologiste qui est en train de
s'exprimer vous nous proposez que ce
formulaire un formulaire qui serait le
préalable à une politique ambitieuse que
vous nous annoncer plus tard et dont
nous n'avons pour l'instant aucune piste
concrète et on devrait commencer par
voter cette index et vous faire
confiance pour la suite et on va se
l'avouer c'est compliqué de vous faire
confiance en ce moment monsieur le
ministre après beaucoup d'enfumage mais
c'est encore plus compliqué de vous
faire confiance quand on connaît votre
pudeur lorsqu'il s'agit d'imposer la
moindre mesure aux entreprises on l'a
encore vu récemment avec le panier
anti-inflation et pourtant il va falloir
agir les probabilités de retour à
l'emploi après 50 ans sont très faibles
les Français considèrent qu'avoir plus
de 55 ans et le premier motif de rejet
lors des embauches à compétences égales
en 2021 les testings réalisés par la
Dares montent une personne ayant entre
48 et 55 ans à 3 fois moins de chance
d'être appelé pour un entretien qu'un
qu'une personne entre 23 et 30 ans selon
la DG trésor la part des chômeurs de
longue durée plus d'un an chez les
chômeurs de plus de 55 ans en 2018 de
60% et le report de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits à 65 ans va donc aggraver
dramatiquement ce sas de précarité des
catégories Aires et le chômage des
seniors votre réforme est donc brutale
et injuste madame Vogel
merci monsieur le Président
évidemment je vais voter les articles de
suppression de l'article 2 euh tout
d'abord parce que je crois que comme
beaucoup d'entre nous dans cette
assemblée je suis attachée au respect de
la Constitution et je ne vois pas bien
l'intérêt de voter une mesure quand nous
savons puisque j'ai lu le monde même si
je suis très triste de ne pas avoir pu
lire la vie mais j'ai lu le monde et il
semble que cette disposition de la loi
sera censurée donc je comprends pas bien
à quoi ça sert qu'on la vote surtout au
Sénat nous qui sommes attachés au
respect de la Constitution ensuite parce
que je suis aussi attaché au
parlementarisme et à respecter le choix
de l'Assemblée nationale qui a retiré
cet article alors même que la droite et
la majorité présidentielle se plaignait
que les débats n'est pas pu avoir lieu
et quand ils ont lieu et bien ça ne les
intéresse pas
sur
on a eu l'occasion de le dire et j'ai
bien conscience qu'on l'a dit qu'on l'a
dit de nombreuses fois mais néanmoins
c'est vrai
cet article ne va servir à absolument
rien c'est pour ça qu'il est
anticonstitutionnel s'il était
constitutionnel ce serait parce qu'il
aurait un impact sur les finances
publiques cette année et donc il servait
à amener des cotisations sociales par
exemple donc moi ma question c'est aussi
à tous mes collègues qui vont voter
contre ces amendements et donc ils
veulent garder l'index des seniors dans
le texte de loi est-ce qu'ils vont aussi
voter pour tous nos amendements qui
consistent à faire que cet index servent
à quelque chose qui soit associé à des
sanctions qu'ils permettent de faire
quelque chose en réalité qui va
permettre d'avoir un impact positif sur
les finances publiques parce que sinon à
quoi ça sert de voter en faveur d'un
truc qui ne sert absolument à rien et de
rejeter toutes les propositions que vous
allez voir parce que nous sommes quand
même constructifs vous en avons beaucoup
toutes les itions qui consistent à faire
que cet article de est un impact
merci Madame pour ce poli
merci monsieur le Président alors tout
d'abord je voulais vraiment remercier
Monsieur Savary parce que vraiment
pouvoir nous permettre de consulter les
notes du Conseil
constitutionnels c'est une avancée
concis des tailles excusez moi c'est une
avancée considérable monsieur Savary
depuis on a perdu beaucoup de temps
autour de ça depuis jeudi nous aurions
pu les consulter
non non non non non c'était secret il
n'y avait que le président de La Mecque
qui pouvait les avoir nous ne pouvions
pas les avoir nous n'avions pas le droit
de les consulter tout à l'heure quand
j'ai causé la présidente de la
commission madame de roche m'a dit
qu'elles étaient secrètes ces notes et
que je ne pouvais pas en disposer si
donc bon en tous les cas il y a une
avancée
et nous la prenons et nous sommes
contents monsieur Savary et je vais
venir je vais venir je vais venir
monsieur ça varie on va passer une
petite nuit ensemble on va regarder les
choses avec les collègues et puis on va
consulter ses notes secrètes qui de
toute façon ne devrait pas l'être de
toute façon
elle ne devrait pas être secrète mais
bon on va venir monsieur Savary ne vous
inquiétez pas on est content alors
évidemment nous allons aussi voter la
suppression de l'article 2 alors si vous
préférez évidemment pas une nuit une
journée peut-être
d'abord parce que il est à cavalier
social et que nous souhaitons pour notre
part ça a été dit une véritable loi
travail la réalité monsieur le ministre
c'est votre gouvernement a une fois de
plus répandue favorablement au MEDEF en
refusant d'associer l'index Seigneur à
des sanctions financières
aucun pouvoir de contrainte donc aucun
effet voilà la réalité là et donc nous
voterons pour la suppression de
l'article 2 monsieur Moga
merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues
reconnaissons que cet article n'est pas
le coeur de cette réforme par contre
elle renvoie à l'essentiel cette notion
de travail des seniors et le vrai
problème que nous avons en France par
rapport aux autres pays c'est
effectivement le taux d'activité des
seniors comme des jeunes donc la
question c'est comment on augmente le
taux d'activité en l'occurrence des
seniors qui effectivement sont plus
touchés par le chômage ils souffrent
d'une attitude bien française qu'il
faudra changer et dans le temps qu'il se
trouve les plus souvent et bien mis à la
porte notamment des grandes entreprises
lorsqu'elle dépense sociaux ça c'est une
réalité ça renvoie aux usages aux
coutumes et l'État à travers les
entreprises dont l'État a encore des
participations est loin de montrer
l'exemple donc il y aura des choses à
faire donc j'aurais presque plus
reprendre mot pour mot l'intervention du
président rénal tout à l'heure le
problème c'est qu'on a mis encore une
fois les choses à l'envers et Monsieur
le Ministre et Monsieur dussobe tout à
l'heure nous disait qu'il y aura une loi
sur le travail son insertion la
formation mais pourquoi n'avons pas
commencé par cela
moi je regrette fortement que cette
partie de l'hémicycle n'est pas
suffisamment fait pression sur le
gouvernement pour que ça passe d'abord
sur le travail et qu'après on travaille
tranquillement sereinement sur les
retraites parce que mettez-vous à la
place des nombreux personnes qui
travaillent moins les plus grandes
entreprises que les PME les PMI et vous
voyez tout j'imagine dans les tribunaux
de commerce de vos territoires augmenter
et bien les dossiers qui arrivent car il
nous a pas échappé que nous vivons une
période d'inflation une période de des
punir une période d'augmentation des
prix d'énergie que ça se retrouve
partout et que nous avons des
entreprises qui vont faire faillite la
mettez-vous simplement à la place des
travailleurs travailleuses pour
apprendre une expression un peu plus
âgées aux autres 55 ans et bien ils
peuvent être légitimement inquiets par
cette réforme donc il faut pas s'étonner
qui est beaucoup de monde dans la rue la
semaine prochaine donc moi j'aurais
vraiment souhaité parce que la fusée de
cette réforme si on met les étages à
l'envers elle n'est pas prête de
décoller donc moi je voterai cet article
et la réforme on verra
monsieur Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement c'est toujours à l'envers
un petit texte rectificatif pour une
grande ambition c'est quand même assez
étonnant ce petit texte qui va quand
même permettre à l'administration
française de faire des exploits puisque
les entreprises d'au moins 1000 salariés
devront publier des indicateurs relatifs
à l'emploi des salariés âgés dès le
premier novembre 2023 en France nous
allons aller vite et ils seront
sanctionnés avant le 31 décembre 2023
c'est assez de conditions-là qu'il
pourrait y avoir des recettes dont les
annexes nous rappellent que compte tenu
de la compatibilité des régimes sécurité
sociale est enregistrée en droit
constaté le produit d'une sanction
juridiquement prononcée et notifié avant
le 31 décembre 2023 sera rattachée à
l'exercice 2023 vraiment on mène les
entreprises dans ce pays en étant aussi
sévère on publie un index obligatoire au
1er novembre et on les sanctionnera
avant le 31 décembre
plus sérieusement sur le fond de ce
propos monsieur le rapporteur je
voudrais vous dire une chose moi je
souhaite effectivement que nous
améliorons les conditions de travail les
conditions de maintien dans l'emploi de
tous les salariés pas jusqu'à 64 ans pas
on a en allongeant la durée du travail
mais jusqu'à l'âge légal du travail et à
partir de 55 ans ou le taux d'emploi est
très faible mais je ne veux pas le faire
dans un texte qui est un texte dont
l'objectif est de maintenir et de
prolonger de deux années de plus au
travail je souhaite le faire dans une
loi travail débattue et négocier avec
les partenaires sociaux sur cet aspect
là je sais que nous nous rejoignons sur
la volonté qui est débat
madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président il faut une
véritable loi travail votre gouvernement
monsieur le ministre a supprimé les
CHSCT la transparence est donc
nécessaire une vraie loi travail
pourrait nous permettre de mieux
échanger dans cette mystique cette
mesure n'aura aucun impact réel dans les
territoires d'outre-mer je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure mais je vous le répète
dans ce contexte d'inflation et de vie
chère il faut de vrais mesures pour
combattre le chômage et améliorer la
qualité de vie l'index senior ne peut en
aucun cas être une vraie solution il
faut une loi complète bien réfléchie
partagez avec les partenaires sociaux
une loi pertinente et bien pensée cet
article doit être supprimé c'est un
cavalier social limité injuste qui ne
propose que des maltraitances envers les
seniors démunis et déjà précaire merci
merci donc nous en avons terminé avec
les explications
madame poncer mon j'ai excusez-moi je ne
vous avais pointu oui je voudrais dire à
Alain Milon que je suis sûr qu'il a tout
compris mais que moi en général je
réponds aux rapporteur et au ministre
donc c'est forcément après donc
justement vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre c'est index c'est très bien
vous avez redécouvert le dialogue social
il sera discuté en interpro et par
branche tant mieux et que les os sont
des propositions il y a pas que la CFDT
tout elles ont toutes des propositions
mais puisque souvent le CFDT est cité je
vous rappelle qu'elle est contre et
qu'elle vous demande leur retrait de
cette loi
moi j'ai si vous voulez ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que cette loi
s'applique dès septembre donc elle va
s'appliquer aux gens qui ont entre 58 59
60 61 ans et de façon brutale et
immédiate c'est là où on va faire les
économies qui va vous permettre
d'être à 3% 2027 pour pour maestrich
alors aussi à partir de là si vous
voulez il est bien certain que tout ce
qu'on va dire sur l'index n'a pas de
défait c'est sur cette population là
c'est déjà trop tard et c'est pourtant
elle qui sont sollicités d'ici 2027 et
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que ben
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
qu'en fait il faut changer le travail il
y a pas que le taux d'emploi des seniors
qui pose un problème il y a celui des
femmes il y a celui des jeunes il y a
celui des seigneurs il y a celui des
personnes en situation de handicap donc
vous voyez bien que ça vous nous avez
promis une loi cette année l'index
aurait pu en parler cette année Nancy il
est là c'est pour vous servir de caution
à ceux qui ont y compris la CFDT refuse
c'est-à-dire l'ouverture le décalage de
l'ouverture des droits à la retraite
monsieur Chantrel
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur Savary vous nous
avez dit dans votre propos mais écoutez
les syndicats qui sont d'accord pour
cette annexe et d'ailleurs ils sont pas
unanimes sur le sujet mais vous ne les
écoutez pas sur le retrait de la réforme
alors que là pour le coup ils sont
uneanime ils se mobilisent constamment
depuis des semaines et des semaines et
là par contre vous ne les écoutez pas
donc c'est vraiment à deux vitesses et
cet article est ne résoudra pas le
problème de l'emploi des seniors s'il
est pas assorti de la moindre contrainte
tous ces indicateurs ils sont dénués et
vous le savez très bien de la moindre
obligation ils sont complètement bidon
il permet de seulement aux entreprises
qui attribuent les labels de fer du
profit imposent une couche de
bureaucratie supplémentaire à toutes les
autres la vérité c'est que votre réforme
va créer un sas de pauvreté pour les
seniors à 62 ans 40% de ceux qui ne sont
pas la retraite ne travaillent pas
parmi eux parmi eux un tiers vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté votre effort qui
file l'axe de départ justement à la
retraite à 75 ans et violente et cruelle
va accentuer cette cette pauvreté
d'après l'Observatoire français de
conjectures économiques qui est un
observatoire sérieux elle se traduira
justement par 277 000 chômeurs
supplémentaires 400 000 nouveaux arrêts
de travail pour maladies
professionnelles et 110 000 personnes de
plus au minima sociaux au bout du compte
si vous voulez réellement faire quelque
chose pour les seniors commencez par
faire en sorte d'empêcher qu'il soit
licenciés et ensuite lutter contre la
discrimination à l'embauche qu'il
subisse comment faire me demanderez-vous
et bien en leur donnant des droits ainsi
qu'au syndicats afin qu'ils puissent se
défendre
le président rénal
en sur un point monsieur président merci
sur un point quand même qui est rappelé
qui est quand même dedans c'est tous
qu'il est faux
c'est le rapport entre ce texte et puis
l'année 2023 du point de vue financier
et budgétaire bon c'est tout ce que
c'est faux et si à la limite on voulait
faire un effort en se disant qui on y
croit un instant il suffirait de se
souvenir de ce qui nous a été expliqué
encore une fois récemment sur la réforme
de la CVAE ou sur la réforme de la C2 un
des sujets et de dire que si on veut
allouer aux entreprises par nos
collectivités ce qu'elles recevait avant
il faut que les entreprises puissent
conserver le juste comptage de leur
salarié et le donner l'administration et
bien on nous a dit à l'époque que
c'était un faisable que les entreprises
on ne pouvait plus d'un instant ou en
supprimer la CVE leur demander cet
effort de juste comptabiliser leur poste
de travail et le donner à
l'administration fiscale c'était
infaisable un truc basicum basique et là
où nous explique qu'on va appliquer un
texte donc qui va s'appliquer début
septembre où on va demander aux
entreprises l'air de rien de remplir des
fichiers pour le mois
fin octobre et ensuite qu'on va s’il ne
se rende pas s'ils ne font pas les
choses on va les taxer tout ça dans la
même année
ça veut rien dire quoi voilà alors on
peut faire semblant de le croire voilà
mais je crois que franchement ici
personne ne peut croire à une à une
telle une telle chose donc effectivement
je pense que il y a du travail pour le
Conseil constitut
à ce moment du débat ayant écouté aussi
le ministre tout à l'heure je une
remarque m'est venue parce que c'est
c'est quand même incroyable
notre démocratie est assez malade
ce matin encore le JDD nous annonce avec
une nouvelle enquête d'opinion que ça le
32% des Français sont favorables à cette
réforme et si l'on regarde les moins de
35 ans c'est-à-dire ceux qui vont être
plus concernés
64%, et ceux qui ne sont pas concernés à
50%. je sais pas si on se rend compte du
sujet nous sommes ici en train de
discuter d'une réforme dont on sait que
deux tiers des Français la rejettent que
pourrait faire le gouvernement et
d'ailleurs vous aussi à droite de
discuter avec ceux qui sont opposés à la
réforme nous
qui représentons à peu près l'opinion de
deux tiers des Français pour voir
comment on règle dans cet enceinte ce
problème démocratique c'est-à-dire que
le gouvernement nous interrompons
quelques instants les débats on va
rejoindre tout de suite Audrey viettaz
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat Audrey parce
qu'il y a eu plusieurs fois et bien des
allusions à une note confidentielle du
Conseil d'État peut-être une allusion un
peu ésotérique pour certains de nos
téléspectateurs est-ce que vous pouvez
un petit peu éclairer leur lanterne et
la nôtre également oui pour éclairer
noter les spectateurs la note dont parle
de très nombreux sénateurs c'est un avis
du Conseil d'État dans lequel il
émettrai des doutes sur la
constitutionnalité de la réforme un avis
qui n'avait pas vocation à être rendu
public mais qui a fuité en partie dans
la presse alors depuis je dis les
sénateurs des groupes de gauche
demandent à prendre connaissance de cet
avis le demande au gouvernement mais le
gouvernement n'y est pas obligé il ne
semble pas disposer tout à l'heure René
Paul Savary le rapporteur de la
commission a peut-être émis une solution
en sa qualité de président de la mission
de contrôle de la sécurité sociale il
peut prendre connaissance de cet avis et
en part et en parler au sénateur qui en
ferait à la demande on a peut-être donc
trouvé la solution à un problème qui se
pose depuis le début des débats depuis
jeudi effectivement c'est un sujet qui a
largement un venimé les débats notamment
hier soir merci beaucoup Audrey pour
toutes ces explications avec moi pour
prolonger sur l'examen de la réforme des
retraites du plaisir d'accueillir
claudemanürel bonjour vous êtes
président du groupe Les Indépendants
Claude malurey déjà un mot sur la façon
dont ce déroule les débats depuis le
milieu de l'après-midi on entend à peu
près seulement la gauche est-ce que
c'est frustrant
oh non c'était prévu alors à partir du
moment où j'ai prévu on prend ces
dispositions et puis voilà
on savait que il y aurait de
l'obstruction ça va être l'idée c'était
de reculer le vote l'idée c'était
d'abord d'examiner l'article 7 à partir
de mardi prochain donc il faut tenir
jusque là et puis ensuite peut-être
c'est je ne sais pas mais arrivé à ce
qu'on comme à l'Assemblée on ne puisse
pas voter c'est pas si c'est la tactique
la stratégie ou non mais c'était attendu
et par conséquent tout le monde est prêt
comment qualifiez-vous ces débats on a
parlé nous d'une obstruction
cordiale courtoise est-ce que c'est bien
là la teneur des échanges c'est ce que
je dirais aussi parce que évidemment
tout le monde se rappelle les images de
l'Assemblée les images
catastrophiques catastrophique d'abord
pour ceux qui l'ont lancé pour la France
insoumise qui a transformé ses dessins
souhaits d'ailleurs l'Assemblée
nationale en ZAD pendant quelques
semaines et catastrophique pour l'image
du Parlement donc il était important et
je crois que c'est le cas de tout le
monde ici qu'on soit pour ou contre la
loi de montrer qu'on peut avoir ce débat
d'une façon digne ça n'empêche pas
l'obstruction c'est une tactique
parlementaire classique et par
conséquent le retard le fait de parler
longtemps pour pouvoir retarder le vote
mais ça se passe vous le voyez chaque
minute dans une ambiance complètement
différente dans une annonce républicaine
dans une langue sérieuse dans une
ambiance digne et je crois que le
Parlement en avait besoin parce que le
spectacle de l'assemblée a été une vraie
catastrophe pour la démocratie
vous avez souvent la dent dure un
vis-à-vis du groupe communiste là ce
n'est pas le cas vous trouvez aussi que
là
normal et ils font leur un boulot
d'obstruction ils ne s'en cache pas mais
ils le font pas du tout comme la fée le
groupe LFI à l'Assemblée nationale donc
j'ai rien je suis bien entendu pas
d'accord avec eux je pense qu'ils ont
tort de s'opposer à une réforme qui est
mathématiquement indispensable
économiquement indispensable pour sauver
le régime par répartition ils veulent
absolument le sauver c'est ce qu'il
disait ils sont contrologie par
cabinisation mais si on ne modifie pas
ce régime et bien ce régime va
s'effondrer démographiquement et par
conséquent ils sont en train de se tirer
une balle dans le pied mais ils le font
avec la sérénité du Sénat on a pu lire
ce matin dans le Parisien interview
d'Olivier du Sapt qui a qualifié de la
réforme de réforme de gauche une réforme
qui ne fait pas de est-ce que vous
sentez de gauche Claude malurec en vous
soutenez cette réforme je pense pas que
c'est une réforme de droit toute gauche
c'est une réforme pour sans laquelle le
régime par la partition va tomber donc
comme la droite et la gauche sont
d'accord sur le régime par répartition
une partie de la droite et c'est mon cas
sont pour ajouter au régime par
répartition un régime par capitalisation
collective pas individuelle mais
collective comme ça se fait dans le pays
d'Europe dedans d'ailleurs le problème
c'est qu'on y viendra puisque d'année en
année l'équilibre démographique seront
on est obligé tous les 5 ans on l'a vu
avec la jeune fille avec la femme
Touraine et maintenant avec la réforme
du swap on est obligé tous les 5 ans de
voter des choses supplémentaires et des
contraintes supplémentaires la seule
solution pour ne plus être obligé de le
faire c'est d'avoir comme par exemple
chez les fonctionnaires avec la Préfon
ou comme chez des pharmaciens ou comme
dans d'autres systèmes un système qu'on
pourrait étendre à tout le monde qui
combine la répartition la capitalisation
collective un jour ou l'autre on y
viendra et on a entendu dire le
gouvernement qui n'y était pas favorable
donc pour le coup là vous êtes vraiment
en phase avec la droite sénatoriale
alors le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable pour une raison que je
comprends c'est que il est face à une
contestation de l'ensemble des syndicats
de beaucoup de pari l'ensemble des
partis politiques de gauche et qu'il ne
veut pas charger la barque mais je pense
que voilà donc je comprends
[Musique]
qu'il cherche à se dire par quels moyens
cette réforme peut-elle acceptable et
peut-elle passer en définitive mais un
jour ou l'autre peut-être pas tout de
suite mais dans 5 ans dans 10 ans à mon
avis bien avant 10 ans on y viendra
parce que ce régime est en train de
montrer ses limites une mobilisation
très forte est attendue le 7 mars contre
cette réforme des retraites une
véritable journée noire peut-elle mettre
à mal la réforme pour vous je n'en sais
rien tout ce que je sais c'est que c'est
inéluctable
Fillon un million de personnes dans la
rue Touraine en millions de personnes
dans la rue la SNCF un million peut-être
pas tout à fait dans la rue et là un
million de personnes dans la rue chaque
fois qu'on fait une réforme des
retraites d'enfants on l'a fait dans
tous les pays européens vous le savez
il y a pas de gens dans la rue parce que
dans les autres pays Européens on n'a
pas cette cette culture systématiquement
de la manifestation et de se prendre
pour les sans-culottes pendant quelques
jours chaque fois qu'on est pas d'accord
donc il y aura cette mobilisation ça je
crois pas que ça changera grand chose en
revanche
si
les syndicats aussi un certain nombre de
forces politiques décident de faire ce
qui s'est passé ce qui se passe souvent
et notamment ce qui s'est passé à la fin
de l'année dernière c'est-à-dire une
grève totale reconductive etc je suis
pas sûr que les Français apprécient
cette façon de s'opposer et donc pour
vous ça serait plutôt une façon de se
mettre les Français ados à mon avis au
début vous savez comment ça se passe au
début c'est un peu populaire parce qu'on
se dit voilà il s'opposent et puis au
bout de quelques jours quand on empêche
les gens d'aller au travail quand ou
quand on leur rend essayer la situation
beaucoup plus difficile tout le monde ne
peut pas travailler aujourd'hui et par
conséquent ce genre de situation ça
ça impacte ceux qui sont dans des
conditions sociales plus difficiles et
qui ne télétravail pas et qui doivent
aller au travail tous les jours et
utiliser en voiture donc prendre de
l'essence utiliser le métro le train et
par conséquent je me suis pour la raison
pour laquelle ce genre de grève
reconductible et permanente pendant un
certain temps finit toujours par être
très impopulaire mais à eux de décider
ce qu'il compte faire merci merci
beaucoup Claude malurey
d'avoir tout de cet article 2 qui met en
place l'index senior on prend donc la
direction de l'hémicycle c'est Corinne
Ferret c'est notre spécialiste qui
s'exprime à présent un actif peut être
considéré comme seniors c'est l'objet de
l'amendement que notre groupe a déposé
en le fixant à 55 ans si vous en êtes
d'accord monsieur le Président
j'évoquerai l'amendement suivant qui est
un amendement d'appel qui l'objet était
exactement le même on va dire mais qui a
fixé le plancher la plancher à 50 ans
donc vous avez deux amendements un qui
fixent le plancher à 50 ans et l'autre à
55 ans c'est bien ça
pour être dans l'ordre le
2613 c'est 50 ans et le 2614 55
donc ensuite le
2751 madame Poumirol
merci monsieur le Président l'article de
tel qu'il est rédigé actuellement est en
place donc un index senior sans
contrepartie financière et qui n'a
absolument été négocié avec les
organisations syndicales nous vous avons
entendu ce rapporteur donc le Frozone
d'autres propositions et dans cet
amendement nous demandons que ces index
actuellement
inefficaces puissent remplacées par un
index qualitatif qualitatif donc qui
porte sur la formation l'acquisition de
nouvelles compétences l'amélioration de
la qualité de vie au travail
l'aménagement de poste ou le temps de
travail qui sont des facteurs
extrêmement importants sur le plan de la
santé au travail de nos seniors il
faudra que cette index qualitatif soit
négocié paritairement et ils deviendrait
alors il pourrait être alors mis en
place en même temps des sanctions
différenciées en fonction de la taille
des entreprises cela pourrait rendre
ainsi ce dispositif efficient
[Musique]
merci Madame Poumirol donc ensuite le
l'amendement
4126 madame gréaume merci monsieur le
Président alors l'amendement 4126 c'est
pour remplacer le terme poursuit par met
en oeuvre pour créer une obligation
d'atteinte du maintien dans l'emploi des
seniors je ne peux vous faire l'économie
de la lecture de l'alinéa que nous
souhaitons modifier l'employeur poursuit
un objectif d'amélioration de l'embauche
et du maintien en activité des seniors
mais sincèrement est-ce que c'est
respecté le travail législatif que de
demander aux entreprises un objectif
d'amélioration est-ce que c'est respecté
l'enjeu de l'emploi des seniors que de
leur promettent un objectif
d'amélioration c'est le sens de toute la
philosophie de cette réforme des
retraites et plus largement de votre
politique économique et sociale on va
demander aux entreprises de ce serait
bien que les employeurs fassent et
souvent sans résultat
dans cette réforme l'augmentation de
cotisations employeur sera compensée par
un transfert des cotisations accidents
du travail et maladie professionnelle
par conséquent rien n'est demandé aux
employeurs dans cette réforme c'est du
jamais vu dans chacune des réformes que
notre pays a connu dans votre politique
économique et sociale nous demandons un
total de faire un geste sur les
carburants total est laissé complètement
seul pour fixer la nature et le montant
de ce geste débouche sur des carburants
ou en deçà de 2 euros a pris
singulièrement plus élevé que les coûts
de production appris qui n'est pas
d'actualité dans la politique des gestes
les distributeurs boucles émissaires du
gouvernement peut être trop gourmand
mais quid des fournisseurs dans la
politique des gestes on avait eu des
assureurs pendant le covid alors que
nous concitoyennes et nos concitoyens ne
pouvaient sortir de chez eux ils ne
pouvait causer d'accidents à partir de
ce constat nous disons qu'il fallait
taxer les assureurs ou qu'il diminue
d'autant leur contrat l'année suivante
le gouv ernement leur a demandé de faire
un geste vous avez créé un outil
politique d'un nouveau genre l'aumône
gouvernementale la supplique plutôt que
la loi votre doctrine monsieur les
ministres c'est le principe même de la
philosophie libérale du laisser faire
laisser passer cette doctrine vise à
enjoindre au pouvoir politique de
laisser les agents économiques les plus
libres possibles c'est sûr que vous ne
les dérangez pas cette index ne les
dérangera pas
merci
l'amendement
4655 madame Vogel merci monsieur le
président
repli pour également améliorer cette
index d'une autre manière bon d'abord
pour élargir les informations que qui
seraient publiées dans cette index en
ayant pas seulement de taux d'emploi
mais aussi des informations sur les
conditions de travail des seniors sur
l'adaptabilité de leur poste etc ensuite
en ayant des des notes minimales à
atteindre parce que ça sert à rien
d'avoir simplement des informations
comme ça si on n'a pas des objectifs
donc cet amendement propose d'avoir des
objectifs et puis des conséquences au
fait que les entreprises n'atteignent
pas les objectifs avec une demande
d'avoir par décret des sanctions
financières appliquées aux entreprises
qui ne respecteraient pas ces objectifs
ce qui est quand même un peu a priori la
raison pour laquelle on met en place un
index n'est-ce pas c'est pas simplement
pour pouvoir observer de loin le monde
des entreprises c'est quand même pour
avoir un impact sur elle je crois que
c'est pour ça qu'on fait la loi et puis
aussi des pour améliorer l'implication
des partenaires sociaux dans la
conception de l'index vous avez dit
répéter que certains partenaires sociaux
étaient en faveur de certains ex et bien
j'espère que vous accorderez avec nous
sur le fait que il serait bien de les
associer et puis également ramener la
date d'application au premier janvier
2024 pour les entreprises qui ont plus
de 299 salariés et pour cette entre 50
et 299 au 1er juillet 2024 nous aurons
d'autres amendements que nous
discuterons dans la suite pour améliorer
cette index mais vous voyez que nous
avons beaucoup de propositions nous
essayons d'aborder la chose de manière
constructive
l'idée n'est pas de rejeter l'index en
soi c'est de rejeter un index qui ne
sert à rien donc j'espère que ça
t'intéresse à la fin de la discussion
pourra servir à quelque chose et que
vous pourrez nous donner des raisons de
le voter
bien merci ensuite deux amendements
identiques le premier le 2753 est
présenté par Monsieur Assouline oui
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains visent à
préciser le contenu de l'objectif
d'amélioration de l'embauche et du
maintien en activité des salariés âgés
qui traitera des thèmes suivants
un le recrutement des salariés âgé dans
l'entreprise de l'anticipation de
l'évolution des carrières
professionnelles trois l'amélioration
des conditions de travail et prévention
des situations de pénibilité
quatre le développement des compétences
et des qualifications et accès à la
formation 5 l'aménagement des fins de
carrière et de la transition entre
activités et retraite et la transmission
des savoirs et des compétences et
développement du tutorat
voilà ce que contient l'amendement
concrètement et
les nouveaux retraités du régime général
avait validé des trimestres dans le
cadre de l'emploi durant les mois
précédents la liquidation de leurs
droits à la retraite selon le corps ils
étaient
ils étaient le chiffre exact étant
excusez-moi
bon je vous donnerai un emploi durant
bon
les 25% selon le corps n'avait validé
aucun trimestre dans l'année précédente
de leur retraite en 2019 un rapport
sénatorial votre rapport monsieur Savary
avec Madame Monique Lubin s'est épanché
sur le défi des fins de carrière vous
aviez mis en évidence un marché du
travail
plus pour les personnes les plus âgées
avec une prévalence de chômage de longue
durée plus importante chez les plus de
50 ans que dans la moyenne les
demandeurs d'emploi l'enjeu pour notre
système de retraite
voilà et ben j'arrête il y a pas de
problème
il y en a un autre après je continuerai
où il y a un deuxième amendement
identique le 4129 présenté par Monsieur
ouzulias Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre mais mes chers
collègues j'ai du mal qu'on a à
comprendre quand même monsieur le
rapporteur mais je pars revenir sur le
débat sur la différence d'appréciation
que vous portez sur l'article premier
bisque que vous avez refusé et sur
l'article 2 que vous acceptez or on
aurait pu parfaitement mobiliser
l'argumentaire de l'article premier bis
qui vous a permis de le refuser contre
contre l'article 2 mais puisqu'il faut
en venir à cet article ce qui est très
gênant c'est que cet article ne définit
pas les index alors
l'article en question renvoie tout ça un
décret pris en Conseil d'État et pour
une loi d'urgence ça pose quand même
problème on est dans une loi de finance
rectificative qui renvoie un certain
nombre de dispositions à des décrets
pris en conseiller état je peux prendre
ici le pari que les décrets pris en
concert d'et nous les aurons pas avant
la loi de finances de de cette année et
par ailleurs votre votre gouvernement
avait pris une toute autre option quand
il s'agissait de définir les critères
dont la loi du 5 septembre 2018 c'est
l'article 104 vous n'aviez pas défini
précisément les critères en revanche que
vous aviez fait d'un point de vue
législatif c'est donner par la loi un
cadrage qui permettrait la définition de
de ces index et je pense que ça aurait
été une meilleure solution je vous
proposerai dans dans un amendement futur
un certain nombre de cadrage pour
permettre la définition de ses index
merci monsieur le président
merci ensuite le 3465 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors par
cet amendement le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire propose d'établir
un barème d'évaluation des indicateurs
et d'établir oui des sanctions pour
résultat insuffisants mais différencier
selon la taille de l'entreprise alors il
y a trois je crois 3 ou 4 niveaux
d'entreprises qui sont comme d'habitude
défini soit par le nombre l'effectif le
nombre de personnes embauchées soit par
le chiffre d'affaires annuel soit par le
total de du bilan bien donc c'est index
donc
aurait un impact d'autant plus faible
que l'obligation
si elle l'obligation ne portait pas sur
la queue sur la publication de l'index
et non sur l'obtention de résultats
satisfaisants de progrès quoi un petit
peu comme pour les femmes où il faut un
plan d'action il suffira ainsi pour une
entreprise
les élèves en matière d'emploi des
seniors de simplement publier l'index
pour échapper à une sanction et on a vu
que c'était peu efficace donc il est
donc évident que c'est index sera un
impôt un impact nul c'est un dispositif
d'évaluation chiffré qui inclut un score
minimum à atteindre forcément sous peine
de sanction n'est pas mis en place ces
sanctions financières doivent également
être adaptés à la taille des entreprises
je l'ai dit ces différencier qui ne
disposent pas des mêmes ressources
notamment RH pour mettre en place une
telle mesure
merci ensuite le 4656 madame Vogel merci
monsieur le Président
cet abandon vise à élargir le nombre
d'entreprises qui seraient concernées
par la l'obligation de publier cette
index
en limitant seulement la non publication
aux entreprises qui ont moins de 10
salariés c'est quand même 96,2% des
entreprises françaises qui sont des
micro-entreprises mais de d'obliger les
entreprises à publier l'index dès
qu'elles ont au moins 11 salariés
en abaissant le seuil de 300 salariés à
50 salariés qui seraient déjà un pas
dans la bonne direction on rajouterait
environ 5000 entreprises à l'obligation
de publication
en effet il y a environ
4520 entreprises qui emploient entre 50
et 249 salariés mais c'est pas assez
parce que ça exclut toujours toutes les
micro-entreprises et les PME et la
majeure partie des entreprises
françaises comme j'ai dit au début 96%
sont des petites entreprises la moitié
des Françaises et des Français sont
employés par des micro-entreprises ou
des PME
il faut donc dans la mesure du possible
élargir le champ d'application d'index
des seniors pour améliorer la
transparence en espérant que plus
d'entreprises emploient des Seigneur son
effet essentiel pour permettre au
Seigneur qui devrait travailler plus si
cette réforme était mise en oeuvre de
trouver un emploi nous pensons également
qu'un élargissement de l'index à des
entreprises de plus de 11 salariés ne
représenterait pas une charge
insurmontable pour ces entreprises quand
on a 11 salariés on voit vite en fait
combien il y a de seniors voilà si vous
voulez c'est un peu plus facile à
compter c'est pourquoi nous proposons
d'élargir le champ d'application de
l'index aux entreprises de plus de 11
salariés je vous remercie
merci
chers collègues peut-être que il peut y
avoir un peu moins de conversation à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle on peut
toujours en avoir à l'extérieur en plus
je pense que vous avez souhaité
adopter cet article donc il est normal
qui est un débat sur les amendements
visant à l'enrichir
donc maintenant l'amendement 1970 qui
est présenté par Monsieur Etienne long
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur mes
chers collègues à l'inverse de ceux qui
vient d'être indiqué c'est un amendement
qui a pour objet de relever le seuil à
300 salariés imposé
à des entreprises de l'ordre de 50
salariés
ce dispositif qui va évidemment évoluer
sur le plan réglementaire
cela va créer des charges sur des
entreprises qui souvent n'ont pas les
services de ressources humaines et
suffisamment important et on le sait un
des soucis qui pèse aujourd'hui sur ce
type d'entreprise là c'est la masse des
contraintes administratives qui sont
excessives qui plus est un grand nombre
d'entre elles sont assortis de sanctions
voire même parfois de sanctions pénales
donc ce dispositif de l'index seniors ne
devrait s'appliquer qu'à des entreprises
de plus de 300 salariés pour éviter je
le redis de pénaliser ces petites
entreprises qui font la richesse de la
France
et ensuite deux amendements identiques
qui je crois mon nom de même sens
monsieur Hainaut le premier 2015
président merci monsieur le ministre il
s'agit effectivement de relever le seuil
à 300 salariés dans les entreprises qui
doivent publier un bilan social qui ont
des services de ressources humaines mais
j'en profite pour faire une remarque
voilà mes chers collègues je vous ai
trouvé bien acrimonieux avec ces fameux
index seniors j'ai même entendu tout à
l'heure que c'était une demande du Medef
non le Medef sur l'index senior il est
sur la même ligne que vous figurez-vous
même si je dois être taquin il est
contre l'index senior le le partenaires
sociaux favorables à l'index senior
c'est la sève d'été et donc nous
proposons cette amendement parce que
cette index senior il doit vivre et il
doit pas non plus être encadré au-delà
des contraintes
parce qu'autrement il y aura pas de
paritarisme si on veut faire vivre le
paritarisme il faut laisser les
partenaires sociaux travailler sur
Seigneur sur cette index senior avant
d'y mettre des contraintes et puis je
relève aussi le paradoxe et
l'incohérence de ceux et celles et ceux
qui étaient pour la suppression de
l'index senior et qui est maintenant
veulent les temps à toutes les
entreprises pardonnez-moi mais ça me
paraît quand même curieux quand on est
contre quelque chose on veut pas le le
l'étendre à toutes les entreprises me
semble-t-il voilà nous on croit au
paritarisme on croit aussi à la
responsabilité sociale
sociétale et environnementale des
entreprises c'est la raison pour
laquelle on est favorable à cette
article et à cet amende bonjour Merci
et ensuite donc l'amendement présenté
par la commission monsieur Savary oui
merci effectivement on est parti
exactement de la même philosophie à
savoir que le seuil de 300 c'est le seul
de gestion de discussion au sein de
l'entreprise de la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et en
conséquence véritablement on peut bâtir
dans à partir de 300 salariés une
véritable politique
ambitieuse d'employabilité des seniors
en dessous en dessous c'est un peu
compliqué voyez-vous parce que vous êtes
dans un bassin d'emploi qui est plutôt
dans une population un peu vieillissante
vous pouvez effectivement peut-être plus
facilement trouver des emplois seniors
vous êtes dans un bassin d'emploi plus
jeune la ma foi c'est plus les jeunes
qui vont répondre aux appels que vous
proposez sachant que vous allez pas là
aussi dire je veux un homme une femme je
veux un jeune je veux un senior non il
la discrimination les appels d'offres
sont offerts des propositions d'offres
d'emploi sont ouvertes à toute la
population et en conséquence en dessous
de 50 c'est difficile il n'y a pas des
ressources humaines qui permettent
effectivement de gérer
de façon prévisionnelle notamment les
emplois c'est pour ça que il faut
trouver d'autres critères mais les
partenaires sociaux vont nous donner
d'autres critères les indicateurs c'est
eux qui vont les établir et d'autre part
il y a pas que les indicateurs qui
comptent c'est bien beau de poser les
indicateurs encore faut-il qu'ils soient
évolutifs parce que deux ou trois ans
après il correspondent plus forcément
aux emplois que vous avez eu il y a
véritablement on le sait une dynamique
nouvelle dans le domaine de l'emploi les
emplois de demain dans dans 20 ans nous
ne savons pas quelles ils sont donc il
est difficile de former pour les emplois
dans 20 ans
il y a eu des évolution technologies
telles que on ne sait pas comment cela
va évoluer c'est la raison pour laquelle
il nous semble que il faut limiter ce
seuil à 300
merci monsieur le rapporteur ensuite le
2754 enfin il y a deux amendements
identiques là aussi le premier présenté
par Monsieur Assouline oui avant je vais
corriger une moment de confusion tout à
l'heure dans mon alimentation parce que
j'avais des chiffres un peu inversés
donc je répète en 2019 55% des nouveaux
retraités du régime général avait validé
des trimestres dans le cadre d'un emploi
durant les mois précédents la
liquidation de leurs droits à la
retraite selon le corps un quart avait
validé leur trimestre tout en étant soit
au chômage en invalidité ou en maladie
les 25 restants selon le corps n'avait
validé aucun trimestre dans l'année
précédente leur retraite ça vient
corriger ce moment où j'ai un peu bégayé
tout à l'heure l'amendement que je
défends maintenant au nom du groupe
socialiste République écologiste etc
c'est amendement vise à préciser que les
indicateurs sur les travailleurs seniors
devront être envoyés par l'entreprise au
ministre du travail ainsi qu'un pôle
emploi
transmettre ces indicateurs est un
préalable pour que Pôle Emploi puisse
œuvrer au changement de culture des
employeurs envers les salariés âgés ou
en fin de carrière et déployer des
actions spécifiques adaptées d'adressage
des candidatures de salariés de plus de
50 ans vers les entreprises qui se
doivent de développer l'embauche de ses
profils et pour conclure une réponse à
notre collègue qui vient de s'exprimer
du groupe centriste
il n'y a pas de paradoxe à nous
critiquer sur le fait qu'on était pour
le rejet de cet article pour sa
suppression et le fait que maintenant on
veut les tendre le préciser le renforcer
c'est justement on a considéré que cet
article n'apportait rien pas que la
question d'emploie des seniors n'était
pas un sujet on pense même que c'est le
sujet central qu'on aurait dû traiter
avant cette loi fait à la va-vite et
nicher comme cela sauf que voilà
on vient en parler là où il ne faut pas
et de façon
tellement
tellement insignifiante que ça peut au
contraire faire reculer cette idée
que l'on doit traiter y compris par un
index pour avoir des données pour avoir
une objective de la situation donc voilà
ce que je voulais dire et on va
continuer à essayer de faire qu'il ait
du contenu à travers les débats qui vont
continuer sur cet article merci et
ensuite l'amendement suivant le
4159 madame la Présidente
je voudrais revenir sur
la précision du dispositif de l'intex
Senior et en fait ça continue à nous
interroger bien évidemment et j'ai
quelques quelques questions que
deviendront les données publiées par les
employeurs point d'interrogation ces
données seront quelques instants la
séance en car je suis avec la semestre
socialiste de Paris Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie bonsoir
un mot déjà sur le fait qu'Olivier du
soft à qualifié ce matin dans le
Parisien cette réforme des retraites de
réforme de gauche il fait valoir les
avancées que propose le texte dit que le
texte ne fera pas de perdant il vous a
pas convaincu mais si vous voulez j'ai
j'ai réagi quand j'ai vu ce ce titre de
manière un peu ironique en disant la
droite sénatoriale est en PLS parce que
je pense que c'est ça là exactement
comme honnêtement pour les pratiquer
régulièrement incontestablement ce n'est
pas le cas non c'est d'ailleurs assez
curieux je pense que l'évier du socle
n'a pas n'a pas d'inspiration tactique
extrêmement forte parce que
personne ne croit qu'il n'y aura pas de
perdant et d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
parce que lorsqu'on on regarde pourquoi
il dit ça
certains de vos confrères notamment en
libération on fait une vérification de
cette assertion ça fait un moment qu'il
dit il y aura pas de perdants
et donc apparemment le raisonnement du
ministre c'est de renvoyer vers l'étude
d'impact qui montre que
c'est mieux que si c'était pire c'est à
dire que si on n'avait rien fait les
retraites aurait pu éventuellement
baisser puisqu'il y a un déficit donc
comme par hypothèse selon lui elle ne
baisserait pas donc c'est mieux que si
c'était pire donc on voit quand même que
l'ambition n'est pas n'est pas échevée
non nous sont constaté c'est que par
exemple à l'instant nous parlons nous
sommes en train de parler de du fameux
index senior voilà l'article 2 donc
toute la problématique de l'emploi des
seniors en réalité un point phare du
texte qui a déjà été rejeté par la santé
nationale et qui fait son retour
pourquoi je l'évoque là par rapport à
votre question ce qu'on sait c'est que
le recul de 62 à 64 ans pour partir en
retraite va faire basculer plusieurs
dizaines de milliers voire centaines de
milliers de seniors dans la grande
précarité pourquoi parce que on sait que
à peu près
65% des seniors alors d'abord tout le
monde ne sait pas ce que c'est qu'un
senior ça dépend des questions
en gros on considère que c'est au-delà
de 55 mais ça dépend bien donc on sait
que le taux de chômage ou plutôt de
non-emploi comme on dit quand on va être
un peu politiquement correct et de plus
en plus important quand la j'avance le
problème c'est qu'avec la réforme de
l'indemnité chômage qui a été mise en
place par le gouvernement il y a peu et
bien ces personnes vont se trouver sans
emploi mais sans non plus indemnités
chômage et donc elles vont basculer soit
dans les dans le minima sociaux
c'est-à-dire le RSA ou les allocations
de solidarité le langage de la part du
gouvernement sur la question des seniors
pour vous lorsque vous mettez en
parallèle et bien cette position sur
l'assurance chômage et cette index
senior qui veut et bien favoriser leur
je pense que l'index senior c'est c'est
une sorte de cache sexe c'est-à-dire que
je pense que le fait de reculer l'âge de
de départ à la retraite ça posait
problème et je vous rassure je ne vais
pas les développer maintenant mais
évidemment
c'est poser cette question là et donc la
question de l'emploi des seigneurs est
une question majeure en fait il aurait
fallu faire d'abord un texte sur
l'emploi des seniors et une fois qu'on
aurait pu augmenter le taux d'emploi des
seniors avec diverses mesures dans ce
cas là regardez quel était le déficit de
la de la
de la franchise pour finalement la
combler avec telle ou telle mesure bref
ce n'est pas le choix qui a été fait là
on a décidé de faire l'inverse mais
comme l'inquiétude ce que j'évoque là
l'inquiétude des personnes de se dire
mais oui mais si l'âge de la retraite
recule déjà j'ai pas de boulot comment
ça va être ça va être pire donc ils sont
dit ben on va on va proposer quelque
chose un peu cosmétique pour dire que on
va être très vigilant et donc ils ont
pondu cette index senior donc vous avez
noté que il avait été rejeté à
l'Assemblée comme étant plaisanterie
quoi quelque chose de totalement c'est
vraiment comment on dit que terre sur
une jambe de bois et ici au Sénat comme
le Sénat n'est vraiment pas de gauche le
texte qui nous est proposé dit clindex
qui est imposé aux entreprises c'est un
index c'est juste une photographie
serait obligatoire à partir de 50
salariés le Sénat équipe a voté lorsque
un seuil de 300 voir 2000 de 1000 pour
que ce soit applicable cette année et de
300 dans un an donc voilà on voit bien
que en réalité c'est pour faire joli
dans l'ensemble du dispositif de dire
mais voyez on s'est préoccupé de
l'emploi des seniors vous avez beaucoup
attaqué vous et la gauche le
gouvernement sur une note du Conseil
d'État autour de la réforme et qui
concerne notamment cet article 2 qui
pourrait être un cavalier social qui
pourrait être
anticonstitutionnel on a eu la réponse
de René Paul Savary qui a dit cette note
elle est confidentielle on peut pas la
rendre publique mais j'ai accès comme
membre de la Mecque je peux et bien
communiquer cette note aux autres
membres de La Mecque etc est-ce que
c'est une réponse satisfaisante pour
vous alors il faut distinguer deux
choses ce que dit René Paul Savary est
une chose nous ce qui nous pose problème
c'est ce que fait le gouvernement
pourquoi pour faire très simple les
projets de loi sont toujours soumis au
Conseil d'État point numéro 1 le point
numéro 2 ainsi que désormais depuis
maintenant un sacré nombre d’années ses
avis du Conseil d'État sont rendus
publics c'est très intéressant parce que
le Conseil d'État là est un conseil
juridique c'est-à-dire que le Conseil
d'État examine les textes et dit et dit
au gouvernement avant même la probation
du projet par conséquilibres voilà tel
article vaudrait mieux faire comme si
comme ça etc donc c'est une teinte
document extrêmement intéressant là il
n'y en a pas parce que il ne serait pas
obligatoire dans le cadre de cette forme
très particulière de projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale bon
sauf que ce que nous avons constaté il y
a plus que ça c'est que dans le document
du projet de loi déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale il est mis que le projet de
loi a été adopté en conseil des
ministres après avis du Conseil d'État
donc hier soir nous avons dit au
ministre qui nous avait toujours dit il
n'y a pas d'avis d'ailleurs il n'y a pas
y en avoir j'ai dit mais vous nous avez
raconté des carabistouilles comme on dit
il y a bien un avis du Conseil d'État
non c'est une note c'était nous notre
sujet on a deux sujets 1 ce que dit le
Conseil d'État nous intéresse parce
qu'effectivement on travaille etc mais
c'est voilà ça nous permet d'avoir des
informations plus plus fin des analyses
plus robustes par ailleurs ça permet
aussi de dire que le gouvernement était
alerté sur un certain nombre de sujets
donc ça c'est important le deuxième
point c'était le sujet hier soir quand
ça c'était un petit peu animé en séance
c'est que
on ne voudrait pas que le ministre on
raconte des histoires c'est-à-dire que
il uttait plus juste de sa part de dire
il y a un avis du Conseil d'État mais il
n'est pas public et je n'ai donc pas
vous le communiquer bon on aurait râlé
on aurait dit mais pourquoi qu'est-ce
que vous nous cachez bon on aurait
peut-être fait quand même un petit peu
de polémique mais bon mais là il nous
dit non il y a pas d'avis et noir sur
blanc il est écrit l'inverse donc tout
ça est un petit peu et comme c'est un
ministre qui visiblement un petit peu de
mal à voilà on l'a vu avec la retraite à
1200 euros etc etc on a bon on a
toujours un petit peu de mal à croire ce
qu'il nous dit donc à chaque fois qu'il
se prend un peu les pieds dans
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise je pense qu'il n'a pas su comment
se dépêtrer du fait qu'on souhaitait
avoir cet avis et que du coup voilà je
n'accuse pas les gens de mensonge
honnêtement je ne comprends pas très
bien pourquoi alors c'est pour ça que je
distingue du rôle du rapporteur parce
que le rapporteur il y a eu accès dans
le cadre d'autres fonctions il nous a
dit ce que nous avait dit d'ailleurs
Jérôme Guedj qui a la même fonction mais
pour l'Assemblée nationale membre de la
Mecque j'ai pu foncer au secrétaire
général du gouvernement j'ai pu lire la
note mais je ne peux pas la communiquer
c'est c'est couvert par le secret n'ont
pas professionnel mais bon donc OK dans
ce cas là bon on peut voilà bousculer un
peu le rapporteur en disant ah mais
c'est pas bien dites-nous mais vous
voyez ce que c'est pas la même chose que
le gouvernement qui nous raconte autre
chose que ce qui semble être la vérité
bien merci beaucoup Marie-Pierre de la
ganterie d'avoir répondu à mes questions
et notamment pour éclairer et bien tout
ce qui est en train de se passer sur cet
article 2 cet article qui porte sur
l'index des seniors un des articles
majeurs de ce projet de loi qui a été
rejeté je le rappelle à l'Assemblée
nationale et sur lequel elle est
discussions se poursuivent au Sénat le
président effectivement
l'index seniors on l'a dit et inférieur
en fait à l'index professionnel entre
les femmes et les hommes qui a été vidés
d'ailleurs de son contenu et qui a vu se
dresser toutes les associations
féministes et beaucoup de syndicalistes
contre lui parce que les pénalités sont
effectivement très faibles donc
normalement il faudrait il faudrait en
tirer des leçons je vais vous donner
quelques exemples par rapport à cette
indicateur professionnel entre les
femmes et et les hommes par exemple si
10 femmes sont augmentées de 10 euros
tandis que 10 hommes sont augmentés de
100 euros l'entreprise obtiendra tous
les points sur cet indicateur ou encore
si tous les salariés sont augmentés à
leur retour de congé maternité ce qui
constitue une obligation légale et ce
d'un euro l'entreprise validera
également l'indicateur bref un
paramétrage qui explique les très bons
scores qui sont obtenus par les
entreprises depuis le lancement de
l'index alors même que les femmes
continuent encore à gagner en moyenne 23
10% de moins que les hommes et être payé
près de 17% de moins à poste égal donc
on voit bien que les index c'est quand
même important mais alors l'index senior
il est encore inférieur à ses
exigences-là
donc on refusant d'un de d'associer
l'index seniors à des sanctions c'est un
recul du gouvernement une fois de plus
face au MEDEF pourtant j'ai l'impression
monsieur le rapporteur René Paul Savary
que vous êtes d'accord avec nous avec
notre groupe et que vous trouvez comme
nous inadmissible la situation qui est
faite au seniors face à l'emploi à 60
ans près d'une personne sur trois n'est
ni en emploi ni à la retraite la
majorité d'entre elles et eux se
retrouvent en invalidité ou en situation
de RSA ou de chômage donc en grande
précarité il faut donc en tirer des
leçons et accepter l'enrichissement
grâce à notre abonnement
merci le 4151 madame gréaumont merci
monsieur le Président avec cette index
vous mettez les doigts sur un problème
majeur comme disait ma collègue celui de
l'emploi des seniors connaissez-vous les
réalités de l'emploi que vivent nos
concitoyens pour en être certain je vous
rappelle quelque chose
61,3 % des personnes n'existe déjà plus
d'activités à 61 ans et cela atteint
73,6% à 62 ans on imagine déjà comment
cela évoluera jusqu'à 64 ans il est
difficile d'obtenir un emploi au-delà de
55 ans puisque les employeurs supposent
notamment une moindre productivité ainsi
qu'une moindre adaptabilité cela est
encore plus vrai comme comme toujours
pour celles et ceux qui ont connu durant
leur carrière à un certain nombre de
discriminations je pense aux femmes aux
personnes en situation de handicap etc
alors pour votre index nous proposons de
prendre en compte ces critères pour
améliorer er l'égalité professionnelle
et ainsi éviter les manœuvres pour
contourner les dispositions prévues et
le sens de cet article merci
le 4142
donc cet abonnement a pour but de
rappeler donc
[Musique]
non mais je vais y arriver je vais y
arriver c'est monsieur savolelli qui me
perturbe donc je recommence c'est à vous
besoin appeler que dans certaines de nos
qualités non mais on se détend aussi on
est bien là on vous attend voilà donc
dans certaines de nos qualités la
démographie la démographie est stable à
d'autres endroits et des croissantes et
dans d'autres elle est même décroissante
plus la population est grande plus
l'entreprise est grande mais lorsque la
population est moindre a un certain
endroit certaines entreprises ne peuvent
compter 300 salariés au sein de leurs
effectifs il faut donc prendre en compte
un plus grand nombre d'entreprises pour
que la plage des seniors soit réellement
une priorité au sein de ces dernières
c'est l'article ne s'adapte pas à ces
différences la valorisation du travail
des personnes âgées doivent s'appliquer
à toutes les échelles même si
l'entreprise ne compte pas 300 salariés
ce ne sont pas toujours les plus grandes
qui doivent être privilégiés afin qu'une
telle une
pour le 3467
merci monsieur le Président alors si on
veut faire vivre l'index Seigneur si on
croit au paritarisme si on croit à la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale on écoute les
organisations syndicales je viens de
citer mon collègue Olivier Hainaut alors
immédiatement presque
j'ai décidé de défendre avec conviction
cet amendement qui est proposé par une
des organisations syndicales d'une ça
vous voyez l'une ça que la CFDT et donc
je pense monsieur Hainaut que vous
parliez de toutes les organisations donc
voilà
cette organisation propose que de la
même manière que les entreprises ayant
des résultats insuffisants à
l'indicateur et d'égalité
professionnelle sont sanctionnées
financièrement
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire reprend leur proposition de
sanctionner les entreprises ayant des
résultats insatisfaisants au regard des
critères de l'index senior et pas
uniquement celle ne publions pas
simplement l'indicateur sur l'emploi des
seniors
cette sanction permettrait de créer une
incitation financière mais aussi
réputationnelle c'est pas très joli afin
que les entreprises mettent en place des
politiques d'emploi réellement efficaces
en faveur des salariés
âgés et du taux d'emploi des seniors
voilà les discussions se poursuivent
autour de cet article majeur de la
réforme des retraites l'article 2 qui
prévoit la mise en place d'un index
senior et on va tout de suite rejoindre
Audrey Audrey viiaz car et bien sûr
cette mesure et bien il y a des
amendements de la droite qui sont prévus
oui nous sommes au milieu de l'examen de
139 amendements en discussion commune
Tam vous avez peut-être l'impression que
les sujets sont très différents mais
s'ils sont étudiés ensemble c'est parce
qu'ils concernent tous une mise en
application de l'index senior certains
sénateurs veulent qu'ils soient
qualitatifs et non uniquement
quantitatif ils veulent par exemple que
l'on publie les formations dont
bénéficient les seniors en entreprise
d'autres sénateurs veulent déterminer
tout simplement l'âge à partir duquel on
éteint senior au milieu de ces
amendements on trouve une mesure phare
de la commission elle a été défendue par
le rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales ça concerne la taille
des entreprises concernées par cette
index senior écoutez
le seuil de 300 c'est le seul de gestion
de discussion au sein de l'entreprise de
la gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
en conséquence véritablement on peut
bâtir dans à partir de 300 salariés une
véritable politique
ambitieuse d'employabilité des seniors
en dessous en dessous c'est un peu
compliqué voyez-vous
concrètement si l'amendement est adopté
l'index senior ne concernera que les
entreprises à partir de 300 salariés au
lieu de 50 comme le voulait le texte se
transmis par le gouvernement merci merci
beaucoup Audrey pour toutes ces
explications vous le voyez une véritable
différence entre le traitement de cette
index senior à l'Assemblée où il avait
été rejeté et notamment par la droite de
l'Assemblée alors que au Sénat et bien
les sénateurs ont cherché à amender
cette index senior il prévoit également
ensuite de discuter d'une de leurs
propositions phares celles de la mis en
place d'un CDI Seigneur avec des
exonérations de charges pour les
entreprises qui conserveraient ces
seniors les discussions auront lieu
après cet article 2 voilà on reprend
tout de suite la direction de
l'hémicycle c'est le sénateur communiste
pierre aux ullias qui s'exprime à
présent au dialogue social bien
évidemment nous prévoyons par par cet
amendement que une convention de branche
puisse enrichir la laisse la liste des
indicateurs mentionner au 1er année tel
que je viens de faire et cette liste
pourrait se substituer ensuite au de
créer mentionné merci monsieur le
Président merci ensuite le 2759 présenté
par Madame Monnier madame le wéron
pardon
puisque vous avez voté l'index senior
cet amendement de notre groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
visent à mieux définir les indicateurs
donc
l'index senior afin de s'assurer de son
efficacité alors nous proposons que ce
soit précisé dans le décret 5 éléments à
prendre en compte la prévention des
effets défavorables et risques inhérents
carrière longue ou à la pénibilité des
professions notamment en matière de
santé et sécurité des travailleurs
deuxième élément l'organisation des
conditions d'emploi et de travail la
durée des contrats de travail le temps
de travail la mobilité la pénibilité
troisième élément le maintien des
niveaux de rémunération et les
dispositifs d'entreprises de financement
des retraites le quatrième élément les
cumules en poids retraites la
reconversion professionnelle des signaux
ou les retraites progressives dans
l'entreprise nous proposons également
qu'une convention de branche soit
étendue et qu'elle puisse enrichir la
liste des indicateurs
mentionnés donc si devant ce cadre
permettra de garantir la prise en compte
des politiques d'emploi des conditions
de travail et de rémunération des
salariés proches de la retraite afin que
l'index soit l'outil de mesure le plus
effi efficace possible au service de la
négociation en branche et en entreprise
cet amendement a été travaillé avec
l'UNSA merci
je suis deux amendements identiques le
3731 présenté par Monsieur Ferny et
ensuite il y aura le 4171 allez-y
monsieur ferrique merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre un
affaire collègue donc je pense qu'on l'a
bien compris l'index senior proposé
repêché par le gouvernement après que
l'Assemblée nationale ne l'est pas jugé
convaincant c'est index est peu
contraignant puisqu'il ne prévoit qu'une
obligation de publicité pour que l'index
senior est un réel impact sur les
pratiques des entreprises en matière
d'emploi des salariés seniors il
faudrait inclure dans ce dispositif un
barème d'évaluation avec une note
minimale à atteindre c'est ce que vous
propose cet amendement j'ai pas été trop
long merci ensuite le 4171 madame
apourceau poli
merci monsieur le Président alors notre
collègue vient de le dire cet amendement
pour notre part visa intégrer à l'index
senior son évaluation sans quoi il sera
il serait difficile de mesurer la
progression restant à accomplir car
l'employeur doit assumer son objectif
d'amélioration d'embauche et du maintien
en activité des travailleurs seniors
après avoir réclamé un coréacerie que
vous lui livriez encore plus de main
d'oeuvre il les voulait ses deux ans de
plus que vous arrachez au peuple tous
ici puisqu'ils devront travailler demain
les salariés jusqu'à 64 ans voulez-vous
lier évidemment aussi c'est 64 ans nous
vous avons démontré les économistes
l'ont également démontré vous ne vous
engagez pas pour sauver notre système de
retraite c'est autre chose ici qui vous
anime et si elle n'est pas le cas
pourquoi vous obstinez à refuser
d'établir des seuils deux ans pour
l'emploi des travailleurs les plus
vulnérables vous promettez des grandes
négociations qui laisseraient la part
belle à l'expression de tout et tous et
qui permettent d'entretenir évidemment
le flou nous ne voulons pas d'influ sur
ce type de mesure un barème d'évaluation
comprenant une note minimale à atteindre
doit constituer un cadre d'objectifs
nous souhaitons qu'au-delà du fétiche ou
plutôt de cette épouvantail qui ne prend
auprès de personnes nous soyons un peu
sérieux la construction de cet index et
son évaluation permettra de situer
précisément les marges de progression de
chaque entreprise Intel sera en 200
matières de formation qui nous le savons
est un très grand chantier untel sur
l'aménagement des fins de carrière ainsi
la note sera porteuse de sens nous
introduisons d'ailleurs un délai afin
d'atteindre un seuil minimal acceptable
merci
ensuite le 2758 présenté par Madame le
héros
de notre groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains vise à confier à un accord
national interprofessionnel le soin de
construire les indicateurs de l'index
senior alors un accord national
interprofessionnel est un accord négocié
et signé par les partenaires sociaux et
donc nous donnera des gages d'efficacité
dans la mise en oeuvre le dialogue
social est important primordial même
dans ce domaine précis de la définition
des index la place des partenaires
sociaux doit être respectée la
discussion avec ses partenaires doit
permettre de trouver le bon équilibre et
les indicateurs les plus pertinents pour
assurer l'efficacité de cette index
merci
merci ensuite le
4176 monsieur ça vole des lignes merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
amendement vise à ce que la liste des
indicateurs c'est à dire leur mode de
calcul leur évolution soit précisée et
non pas de manière discrétionnaire
mais par un accord national
interprofessionnel
avec notre amendement nous redonnons
donc toute sa place
vous nous dites monsieur le ministre je
pense que vous la voulez aussi
c'est la place que doit avoir la
négociation collective dans la mise en
place de l'index senior donc j'ai pu
retrouver avec mon groupe les dires de
l'ancien membre du Conseil
constitutionnel Olivier duthier de la
Motte qui résumait dans sa contribution
à la revue Semaine sociale les quatre
atouts possibles d'une norme négociées
collectivement et vraiment son
diagnostic est
utile d'abord elle vient des acteurs
même de l'entreprise
deuxièmement elle émane des partenaires
sociaux et elle est le plus souvent de
batterie la troisième elle est souvent
appliquée car appropriée et enfin elle
est au souvent plus stable et donc au vu
de l'enjeu le seul cas de collectif qui
convient reste celui de l'année donc
l'index senior ne peut se passer de
négociation nationale visant à couvrir
une majorité des travailleuses et des
travailleurs seniors voilà le sens de
cet amendement je pense que le caractère
massif et national des discriminations
faites aux salariés âgées rend légitime
de lesaut dialogue social le temps
nécessaire revendications et à la
discussion
merci ensuite le 2756 madame Rossignol
merci monsieur le Président alors la
ligne de l'article 2 prévoit que la
liste des indicateurs et leurs méthodes
de calcul sont fixées par décret nous
proposons avec cet amendement de
préciser qu'il s'agit d'un décret en
Conseil d'État alors pourquoi un décret
en Conseil d'État parce que le décret en
Conseil d'État est une procédure
différente et il suppose d'être par
ailleurs de passer par le Conseil des
ministres or ces décrets nous paraît
important dans la mise en œuvre de
l'index seniors nous sommes beaucoup ici
en cités l'index égalité femme homme or
il faut tirer les leçons de ce qu'on
constate sur l'index égalité femme homme
nombreux biais et des biais qui tiennent
à la fois sur la question des
comparaisons sur les augmentations des
femmes des augmentations sur les nombres
de femmes promues comparé bien entendu
aux augmentations accordées aux hommes
aux augmentations au nombre d'hommes
promus Laurence Cohen tout à l'heure a
fait référence un certain nombre de
d'exemples qui montrent que c'est bien
en fait permettent à des entreprises qui
ne respectent que la moitié de
les prescriptions de l'index égalité
d'obtenir le nombre de points suffisants
les 75 points qui leur permettent
d'échapper aux sanctions d'abord et
ensuite on rattrapage de leur politique
donc instruite tout ça il nous faut nous
prévoir le meilleur indicateur et on
pense que le Conseil d'État est une
garantie d'un meilleur indicateur et
surtout de Planète plus
d'interministérialité et puis enfin
dernière élément un indicateur Conseil
d'État un décret en Conseil d'État c'est
un gros avantage c'est que peut-être il
y aura un avis et s'il y a un avis en
Conseil d'État je ne doute pas que notre
collègue que notre collègue Daniel
broyer demandera à ce que l'avion
conseille d'État soit montré au
Parlement après dans le cadre de notre
activité de contrôle du gouvernement
ensuite
2479 monsieur Breuillet justement merci
monsieur le Président et merci cher
collègue rossignol
l'amendement je défends l'amendement qui
a été présenté par mon collègue Thomas
dossu mais qui a dû rentrer à Lyon c'est
aussi d'ailleurs un amendement proposé
par le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire il vise à prendre le décret
qui définira la liste des indicateurs à
l'index senior après consultation de
l'Agence Nationale pour l'Amélioration
des Conditions de Travail la nacte
l'index senior qui est proposé dans le
texte et la principale et avons le nous
l'avons d'ailleurs tous reconnus
ensemble bien maigre mesure prévu par le
gouvernement pour mettre fin au chômage
des seniors ou en tous les cas pour
réduire le chômage des seniors cette
mesure se base sur l'isée qu'un index
que les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés devraient publier tous les ans
suffirait à résoudre les difficultés
auxquelles font face les seniors en
recherche d'emploi
Olivier Mériot l'ancien directeur
technique et scientifique de l'anake a
jugé hypocrite et dangereuse la
proposition du report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite dans une tribune
parue dans Le Monde fin janvier il
précise qu'aucune mesure ne pourra
contrebalancer les impacts d'un recul de
la borne d'âge pour une large partie du
corps social déjà fragilisée selon lui
l'index senior n'échappe pas ce constat
l'index senior est une mesure plus
qu'insuffisante qui ne comporte de
surcroît aucune garantir en voyant un
décret le soin de fixer la liste des
indicateurs de cet index ainsi que leur
méthode de calcul établir de telles
indicateurs ne peut se faire sans la
consultation des acteurs concernés par
la thématique du travail et de l'emploi
et notamment l'Agence nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et d'emploi l'anacte à plusieurs
domaines de compétences notamment
je m'arrête puisque excusez-moi j'ai
dépassé le temps et pour rattraper un
peu de ce temps si vaut mieux autorisez
monsieur le Président j’enchaîne avec
l'amendement suivant absolument il y a
trois amendements identiques c'est vous
qui présentez le premier allez-y alors
le présente amendement porté par le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire vise à prendre le décret qui
définira la liste des indicateurs de
l'index senior après consultation cette
fois-ci du Conseil économique social et
environnemental le 16e si l'on en croit
l'étude d'impact fournie par le
gouvernement l'index senior prévu à
l'article 2 de ce texte a notamment pour
objectif d'objectiver la place des
seniors en entreprise d'assurer la
transparence en matière de gestion des
âges et de mettre en oeuvre une logique
d'amélioration continue des pratiques
des entreprises en mobilisant le
dialogue social dans l'entreprise
l'emploi des seniors est un sujet qui
mérite d'être traité avec sérieux
d'après le CDO le taux d'emploi des 55
64 ans atteint 56, 100% en France contre
62,6% dans la zone euro les salariés de
plus 50 ans sont souvent victimes de
pratiques délétères de la part d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui
préfèrent les placardiser ou les
licenciers les discriminations la vie
dur c'est salarié en fin de carrière
sont nombreux à être jugé trop coûteux
ou encore trop susceptibles de tomber
malade et il subisse une double peine
une fois licenciée il aurait très
difficile de retrouver du travail si le
gouvernement veut prendre à bras le
corps le problème du chômage comme il
l'affirme l'index senior est une
solution bien maigre et ce ne sont pas
les résultats de l'index de l'égalité
professionnelle homme-femmes qu'on vient
de le démontrer ma collègue qui
contredit ce constat c'est pourquoi face
à la détermination de tes indicateurs
comme la détermination de ces
indicateurs ne peut se faire à la légère
nous proposons par cet amendement de
repli d'obliger le gouvernement à
consulter le 16e pour établir par décret
la liste des indicateurs de l'index
senior
merci ensuite donc deux amendes moyen
identiques à celui-là le premier
président rossignol
merci monsieur le Président
qu'on se fasse bien comprendre d'abord
moi je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je suis
pas hostile à la technique des index je
pense qu'elle a une utilité dès lors
qu'il s'agit d'identifier des
discriminations de mieux en comprendre
les mécanismes et les raisons et aussi
les vices et ainsi dire médié et nous
amendements
ne visent pas à alourdir
inutilement la procédure elle vise au
point de vise au contraire à garantir
pour cette saison c'est index le plus
grand succès la meilleure performance de
l'index les discussions autour de
l'article 2 de cette réforme des
retraites se poursuivent c'est
discussion autour de l'index senior
noter et bien que les amendements de
suppression qui avait été émis très
nombreux une cinquantaine à part la
gauche et bien non pas été adopté
maintenant et bien les sénateurs
débattent du fond de cette mesure et
font leur proposition et on entend
encore beaucoup la gauche Audrey oui et
c'est peut-être le moment de faire un
petit point d'étape nous en sommes donc
à l'article 2 du texte il reste encore
3150 amendements environ sur
4751 déposés sur l'ensemble du texte
actuellement nous étudions 139
amendements en discussion commune ça
veut dire que leur thème général est
commun ça concerne la mise en
application de l'index senior et la
dynamique et la même que depuis
plusieurs jours la gauche amande défonce
ses amendements quitte par exemple à
évoquer l'âge des seniors alors que le
ministre a dit que ce serait évoqué plus
tard dans les branches et dans une autre
partie du texte en face on a une droite
quasi mutique qui n'a pas pris la parole
depuis de très longues minutes elle va
bientôt le faire par l'intermédiaire du
sénateur LR alain Milon au milieu d'un
océan de sénateurs de gauche merci merci
beaucoup Audrey effectivement ces
scénaris se reproduisent de bonjour à
l'exception de ce matin on a entendu à
la droite sénatoriale s'exprimer sur le
fait d'introduire une part de
capitalisation dans notre système de
retraite par répartition et bien pour
l'essentiel on a surtout entendu et bien
la gauche jusqu'ici soit pour des
amendements de suppression soit pour
amender le texte à son tour tout de
suite c'est bien on continue les débats
dans l'hémicycle et c'est la sénatrice
comiste lance quand même qui s'exprime
en ce moment de salariés le secteur
associatif est même le patronat qui sont
présents au CES eux s'élèvent tous
contre cette réforme des retraites et
pour des raisons différentes donc ça
c'est intéressant d'avoir leur point de
vue leur expérience leur analyse et je
vais m'attacher à présenter des faits
objectifs que nous pouvons partager me
semble-t-il sur tous les bancs de notre
hémicycle le taux d'emploi des plus de
60 ans
en France c'est beaucoup plus faible que
la moyenne de l'Union européenne ça a
été soulignée mais je le redis c'est
extrêmement important de l'avoir en tête
le taux d'emploi des personnes de 60 à
64 ans discrimine particulièrement les
moins diplômés 25% des 100 diplômes sont
sans emploi à cet âge contre 53% des
diplômés de l'enseignement supérieur
plus on avance en âge mais on a de
chance d'avoir un emploi prétendre faire
travailler deux ans de plus celles et
ceux qui ne travaillent déjà plus n'aura
qu'un effet renforcer la trappe à
précarité en 2019 939
000 personnes
âgées de 50 à 64 ans déjà en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté un seuil de pauvreté
fixé à 50% du revenu médian concrètement
000 personnes vivent en France avec
moins de 919 euros par mois en réponse à
cette réalité sociale qui doit tout et
tous nous préoccuper franchement
se contenter de la publication d'un
index tel que prévu sans obligation de
résultats et quelque chose de totalement
dérisoire d'où le sens de notre
amendement merci ensuite le 46 rectifier
madame Guillotin
le président donc et nous interrompons
un instant à nouveau c'est débats car je
suis avec Katia poursuppoli bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice communiste
chef de fil du groupe sur cette réforme
des retraites on a entendu les
discussions qui se sont largement en
venimer hier encore un certain moment
aujourd'hui autour et bien de cette note
du Conseil d'État avis du Conseil d'État
on sait comment le nommer qui n'a pas
été rendu public et dont vous demandez à
ce qu'il veut à ce qu'elle vous soit
communiqué René Paul Savary a fait un
pas vers vous cet après-midi mais ce
n'est pas encore satisfaisant pour vous
oui la note que de toute façon on
devrait nous donner sans aucun problème
qu'est-ce que cache finalement cette
note monsieur ça varie va me recevoir
demain midi pour nous présenter donc la
note mais finalement nous l'obtiendrons
pas donc eh bien écoutez nous irons la
chercher cette note parce que finalement
quand on ne veut de faire la
transparence et bien des divers
documents c'est qu'il y a certainement
quelque chose à cacher là dessous
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez
voir cacher et bien dans le fait qu'on
ne vous communique pas cette note le
fait que cet article 2 soit
anticonstitutionnel que ce soit un
cavalier social ça a été largement
commenté depuis
commenté mais je pense qu'on est là dans
une escroquerie quand même en bande
organisée parce que finalement ce projet
de loi c'est la retraite à 64 ans moi
j'ai entendu depuis hier des choses
quand même assez dures dans cette
émission y compris sur le fait que les
salariés capitalisés j'ai trouvé quand
même ça forte de café d'ailleurs je l'ai
dénoncé en disant que et bien ce n'était
certainement pas les petits smicards les
aides à domicile les gens qui gagnent le
SMIC qui finalement n'ont plus les
moyens de se nourrir et de nourrir leurs
enfants qui vont aller vers une retraite
par capitalisation finalement c'est
pratiquement la fin du régime par
répartition qu'ils veulent organiser et
par rapport à cette note rappelons que
pour l'instant il y a eu un amendement
DLR qui a été adopté qui prévoit et bien
un rapport pour voir comment on pourrait
introduire une dose de capitalisation
dans notre système de retraite par
répartition oui oui c'est ça exactement
il y a un amendement qui a été adopté de
la part DLR parce que finalement et bien
c'est ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
veulent c'est que les gens capitalisent
que les gens prennent des fonds de
pension mais les gens n'ont pas les
moyens de ça les les familles les plus
populaires les travailleurs qui chaque
jour vont dans leur entreprise à l'usine
qui travaille dans les supermarchés et
bien tous ceux qu'on a appelé ceux de la
première ligne que je n'aime pas
d'ailleurs parce que chaque profession
est une première ligne dans ce pays et
bien ce sont eux qui finalement à qui on
va demander de se serrer la ceinture en
leur présent finalement et bien si plus
tard vous n'avez pas de retraite ça sera
de votre faute parce que vous n'aurez
pas épargné mais comment on peut
épargner quand finalement on a un
salaire qui est au SMIC ou que les coûts
de l'énergie etc flamme fin c'est
complètement scandaleux et on voit bien
que toute la philosophie de ce texte
finalement vise à un criminer les
salariés qui ne feraient pas assez pour
pouvoir se payer une retraite plus tard
je trouve ça complètement scandaleux
alors j'ai bien vu aussi le CDI que
propose la droite républicaine
pour pour les entreprises ouais mais
quand on parle de ça on oppose y compris
les jeunes aux plus anciens le CDI c'est
aux jeunes qu'il faut le donner enfin
quand on a travaillé toute durant toute
sa vie c'est pas à 55 60 ans qu'il faut
nous proposer un CDI qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire quoi voyez on oppose sans
cesse les jeunes aux anciens on a essayé
quand il y avait les régimes spéciaux et
bien d'opposer les salariés qui ont des
régimes spéciaux aux salariés qui n'en
n'ont pas mais ça ne prend pas dans le
pays ça ne prend pas puisque 9 salariés
sur 10 de toute façon refuse cette
réforme des retraits à cette journée
d'action sur lesquelles tous les regards
sont aujourd'hui concentrés la journée
d'action de mardi cette mars vous
attendez d'ailleurs cette mobilisation
avant et bien de débattre de la du cœur
de la réforme de l'article 7 sur le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite on sent le gouvernement
toujours aussi motivé qu'attendez-vous
vraiment de cette mobilisation écoutez
moi je pense que le 7 il va y avoir une
mobilisation exceptionnelle il va y
avoir la rue la rue les salariés seront
dans la rue mais il y a la rue et il y a
les grèves dans les entreprises et je
pense vraiment que ça va être très fort
et que le gouvernement et bien va devoir
tenir compte de ça parce qu'autrement on
s'en va la catastrophe du pays ils vont
obliger les salariés de ce pays à devoir
faire grève beaucoup plus longtemps on
parle aujourd'hui de blocage du pays et
c'est le gouvernement et la droite
sénatoriale qui emporteront l'entière
responsabilité de ne pas écouter ces
salariés et de ne pas écouter le peuple
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à toutes
mes questions alors que les discussions
se poursuivent toujours sur ce fameux
article 2 que on va donc rejoindre
maintenant l'hémicycles où se trouve et
bien Raymond poncemont je chef de fil du
groupe écologiste sur la réforme des
retraites alors vous allez me dire avant
on avait une visite médicale tous les
deux ans et ben ils sont au moins
maintenant c'est tous les 5 ans donc ça
leur donne un répit pour leur préjudice
d'anxiété ceci cette plaisanterie mise à
part je voudrais quand même rappeler
quand même qu'à ces âges là vis-à-vis
des aptitudes et vous avez des branches
que je connais bien du soin de l'aide et
du soin à domicile qui ne sortent plus
par retraite c'est fini plus personne au
fait plus les départs en retraite dans
cette branche on a que des sorties par
inaptitude et les courbes entre la
sortie par retraite et la sortie par
inaptitude se sont croisés après la loi
2010 il faut bien le savoir donc voilà
c'est une inquiétude de justifier ils
sont pas anxieux pour rien 95% des
salariés déclarés inapte sont licenciés
donc et c'est un rapport de 2019 de la
Haute Autorité de Santé sur la
désinsertion professionnelle qui le
signale et ce malgré mais c'est pas
toujours possible l'obligation de
reclassement à la charge de l'employeur
ils s'en suit alors pour le salarié une
perte durable d'emploi qui est d'autant
plus grande pour les seniors
donc voilà je suis pas bien merci
ensuite le 258 et le 259 tombent puisque
aucun des signataires n'est présent
le
3732 monsieur Ferny oui merci monsieur
le Président
les femmes sont particulièrement
victimes on l'a dit des inégalités
salariales qui se creusent au fil du
temps les inégalités liées aux gens
s'ajoutant aux problèmes liés à l'âge le
montant moyen des pensions de retraite
en est d'ailleurs le reflet donc
l'introduction d'un indicateur sur le
genre dans l'index senior permettrait
ainsi de contribuer à ce que les
entreprises publient une manière
distincte les chiffres relatifs à
l'emploi des femmes seniors de ceux des
hommes seniors afin de constater plus
nettement les inégalités de gens en fin
de carrière constater plus nettement
pour permettre d'y mieux remédier telle
est l'objet de cette amendement
merci ensuite le 2480 monsieur broyer
le président toujours au nom de mon
collègue Thomas dessus cet amendement
vise en fait à garantir le fait que dans
l'index senior il y est bien des
indicateurs spécifiques aux
travailleuses et aux travailleurs
seniors qui occupent des emplois
d'employés si la situation des seniors
sur le marché du travail est déplorable
ce n'est peut-être pas la peine de le
répéter puisque ça a beaucoup été dit
qu'elle soit 60 ans près d'une personne
sur trois n'était ni en emploi ni à la
retraite la majorité d'entre elles en
situation de l'invalidité de RSE ou de
chômage et donc de précarité mais il y a
des difficultés particulières qui
concernent les personnes qui sont dans
la situation d'employés et notamment les
conditions de travail qui peuvent aussi
être désastreuses ce à quoi on pense
moins souvent que pour d'autres métiers
durée dans l'emploi est plus difficile
pour les personnes les plus précaires
qui exercent des emplois à forte
pénibilité à titre d'exemple 20% des
infirmières finissent en invalidité à la
fin de leur carrière
à cause de la pression psychologique
notamment et surtout du rythme imposé
par le travail qui les empêche d'avoir
une carrière complète l'index senior tel
qu'il est présenté dans ce texte ne peut
évidemment pas résoudre les problèmes
inhérents à l'emploi des seniors et à
leurs conditions de travail c'est il
pourrait rester un pansement sur une
jambe de bois si nous ne le nourrissons
pas à défaut d'un dispositif ambitieux
nous proposons de l'améliorer notamment
en ce qui concerne ces indicateurs et de
préciser dans le texte que la liste des
indicateurs de l'index seniors ainsi que
leur métier de leur méthode de calcul
seront fixées par des craies ce qui
offre peu de garantie mais qui les
fondamental que ça examine les
conditions de travail des seniors avec
des indicateurs spécifiques pour les
seniors occupants un emploi d'employés
ensuite le 2755 madame Poumirol oui
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
monde du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain vise à garantir que ces
index seniors contiennent au moins
indicateurs spécifiques aux travailleurs
occupants en emploi d'ouvriers bien sûr
ce sont des indicateurs portant
essentiellement sur la qualité de vie au
travail les aménagements de poste les
aménagements d'horaires tout cela pour
éviter les maladies professionnelles ou
les accidents de travail qui sont plus
importants bien sûr au-delà de 60 ans et
les ouvriers sont aussi ceux qui ont les
facteurs de pénibilité les plus
importants et dont il faut tenir compte
merci ensuite le 32
3200 5 pardon madame poncer mon jeu
nous souhaitons alors on a parlé des
employés mais que la liste effectivement
contiennent des indicateurs spécifiques
au travailleur seniors
occupants un emploi d'ouvriers je
voudrais dire en préalable que tous les
travailleurs sont touchés de façon
brutale par cette par cette réforme mais
effectivement de façon différenciée plus
pour les femmes plus pour les ouvriers
plus pour les employés donc il est
important effectivement de d'avoir cet
indicateur spécifique aux travailleurs
seniors occupants un emploi d'ouvriers
les ouvriers seront les premiers touchés
par cette réforme brutale inégalitaire
il est nécessaire de rappeler que selon
l'Insee 10 à 11 ans selon les
statistiques d'écart d'espérance de vie
sans incapacité dit en bonne santé c'est
pas pour les hommes les ouvriers et les
hommes les ouvriers et les cadres comme
dans une moindre mesure effectivement
pour les femmes alors selon la dernière
étude de la DARES le service
statistiques du travail tout le monde
connaît le taux d'emploi des seniors
après 60 ans s'effondre seulement 35%
bon ça a été dit je peux sauter
mais les ouvriers quand même par rapport
à ça 61 ans ce n'est pas par hasard si
il n'y a plus que 28 % en emploi alors
que pour les cadres à 61 ans il y a 61%
des cadres mais je tiens à dire quand
même que les cadres à 13% sont aussi
touchés par le phénomène à ces âges là
61 ans des personnes n'y en emploi ni en
retraite donc 13% des cases sont dans ce
sas de précarité c'est pour ça que vous
avez toutes les organisations syndicales
y compris celles qui représente les
catégories cadres
bon ben si je n'ai plus de temps donc je
vais m'arrêter là et je vous invite à
lire les autres points qui sont dans
l'objet
bien merci
le 3109 présenté par le Marie Pierre de
la Gontrie
bon alors qui le défend là monsieur a
souligne
[Musique]
mais moi j'étais là alors Monsieur
j'étais dans l'hémicycle mais pas à ma
place classique
et bien de toute façon ça va ça va pas
être une défense très longue comme j'en
ai l'habitude cet amendement visa
garantir que l'index senior contiennent
au moins des indicateurs spécifiques aux
travailleurs en situation de handicap je
vais y revenir à travers plusieurs
amendements mais cet indicateur
spécifique et très important si l'on
veut parler
de ces personnes en situation
particulière y compris par rapport à la
retraite
merci le 4183 qu'il présente dans le
groupe communiste madame gréaume
alors merci monsieur le Président les
seniors ne sont pas égaux devant la
précarité selon le rapport du corps à
l'âge de 62 ans près de 16,7% des
personnes se sont insignies en emploi ni
à la retraite entre la cessation
définitive d'activité et la retraite les
quarts est en moyenne de deux années
parmi ces grands oubliés 3% sont au
chômage et 13,7% en inactivité si bien
qu'il ne dépendent que du RSA ou d'une
pension d'invalidité ou du revenu
d'accroix l'un des grands arguments de
notre Arco rapporteur doit nous dans son
rapport c'est que le taux d'emploi
connaît une hausse rapide autour des
années 2010 en passant de
40,5%, fin 2010 à 47,1% fin 2013 les
réformes de retraite successives ont
contribué à augmenter le taux d'emploi
des 55 64 ans oui nous vous accordons
que le taux d'emploi augmenté de de
vapoint pour les 60 et 61 ans
mais je cite aux prix social élevé d'un
allongement du sas de précarité et on en
revient précisément à notre amendement
sur les conséquences d'une réforme des
retraites sur leur poids des seniors les
ouvriers ont payé un lourd tribu si bien
que le taux de ceux ni en emploi ni en
retraite a augmenté de 16 points par
conséquent 2019 les ouvriers à 61 ans
sont plus souvent ni en emploi ni en
retraites cette situation concerne 35%
d'entre eux les conséquences sont
lourdes selon l'adresse le taux de
pauvreté de ces personnes et de 32%
contre 7% pour ceux en emploi ou à la
retraite toutes les données statistiques
le démontre vos arguments ne sont pas
recevables je vous le dis tranquillement
nous vous appelons solennellement
retirer ce projet de loi en posant au
préalable la question du travail plutôt
que de vous acharner sur les droits à la
retraite merci
merci ensuite madame ponce le 3123 et
ensuite vous en avez plusieurs
d'ailleurs donc vous pouvez peut-être
les présenter
prenons le temps nécessaire
merci alors il s'agit là on revient un
petit peu au licenciement pour
inaptitude mais de les préciser pour les
salariés de plus de 50 ans et sur les
cinq dernières années en effet on y
reviendra beaucoup les contraintes et
des risques physiques se sont fortement
accrues depuis 30 ans l'adresse a mesuré
ainsi l'évolution sur 30 ans
en partant de 1984 et les dernières
statistiques c'est 2016
l'adresse dit que l'exposition à moins
trois contraintes physiques
éventuellement je pourrais vous le dire
lesquels concerne 34% des salariés dans
la dernière date il n'était que 12 pour
cent en fait
tous les indicateurs vont être
multipliés sur cette période par trois
voir par 4 pour les ouvriers et les
employés c'est pas 34% on en parlait à
l'instant c'est c'est 63% qui sont
concernés par cette exposition à trois
risques pour les ouvriers qualifiés ont
un peu moins mais guerres vous voyez
60,8%. 13% des employés étaient exposés
au moins trois contraintes ils sont 46,9
ça a été multiplié par presque 4
l'intensification du travail touche donc
particulièrement les salariés les plus
âgés et d'ailleurs
l'Observatoire Everest avait posé une
question à savoir demander aux ouvriers
à 60 ans comment ils envisageaient
la possibilité de travailler deux ans
supplémentaires et bien la moitié des
ouvriers des employés doutent que leur
état de santé leur permettent à
l'horizon de deux ans de leur travail
actuel alors on nous parle de
reconversion à 60 ans pour être on va
arrêter peut-être le cynisme et je
propose qu'on refasse cette évaluation
et qu'on leur demande maintenant à 60
ans s'il se voit travailler 4 ans de
plus alors c'est pas la moitié que vous
allez avoir bon j'en ai fini pour le
premier amendement je passe au second
monsieur le Président si vous permettez
c'est un peu la même chose mais il y a
il n'y a pas que les contraintes
physiques qui effectivement touche
massivement je l'ai dit les ouvriers les
employés il y a aussi les contraintes de
rythme et dans les contraintes de rythme
vous allez trouver la flambée en France
mais aussi en Europe il est vrai des
risques psychosociaux et là être exposé
à trois contraintes de rythme ça
concerne des hormones un tiers des
salariés ils étaient quasi inexistants
30 ans avant ils étaient à 6%. vous
voyez et ça concerne pas seulement les
cadres là encore ça concerne massivement
les câbles par rapport à l'évolution
mais aussi 53% des ouvriers qualifiés
soit 6 fois plus que 30 ans auparavant
qu'est-ce que c'est ces rythmes c'est
effectivement ces contraintes
temporelles ou ces contraintes de rides
c'est de ne pas pouvoir quitter son
emploi des yeux aujourd'hui 43% des
salariés sont sous cette contrainte
avoir un rythme de travail imposé par un
contrôle ou un contrôle humain ou un
suivi informatisé concerne un tiers des
personnes et tous ces indicateurs
d'intensité soit physique soit de
contraintes par le rythme et bien
effectivement explose il y en a une
autre qui est intéressante c'est
l'imposition de normes de production à
satisfaire en une journée là et là les
cadres aussi sont touchées 21% des
salariés effectivement ont une
contrainte temporaire sur la journée et
plus grave quand même vous en avez quand
même
non maintenant c'est 48% excusez moi
c'était 21% donc ils ont été multipliés
et ce qui a été multiplié aussi c'est
l'imposition de normes de production
insatisfaire
une heure qui est passé de 5% à 29%.
voilà toute cette intensification du
travail des contraintes d'origine ce qui
nous a conduit à dire qu'avant de
prolonger de 60 à 62 et à 64 il faut
changer le travail bien évidemment
donc je continue donc j'en suis sur le
troisième le troisième
alors c'est là c'est la publication des
indicateurs relatifs à l'emploi des
seigneurs en distinguant alors là par
genre leur sexe ainsi que les actions
mises en œuvre pour favoriser l'emploi
au sein des entreprises
bon là c'est voilà je peux encore vous
assommer peut-être de enfin mais je
pourrais et nous y reviendrons parce que
quand même vous voyez ça fait le lien
avec les régimes spéciaux quand on nous
dit mais ils vont passer dans le C2P
c'est pas gênant je le répète le C2P
c'est deux ans maximum de départ
anticipé et quand on passe à 64 ans
c'est 62 donc les fameux ouvriers les
50% qui disaient à 60 ans qui pourront
pas aller à 62 vous voyez
là si on leur donne deux ans ça sera 62
hein en toute état de cause dans le
meilleur des cas
madame poncer vous en avez encore un
ensuite parce qu'il y a deux amendements
identiques qui suivent
dont l'un est présentée par vous
supprimer la Linéa 7 dans ce cas-là non
c'est ça que vous 1178
bah il supprimait la possibilité laisser
un accord de branche de déroger aux
indicateurs et méthodes de calcul
déterminés par des craies et relatifs à
l'emploi des seniors
bah oui moi je suis assez pour la
hiérarchie des sources donc
effectivement je pense qu'il faut les
branches c'est bien mais elles doivent
être plus favorables je rappelle plus
favorable que le niveau supérieur qui
est le cadre légal qui lui-même doit
respecter des règles européennes donc
des indicateurs
définis clair comme des méthodes de
calcul permettent des analyses
intéressantes et y compris de façon
comparative et je pense qu'il n'est pas
normal de risquer de les faire
disparaître lors de discussions de
branches parce que ces données sont
précieuses
elles sont comme elles doivent être
comme une à toutes les branches qui
permettent une analyse globale pour les
politiques publiques et pour changer le
travail pour la prochaine loi ça aidera
ça éclairera le gouvernement il faut des
critères communs à l'échelle d'une
société tout entière par contre bien sûr
la branche peut ajouter des indicateurs
pour tenir compte de sa spécificité mais
je pense qu'il faut pas qu'elle en
retire voilà je te remercie
merci Madame concemont donc maintenant
amendement identique au dernier que vous
avez présenté le 4186
le groupe communiste
4100 non non on va les exposer
tranquillement
allez-y
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement de bon sens a reçu un avis
défavorable la commission alors qu'il
souhaite simplement assurer une clause
de non-régression sur les indicateurs
mesurés par l'emploi des seniors cet
amendement est l'occasion de revenir sur
l'anthologie de cet article qui
prévoyait comme pour faire croire que
les marges de négociation étaient
possibles que l'index senior ne
s'applique qu'aux entreprises de plus de
1000 salariés cette obligation de
publication n'aurait concernée que 0,15
des entreprises 6040 au total seulement
un peu plus de la moitié des salariés du
pays auraient été couvertes par cette
disposition les autres leur sort
n'intéressaient pas a priori le
Gouvernement l'Assemblée nationale avait
justement avant de rejeter l'article
abaisser le seuil de publication à 50
salariés je vous remercie
ensuite madame Ferré le
2784 merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement donc au concerne la Linéa 7
où nous proposons de remplacer le mot
déterminé par le mot enrichir dans la
phrase une convention en accord de
branche étendue peut déterminer la liste
des indicateurs cet amendement vise
effectivement à ne pas laisser la
possibilité à la branche d'établir des
indicateurs sur l'emploi des seniors
moins 10 ans que le degré qui sera pris
à cet effet
merci ensuite le 4189 madame a ponceau
poli
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement de repli du groupe CRCE en
tant s'assurer que par convention ou
lors d'un accord de branche étendu les
indicateurs retenus ne puissent être
inférieurs à ceux de la norme nationale
le cas échéant et même si nous le
regrettons définis par la loi
réglementaire je vous remercie merci
ensuite le 2483 monsieur Breuillet merci
monsieur le Président c'est toujours moi
pour mon collègue Thomas dessus la
réforme proposée par le gouvernement va
grandement affecter les seniors c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils seront avec les
salariés des millions dans la rue le 7
mars prochain le gouvernement fait un
pari qu'un recul de l'âge légal
augmentera mécaniquement le taux
d'emploi des seniors et j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure dans la discussion que
cette se fait était avéré dans les
réformes précédentes mais si ce fait est
partiellement avéré ce qui est également
c'est que les seniors les plus éloignés
de l'emploi ne sont pas miraculeusement
embauché après la réforme et à chaque
réforme de décalage de l'âge légal du
départ en retraite nous avons constaté
un pic de rupture de contrat de
travailleuses et de travailleurs seniors
des seniors sont ainsi licenciés ou
placardisés sans raison basculant le
plus souvent dans la précarité on a
évoqué 100.000 pour la réforme de 2010
le texte je fais cours le texte de
l'article 2 renvoie un décret le soin de
fixé la liste des indicateurs de cet
index ainsi que leur méthode de calcul
or cet article laisse également la
possibilité à la négociation collective
ce qui est une bonne chose mais de
branches d'adapter ces indicateurs si
l'adaptation de l'index peut permettre
une meilleure prise en compte de chaque
milieu professionnel la rédaction
actuelle de l'article pourrait être
dommageable il y a un risque de
dégradation excusez-moi
des mesures de l'emploi des seniors
qu'il convient d'encadrer c'est pourquoi
par cette amendement nous demandons à ce
que toute nouvelle modification des
indicateurs par accord de branche ou
conventions n'entraîne pas une
dévalorisation des indicateurs
déterminés par décret
merci ensuite le 3734 et vous en avez
plusieurs monsieur Ferney qui se suivent
mais commencez par le 3734 allez-y
3734 donc l'index senior en l'état
risque fort de ne pas permettre de réel
changement de comportement des
entreprises faisant preuve d'une
discrimination dans l'emploi des seniors
pour le rendre plus ambitieux le présent
amendement
propose que pour les entreprises qui ont
conclu un accord de branche ou une
convention relative à la définition des
indicateurs mentionnés le bénéfice des
dispositifs généraux de réduction ou
d'exonération de cotisation sociale soit
conditionnée à une mise en place
effective et au respect des indicateurs
de l'index seniors le suivant le tableau
ne montre pas c'est le
3735 c'est un amende repli par rapport
au précédent puisque il s'agit d'un
moment presque identique sauf qu'il ne
concernerait que les entreprises de plus
de 300 salariés et je passe au suivant
si vous le permettez donc c'est le 736
et 373 mais le tableau est en panne
c'est pas grave c'est le 3736 donc et
nous interrompons encore et bien une
dernière fois cette séance qui se
poursuit autour de l'article 2 l'article
sur l'index senior qui est débattu
depuis le milieu de l'après-midi dans
l'hémicycle les prises de parole les
amendements de suppression et les
amendements tout court ce sont
multipliés aujourd'hui on va rejoindre
Audrey Audrey viettaz dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat Audrey pour faire un petit
bilan de cette journée il y a eu des
ambiances différentes ce matin et cet
après-midi oui la journée a été marquée
ce matin par une sorte de parenthèse
enchantée sur une question de société ça
partait d'une idée de certains
républicains qui ont proposé de
commencer à réfléchir à introduire une
dose de capitalisation dans notre
système de retraite la capitalisation
c'est quand les employés investissent
leur cotisations dans des fonds de
pension c'est très différent de notre
système actuel par répartition ou les
actifs financent la retraite des
retraités mais pour certains à droite
c'est inévitable si on veut préserver
notre système à gauche c'est impensable
c'est une mesure injuste écouter les
différents arguments
si comme vous comme nous nous sommes
attachés à ce que demain en France il
puisse y avoir des fonds souverains pour
que nos centres de décision ne partent
pas si nous voulons demain en France que
nous ayons de l'argent des Français pour
qu'on puisse investir précisément dans
la transition énergétique la transition
écologique il y aura pas d'autres moyens
c'est la souveraineté financière c'est
la souveraineté industrielle c'est là
qu'elle enjeu et on peut le faire sans
détricoter notre système est-ce que vous
pensez véritablement que les caissières
les aident à domicile les petits
smicards
non mais vous rigolez pas à sang dans la
capitalisation vous savez où ils sont
actuellement ils font la queue au Resto
du Coeur ils sont au Secours populaire
ils n'arrivent plus à payer leur
électricité
l'orgasme il pense tous les jours à se
nourrir mais oui monsieur c'est ça la
réalité de l'avion que toi peut-être pas
les mêmes en tous les cas vous irez dire
à tous ces gens qu'il faut qu'ils
capitalise parce que finalement vous
voulez leur enlever le régime par
répartition vous le voyez de grands
moments de débat entre la gauche et la
droite l'amendement du sénateur Rubson a
été adopté un peu à la surprise contre
la vie de la Commission et du
gouvernement c'est l'un des apports du
Sénat aujourd'hui le Sénat décide avec
un rapport soit réalisé pour voir
comment on peut introduire une dose de
capitalisation dans notre régime une
matinée marquée par des débats de fonds
dont la gauche s'est félicitée elle
demandait à débattre avec la droite
depuis le début de l'examen du texte
ensuite il a été question de l'article
indice intégré par le gouvernement entre
rassembler le Sénat qui a pour but
d'étudier la possibilité d'un retrait
d'un système de retraite universel non
sans rappeler la réforme de 2019 qui a
été avortée et qui avait causé de
grandes manifestations écoutez la
réaction de la gauche à ce sujet
le considérer que ainsi le gouvernement
revient par le fenêtre avec cet article
alors que les Français avaient
massivement rejetés en 2019 le projet
porté par le gouvernement de l'époque et
qui a obligé ainsi avec ce rejet massif
obligé le président de la République à
retirer son texte alors aujourd'hui il
nous faisons le constat que non
seulement le gouvernement ne veut rien
entendre sans tête encore et toujours
mais aussi d'une certaine façon ça a été
dévoilé ou révéler par notre collègue
trompe à nouveau les Français parce que
avec ce rapport et bien cela peut
laisser penser que demain après-demain
c'est un autre système de retraite qui
pourrait être mis en œuvre
le Sénat a rejeté cet article et depuis
le milieu d'après-midi nous en sommes à
l'article 2 un article important sur
l'index senior la même dynamique est
revenue cette fois la gauche amande
défend ses amendements la droite reste
mutique la gauche qui essaye de
temporiser avec un objectif ne pas
étudier l'article 7 sur l'allongement de
l'âge de des départs avant la grande
journée de mobilisation de mardi merci
beaucoup Audrey pour toutes ces
explications et pour nous avoir
accompagné tout au long de cette journée
dans l'hémicycle pour nous faire vivre
la réforme des retraites on se quitte
dans quelques instants mais on se
retrouve demain des 10 heures à 100%
Sénat spécial retraite continue avec
notamment Alexandre Poussard et Quentin
Calmet qui seront à nos place
respectives je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée sur Public Sénat n'hésitez
pas à aller sur notre site publicena.fr
pour lire tous les décryptages sur cette
réforme et bien plus encore très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]
les questions au Gouvernement c'est le
temps fort de la semaine au Sénat chaque
mercredi les sénateurs interpellent les
ministres dans l'hémicycle on vous fait
suivre cette séance en direct et en
exclusivité et avancer on se retrouve en
plateau pour débattre des grands thèmes
du moment et après la séance on débrief
avec nos journalistes aux quatre coins
du Sénat et de nombreux invités
rendez-vous mercredi à 14h sur Public
Sénat